hello everyone we'll be starting with
the research symposium in 12 months
thank you for joining
i would like to welcome those who have
just joined
the session
we'll be starting in more 10 minutes and
in the meantime you can introduce
yourself in the chat box and let us know
about your
education or research background thank
you
a very warm good morning good afternoon
or good evening in whichever part of the
world you are i would like to welcome
you all to the much awaited event of the
year omics research symposium
before we get started today i would like
to introduce omixlogic
to begin we must ask what is
bioinformatics
it is the development implementation and
usage of methods and software tools for
understanding biological data
bioinformatics has practical
applications in healthcare agriculture
and mitigating climate change
as this field progresses bioinformatics
poses several challenges for both
students trying to learn it and faculty
trying to teach it
in this presentation i will explain the
current challenges and limitations in
bioinformatics describe how we aim to
address these challenges with the omics
logic portal
describe bloom's taxonomy for learning
progression and how it can be used in
bioinformatics coursework
explore the omixlogic portal and how it
utilizes gnomes taxonomy in structuring
its course pipelines and projects and
finally describes several outcomes of
the omics logic portal
i'm sunali khari and i'm the omix logic
community manager i'm responsible for
daily interaction with thousands of
users that are a part of our
bioinformatics community which is
managed by pine biot
over the several years we have had the
privilege of working with a number of
organizations
developing a training program for
research-oriented students faculty and
improvising bioinformatics making this
discipline accessible to thousands of
students and culture around the world
omics logic research based training
programs are a result of close
collaboration between pain biotech and
numerous academic institutions that have
participated in content evaluation
curriculum review and project design
so what are some of the challenges that
the field of bioinformatics is currently
facing
to begin this field is constantly
growing and developing new tech and
software to improve processing time and
power
the data sets that are analyzed are
usually very large and they take immense
amounts of computing power and memory
that many personal computers do not have
also despite being publicly available
data are also usually complex to access
and coding knowledge is usually required
to do so
similarly analysis pipelines and
programs require coding knowledge that
many biologists do not have
in a university setting students have
the opportunity to learn the
bioinformatics project
of designing and implementing a project
but do not receive practical or hands-on
experience with the full workflow
due to the faces due to the limitations
that i just mentioned
similarly faculty faces challenges with
being able to cover a diverse range of
topics if they are specialized in a
certain area of bioinformatics or if
they are unfamiliar with bioinformatics
in general for example a professor whose
research focuses on oncogene expression
might not know much about the meta
genomics or sea water
to overcome these challenges the omics
logic portal was developed this program
aims to standardize organize and
systemize bioinformatics training in
order to make these analysis usable for
any biologist or clinician
there are some traditional problems with
the standardization of bioinformatics
coursework
which includes materials for courses
that are usually developed in-house
taught sporadically and are rarely
updated
the omixlogic portal introduces new
material that keeps up with new
technology these courses need to be
organized because the challenge is to
combine several different topics
together the flow and transitions
between subject needs to be developed
this is addressed at comics logic
through introductory material which is
being woven throughout the courses
the last challenge we face is
systematization
how can you know that someone is stuck
and needs help or allow someone to run
forward to address this omixlogic uses
standardized modules and interactive
sessions beginning with mastering
terminology and concepts to implementing
these concepts with real data sets in a
project based approach
here is an overview of the learning
process in order to create a path of
skill development omixlogic employs the
bloom's taxonomy levels of learning
this approach starts with the basics
where students recalls facts and
terminologies and are able to repeat and
memorize the material with this base the
learning builds to conceptual knowledge
being able to understand concepts and
apply information to new situations
the students will then be able to
analyze data by drawing connections and
evaluate when to use certain methods
this leads them to the highest level of
learning the ability to design and
create original work
so how do omixologic resources help
advance bioinformatics teaching
omixlogic is a portal for practical and
theoretical learning of bioinformatics
composed of courses designed to take you
through the theoretical knowledge
omixlogic takes a combination of
training modules data analysis tools
curated project datasets and interactive
sessions with mentors to give a student
a clear part of the bloom's taxonomy
pyramid
no matter what the user's initial
experience with bioinformatics is comics
logic is a useful tool for gaining a
baseline knowledge of the theory behind
bioinformatics analysis of large
datasets an introduction to basic boring
languages like art and python are
beginning a data analysis project
these six courses were taken from the
core omixlogic curriculum which is
available online
beginning with an introduction to
application of bioinformatics and an
overview of data types the student is
able to learn terminology and factual
knowledge to build upon
from there genomics translatorics
metagenomics epigenomics and data
science are introduced
each course starts with important terms
and concepts and then introduces case
studies and pipelines related to each
one
this allows the students to gain the
conceptual knowledge in order to begin
their own projects
omics logic expands upon its basic
curriculum with specialization track
projects
bioinformatics methods are best learned
in the context of real case studies
prepared by our network of mentors and
collaborators that illustrate how
various bioinformatics methods and omix
data types are used in current research
in medicine biotechnology agriculture
and even astrobiology
the projects are prepared by taking
publicly available datasets and using
them to explore and understand both the
research challenge and the analysis fact
to extract meaningful insights from
complex comics data
in this symposium we will hear from
speakers from different domains of life
sciences
talking about relevance of omics
of omix technologies advancements in
biomedical research and also we'll hear
about machine learning view of
multi-omics integration
what we will discuss today and
throughout is a result of hard work by
amazing team led by company co-founders
dr alfred trobo who comes from a medical
background has an extensive expertise in
oncology immunology and biochemistry of
information and has been recognized
internationally for his generous support
of many research projects and
initiatives that support data science
training and applications in medicine
dr ewnet brodsky is the director of
trouble bioinformatics research center
at the university of haifa and is an
expert in bioinformatics and
biostatistics
he has numerous publications in
mathematics and bioinformatics and over
uh his course of his career he has
developed multiple novel algorithmic
approaches to biomedical data analysis
under his leadership the trauber
research center started collaborations
with research teams at such universities
as the university of california san
francisco institute pasture
tulane university and many others where
research labs are working on
cutting-edge research projects studying
viral and bacterial infections and
designing novel drugs and vaccines to
treat and prevent infections diseases
the rest of the team includes experts in
bioinformatics computer science and
training some of our team members will
be presenting to me as well
to give students the options for
analyzing a given data set
code dependent paths or port independent
paths these data sets and associated
publications can be used in several ways
you can learn bioinformatics without any
coding at all
for that in each project we explain the
analysis pipelines on the user friendly
t by info platform for big data analysis
you can also learn the scripts behind
many of the steps learning to wrangle
clean visualize and analyze data in your
own analysis
finally you can hear about the projects
and their research applications in our
mental guided programs where experts
share their experience and support
research projects developed by you
here is an example of the code
independent pipeline
the pipeline builder interface on the
t-bioinfo platform is a color-coded
pipeline that helps establish a logical
connection between the technical names
of data analysis methods and the logical
steps needed to build the full pipeline
data is put in a as an input file
and the analysis can be chosen based off
on the type of research
each analysis is separated into three
columns blue for pre-processing red for
mapping and green for quantification
each time you click a button a pop-up
will contain additional information
useful for building the pipeline the
ease of the color-coded buttons allow
programs to be run without any coding
knowledge interactive outputs allow easy
visualization of the data several demo
pipelines with real data sets are
available
for students to practice the workflow
including demos on genomic variant
calling of cancer cell lines 16 as
amplicon analysis on diet and its
analysis on the microbiome and a
pipeline for examining our phytogenetic
analysis of ebola virus
to answer your curiosity about the g
biology platform we have among us
researchers for troubled bioinformatics
research center who will highlight few
areas of analysis available on the
server dr julia pano who will talk about
analysis of bulk and single cell
transcriptomics data on the tbi info
platform and dr elizabeth
will talk about metagenomics data on the
t by info platform
after using the t bioinfo platform to
visualize the pipelines and practice
analyzing students are then able to take
their theoretical knowledge the remember
and understand levels of loops and apply
that in a project the apply analyze and
evaluate levels of groups then check
their comprehension with levels and
batches certificates of completion and
test
similarly faculty should be able to
assign the homicide portal to their
students with an understanding that it
will give them holistic understanding
and comprehensive knowledge of
bioinformatics beginning with bytes and
molecules and onto designing their own
question based project
omixlogic employs a hybrid approach
combining learning and research to
ensure that students are billing off of
the first level of bloom's taxonomy
omics logic tracks progress with
activities like pipelines coding and
literature reviews quizzes on topics key
terms and important questions and covers
a broad range of topics like biomedical
research biotechnology and agriculture
their students are able to continue
their knowledge base with a research
assessment making sure they are able to
understand methods challenges and
results as well as being able to
comprehend primary research literature
and recreate the methodology
they should also be able to ask
questions based on data exploration this
leads to the ability of to encounter
errors in their analysis apply
theoretical knowledge of why those
errors are occurring and find a solution
bioinformatics combines life science
terms with data science skills which
allows researchers to answer life
science questions with reproducible data
analysis methods
logic is proud to collaborate with many
diverse programs across the globe we
also work with over 15 000 students at
community colleges like glendale
community college
top-tier universities like georgetown
university as well as 20 universities
around the world
we are pleased to have among us
researchers from our partner
universities and institutions who will
enlighten us with their talks on
different topics relevant to any student
or researcher
from knowing about technology and soft
skills uh for industry skill sets the
missing link between academia and
industry to understanding genotypic data
personalized therapies for cancer
patients and hierarchical patient models
in this presentation i explained the
current challenges and limitations in
bioinformatics
i described how we aim to address these
challenges with the omixlogic platform
we discussed bloom's taxonomy for
learning progression and how it can be
used in bioinformatics coursework
we also explored the omixlogic program
and how it utilizes bloom's taxonomy in
structuring in scores
pipelines and projects and finding this
destroyed several outcomes of the
omixlogic program
want to know how to get started the
omixlogic portal is easy and free for
anyone to register with many courses
and online mental guided training
programs in the field of omics that
includes genomics transcriptomics single
cell transcriptomics metagenomics and
epigenomics
also you will find programs in the field
of bioinformatics
structural biology infectious diseases
and procession medicine
these programs are available all around
the ear and you can get started with
your specialized training anytime at
your own convenience
once you have a specialized training
then you can work on an independent
research project
again under mental guidance on different
specialization tracks which includes the
analysis of data types
you learnt in the training program these
specialization tracks include oncology
infectious diseases precision medicine
neuroscience data science for biomedical
data analysis metabolic disorders space
omics agriculture and comprehensive
training on omix data analysis
throughout the year various students and
researchers joined comics research
fellowship program and work on their
research projects to either gain new
skill sets or to complete their college
recitation
or for a publication to add to their
achievements
comics research symposium will provide a
stage to such research fellows to
present their innovative research
projects
also all the research projects will get
a feedback from our panel of judges
the omics logic training has been
completed by over 24 000 participants
from 187 countries in over 500 workshops
and due to this fast growth our team is
now working with local and recent
coordinators that are helping refine the
local program logistics and leverage our
online training resources adapting them
to the needs of students and researchers
around the world
as a result we have acquired
professional certification to offer our
curriculum and support research projects
using our omics logic project based
curriculum and here are some amazing
stats from an year-long training
programs that were conducted by us
the symposium is divided in three parts
where we listen to speakers from asia
first
then africa and finally the americas
so to begin with an introduction to
omixlogic asia i would like to call upon
stage dr mohit mazumna
dr mohad mazundar is an experienced
bioinformatician
with multiple publications in peer
review journals he has been developing
collaborations with universities as a
mentor and project lead for omixology
training and research fellowship
over to you dr mohit
thank you sunalika
i think we are running a little ahead of
the time but
let me start by
thanking you all and it's great to see
you all here today with us
so uh this symposium is extremely
important for us and i hope you all are
as excited
as we are to hear about these cutting
edge approaches in life sciences and
also omics space
we will learn about these challenges not
just from our team but from experts who
have spent their lives struggling with
these challenges and more importantly
coming with coming up with these great
solutions
also it is great to see a much broader
appreciation of data in life science
domain as well as a great excitement
about this potential impact of
bioinformatics on areas touching the
lives of everyone for example medicine
vaccine design genomic surveillance and
even space travel
so in this presentation i will explain
our initiatives and highlight the
partnerships and collaborations for
omics logic bioinformatics and data
science training research in asia and
upcoming expert sessions and discussions
on day one of this omics logic
fall research symposium
so let me start
by taking this opportunity to briefly
introduce myself and our team
since 2019 we have launched omics logic
in india with initial collaborations at
several universities where we piloted
our training and worked with faculty to
develop programs that addresses the
major gaps in bioinformatics education
so since then we have been working with
thousands of students from our partner
universities who are going through this
training and working on projects so we
will be discussing that so working in
project work and faculty who are
interested to utilize this collaborative
research platform to incorporate
bioinformatics or project based
bioinformatics and data science
curriculums so tell you to tell you a
little bit more about this growth and
about our collaborations so we have been
able to work with a lot of students and
that's why it has been a thrilling
journey and this experience has enabled
us to work on variety of challenges that
comes
with the educational training as well as
the translational aspect and the
translational research so with the
agenda to bring awareness about
data-driven healthcare research our team
is reaching out to
sorry are reaching out to universities
to make bioinformatics and high quality
data-driven research accessible to
everyone so this engagement has helped
also helped us to collect a lot of this
data and improve on our learning models
so after many programs coordinated with
universities thousands of students
across india
we saw that there is a gap there is a
gap in skills there is a gap that
student
help effectively could integrate into
their research project thinking
critically about the data applying
appropriate methods to the right data
these are some of the gaps which are
quite evident
which we were able to find out and
propose solutions to so in this
presentation i'll i'll be taking you
through those uh through those case
studies and also the solutions that we
have got and the innovation that we were
able to bring into this
so um every student we started with this
realization and with this goal that
every student needs to be enabled with
data skills and analysis logic to
succeed in their research to succeed in
their academia excel in their career and
to be ready for the world of data we now
live in so schools universities and
colleges they needed to be equipped to
help faculty and students learn and use
data now
this is a big task
and hence it is a big task on our hand
that can only be accomplished or
achieved by a community not by only us
by a group of people group of
like-minded researchers group of
like-minded institutions and
universities and uh our appreciation
really to all of our academic partners
who have come forward and joined hands
to bring this awareness to bring these
new tools to bring this new technology
and an international standard to the
training and research that we are
providing in collaboration so
not only indust not only academia but
also industry and that that is why we
are here today to discuss what can our
educational system do about this gap how
do schools colleges and universities
prepare students for the future of
biotechnology and life science in
general so where biology we can see that
like this is quite evident because we
see that every day that biology is
acquiring the characteristics of data
science we are generating so much data
how can we merge data science and life
science together in a practical way that
is effective as well as inclusive how to
prepare students for successful research
and industry career give them skills and
experiences that help them navigate
their future so this is something that
we have learned and that that we have
experienced through our own own journey
as well as through the entire experience
of working with these thousands of
students and we are delighted and have
welcomed all our industry collaborators
those have really contributed in this in
mentorship in industry translation
transition and soft skill development in
translational projects for expert omix
logic fellows internships and job
opportunities career guidance and
placements research opportunities and
also startups and hackathon hackathons
so there is a lot of contribution about
through industry through academia and we
are seeing these different components
here and there
so
during this entire symposium we will be
able to do one thing we will be able to
connect these components together and
see that how this could be a part of uh
it could be an ecosystem in itself
so to do to be able to do that that
brings me to this slide
where we would want to
uh make a
major announcement for our 2020 fall
semester and that announcement is the
launch of omixlogic partnership
university program and this this unique
or this program was developed by
contributions not only by the team but
subject matter experts from our
partnership partner universities and
research institutions that you just saw
on the previous slides
not only them but also thousands of
students who have completed the omics
logic training and have provided this
valuable feedback so this omixlogic
partnership is a unique opportunity for
universities and is a comprehensive and
a flexible program designed to help
students faculty and industry to succeed
in this age of data
so our homologic training is designed to
make complex topics like bioinformatics
machine learning
and system medicine easy to incorporate
into existing curricula and help
students and faculty transition to the
data driven research projects where
bioinformatics curriculum curriculums
are designed based on the need and the
level of participants focusing on the
personalized level of training
personalized level of
help that
many of the students require or many of
us required to get the best outcome to
work on and to be able to apply uh
bioinformatics data science biomedical
data science and some of those topics to
so uh we prepared this uh very unique
curriculum along with our partners which
is now available for anyone any
university to opt for free uh is to uh
use these topics which are not usually
are the part of their curriculum so the
omixlogic training again is a
personalized training and research
experience that enables participants to
develop critical scientific thinking
utilizing modern bioinformatics and data
science practices on industry relevant
problems so the sessions that we have
designed they introduce statistical
methods visualization introduction to
popular machine learning techniques for
omix data analysis participants do learn
about public data repositories and
various file formats that are used in
bioinformatics for storing and
efficiently processing omics data so uh
as i was discussing all of this to you i
think the best way to do this is through
a
practical experience and that practical
experience is the case study that i
wanted to discuss with all of you today
so
a memorandum of understanding an mou was
signed between mit university uttar
pradesh and pine biotech us for joint
research and training in the area of
areas of bioinformatics and data science
all right so this collaboration helped
us pilot the omixlogic research based
training on a diverse student cohorts
coming from a non-bioinformatics
background applying data science for
biological problems
now this could only again be possible
with the help of a team so the the
collaborative partnership
program or this partnership that we have
just launched enabled all our partners
to work uh work together while sharing
ideas while sharing research proposals
while sharing curriculums or curriculas
that are protected by the agreement
between these three organizations so the
first organization amity university
uttar pradesh pine biotech and our major
academic partner dobber bioinformatics
research center at the university of
haifa in israel so scientists from the
center are providing academic oversights
and guidance in curriculum preparation
development of current bioinformatics
analysis
on the
for platform as you have seen as a as
you we just uh uh did that uh saw that
sunalika discussing about that that
allows non-bioinformaticians to run
complex algorithms on large-scale
databases and uh
and the uh support team uh whom who have
been uh working relentless to help
students go through these different
stages of training uh uh
through um online and virtual as well as
on-site
support
now uh to be able to do this uh we would
ne we would be needing a
way to evaluate students evaluate their
journey so to learn about the progress
of student during the training and to
learn about the challenges as well as to
encourage students to move through these
different stages of training we
developed and utilized a point based
system that integrates bloom's level as
soon i was telling you and helped us
create a dynamic and a unique interface
ever in bioinformatics and a great
experience for the users now uh we have
the platform that could enable uh and
encourage students and now what we would
want is a pipeline to be able to help
students go through these different
stages that i've been talking about so
to do this uh one of the things and one
of the challenges or i could say the
next challenge for us was to develop the
right components get to get a meaningful
outcome from this training experience so
the reason the reason is that many
students and it's an experience working
with students from all around the globe
they need a soft landing into this field
of bioinformatics where they can get
introduced to the application of
bioinformatics through projects and gain
access to the community with mentorship
guidance and structure so these are some
of the components that are required at a
basic beginner level so we develop these
different stages and resources basic
training example projects and coding so
these are different stages you start
with the basic training you move to
example projects and you learn coding
and and then you practice to work on
projects by practicing on various data
sets and algorithms finally you are
ready to work on your own research
projects or a faculty driven research
projects a research project so that is
the pipeline that we prepared and
created uh to be able to
help students who are coming from
different uh backgrounds different
knowledge and different interests
now
uh uh in the next few slides uh i'll
discuss about the outcomes of the
partnership training program that
enables our team to meet face-to-face
face-to-face and addresses address gaps
and work together and find solutions to
the challenges and translate ideas into
actionable tasks and outcomes so uh this
is again an experience and this is one
of the
one of the pilot that shows it's a case
study that shows that how this route has
helped us develop these outcomes that
i'm going to show you in the next few
slides
so
as i was telling you about some of these
points integration of new ideas that is
very important
because of this opportunities
applicable of this
open source data and then
application of new technology in life
science and then you know kind of
becoming an expert to be able to
contribute to this ongoing scientific
advancements these are really exciting
uh exciting opportunities for students
for faculty who opted this field to
contribute actually for the human
well-being right so the omics logic pro
training had
was able to provide these opportunities
not only to the few but the entire
cohort of students and the
simplification with the simplification
and the integration of ngs and omix
technologies and algorithms through the
training
now
uh as i'm talking about integration
integration of next generation
sequencing on this technology data
science algorithms and that is one of
the focus of our company and uh and then
uh to be able to do this uh we were able
to work together with the faculty with
the with the administration and develop
curriculums that has industry insights
so we are looking at job opportunities
we are looking at what is that that
industry is looking into these
candidates or these students and then we
are trying to highlight that through the
curriculum and that is the industry
insight that we are bringing to the uh
to the curriculum of this
universities now uh the last component
of all of this the last component of all
of this is to
be like first you learn and then you
apply and then you do a research project
then you gain experience from a project
and to be able to work in a group learn
those soft skills communicate how to
communicate in a group and to you know
how to make a
meaningful way to showcase your research
do a presentation and do a publication
but after all of this what is that is
needed is the job opportunity or the
next opportunity that you are looking to
that could be a program that could be a
master's program that could be a phd
program or that could be a job
opportunity so finally to get job and
internship opportunity to build
excellent profiles on omixlogic portal
for recruiters and startups we
integrated uh this um
the omixlogic job opportunity port into
the portal and that helped us to uh
to the to guide students directly to the
related opportunity with the skills that
they are working on and gaining so
the partnership university program
as as discussed is to simplify the
training and make it accessible to
students from all background and not
only from all background but from all uh
demographies from low income countries
and from places where it is really
difficult to access uh technology access
infrastructure this is entirely online
and we are offering the basic training
which is the stage one of this pipeline
freely to the interested universities
who wants to pilot the training for
their students and uh to tell you about
the research aspect of all of this and
one of the major outcome is to be able
to work on thus the aspect of your doing
doing your own research and working on
your own research idea or how a faculty
can work on a faculty can propose their
research ideas and the students can
help with their skill sets to overcome
some of the challenges in in their own
research so one of the important aspect
of all of this is to be able to help
students gain those skill sets and to be
able to come up with uh complete a
project because many students and we
it's it's also us that we tend to start
many things and then to complete that
and to finish that and publish that it
takes a lot of time there are different
stages here this it gets complicated and
there's a lot of research and there is a
lot of literature review and
there are different aspects of of
research so uh to overcome these
challenges we developed this research
fellowship training where we were able
to help students
work from any remote area at any at
their convenient time working on
industry designed example projects that
we curated and then mentor guidance uh
with group projects that are from phd
and post doctoral level solution
providing phd and post doctoral level
solution so we have dr raghavendran and
we have a huge community here who are
helping us guide the students with their
independent research proposals and
integrating faculty ideas into a
research project now
the students who were able to
do that where
were the ones who benefited from this
and
also the the faculty who were able to uh
work with us collaboratively are also
some of those who have benefited from
this research work and now uh to tell
you about the
way this has moved from one uh one year
to another year and what are the
differences that we saw in this
by by students who have completed these
different topics are from coming from
one background in 2021 we see that there
is there was a lot of students from
b-tech biotechnology who joined the
program and completed the program they
were interested in oncology and
application of precision medicine they
applied a lot of genomics and
transcriptomics data analysis and worked
on different of research topics but by
2022 we saw that there has been more
applications there has been more
research areas there has been diverse
community of students who are joining
and working on their research projects
and these are all from
non-bioinformatics background these are
the students who have done uh who came
without any knowledge of coding without
any knowledge of you know
bioinformatics and they started from the
basic training and they went through the
pipeline where they
after doing after working from learning
about these different technologies
learning about this different
applications where this technology is
applied for example how genomics is
applied in precision medicine how a
transcriptomics data analysis is
utilized in uh oncology what are the
different
ways to look at the biomarkers in in uh
neurodegen degenerative diseases where
machine learning is mostly applied and
what kind of data it applies to so there
was a lot of specialization training
which was involved in this internship
period of the students which was also
from 45 days to 90 days to 160 day to
120 days to six months so we had this
challenge where students have different
timelines but we kind of created these
different modules through which we can
we can check their progress and see how
they are how they are moving from one
stage to another based on the timeline
they have registered to now the students
were able to complete some of these
projects that i am showing you in this
slide
so to highlight uh what the students
were able to achieve uh was one of the
one of the major outcomes so of this
research uh initiative of or this
collaborative initiative
where we have uh been able to record a
lot of this
data to be able to showcase or also the
students who were able to see this and
showcase their to their recruiters or to
their faculty and faculty can see their
progress so there is a progress link
associated with this training with every
student where we will if we where we've
been able to understand that what is the
level where the student is working on
what project he is doing or what uh what
kind of uh expertise the student is
developing which is also open to the
uh to the
community and look for
specific expertise in these students now
uh another benefit that uh the students
have been able to achieve through this
is to be able to work on a real project
now uh this is a new project a noble
project in the sense that the data
which we have looked into
and also the research problems that we
have looked looked into are specifically
designed with the help of the mentor and
there were a lot of discussion a lot of
research
literature review before opting for a
specific pathway of
to go for the
use of the tools and the technologies
and also the different visualizations
and
other reporting which is required to
complete a project so i mean for the
students uh going through this entire
process of completing a project doing
going through these different steps of
research and then to be able to uh do a
presentation and do a
do a presentation and get that
acknowledgement that and also which
actually helps them to build a better
cgpa an entire
mark entire growth that would be seen
through this project and also achieving
the brilliant results that they have
been able to do in a very short period
of time it was very rewarding and in
this in this in this entire symposium we
will have those opportunities to hear
from some of the students in our
upcoming session now uh these projects
and uh the focus is on different
specializations as we are discussing
about precision medicine we are
discussing about oncology so some
students
with their pis have very specific ideas
to do uh maybe landscaping of cancer
immunotherapy which is a very broad
topic now
when we are looking at it and when we
start working on it and if it's a
collaborative project then the chances
of completing that project is is very
high because not only one person but
different different
students working together with the help
of a pi and the help of the
mentors at pine biotech now all of these
projects are published on omixlogiclearn
and you are free to check out some of
these projects if you feel interested
and learn about these projects but this
omics symposium is also an opportunity
to learn from some of these experts who
have experience in this field and also
from these student examples that
examples that students have done so we
will have experts
next uh in this in this omics symposium
day one where we will be learning about
the relevance of omics so you saw that
how students have utilized different
omics technology and have completed a
project and we will be hearing from
doctors
about the relevance of bioinformatics in
omix and you will have those questions
ready and you can have those questions
ready that you have to
understand that how this is relevant in
studies or in understanding you know
some of these diseases that we see such
as the neurodegenerative diseases and
also at the same time here are some of
the links
that students have been able to work for
example transcriptomics analysis
that they did on finding out the
gene signatures regulating alzheimer's
diseases so looking at and working on
multi-dimensional data and applying
those algorithms such as principal
component analysis looking at the
gene expression and finding which are
the relevant and significant genes when
we are comparing two different states
and then looking at further doing the
downstream analysis leading to the
analysis of uh alzheimer's variant in
embryonic stem cell derived microglia so
this is a project that it's also an
example that you can take a look at so
again
this is these are some of the outcomes
of the student driven and or the faculty
driven fellowships where students have
been able to work on important topics
such as precision oncology we saw that
as an example we also saw um
the use of in in neuroscience now this
is an example of infectious diseases and
this is an example of surveillance of
sar scope to covet 19 variant of concern
from waste water samples based on the
ngs data and there's a recent article
that actually highlighted that how
important it is to do a genomic
surveillance and how important it is to
use the wastewater samples now this is a
practical experience what is happening
just happening in the industry just
happening in
that you see
around you and you have an opportunity
to work exactly on a similar research
use scientific tools and come up with
those
maybe find new insights find new
mutations those are some of the
opportunities that the faculty student
driven research fellowship was able to
provide to the students who worked with
us during this uh with this partnership
program with amity university which is
the case study that i'm showing
you all
to highlight what we have achieved in
the last six months
working with this different
different students and as an opportunity
as you all are interested here and i see
this great enthusiasm and a lot of new
uh new participants joining and really
happy who are joining for the first time
that we will start uh our presentations
from the experts and we will have we
will be learning from uh experts from
iit delhi where we will discuss about dr
ishan gupta where we will discuss about
the kovid 19 pandemic and
his research on this similarly we are
discussing the research that students
have been able to do while they are
using
this different types of data types for
example genetic and epigenetic basis so
genetic information epigenetic
information a multi-omics approach what
are these different approaches how do
you how do you learn about these
approaches and how do you apply this
into your own research or your you know
cv that you have learned this and
applied this so uh we have those
opportunities in today uh in today's
session where we will be learning about
the application of disease types complex
diseases use of multi-omics data from
experts who are going to be joining us
in and letting us know about their
research and uh what are the different
aspects that they have gone through
completing that research at the same
time yeah the students who have gone
through this entire
experience themselves will also get an
opportunity during the post
representation
uh poster presentation session which is
coming up and really excited to uh to to
look for we are looking forward to the
session where the students will get
opportunity and also for sessions such
as these where we are actually going to
learn from experts like dr anshu
bharathwaj uh to uh who who have
expertise and have been worked across
different institutions uh and a rich
experience in in bioinformatics and uh
understanding the genotypic phonetic
phenotypic correlations in complex
diseases and uh we will be we will be
getting those opportunities to learn
from experts and i hope all of you are
now excited to be a part of this um
these talks upcoming talks and have
questions and insights ready so that
we can discuss this for further now uh
uh after the
after we learn about this you know uh
first we started by learning about uh
kovin 19
and then we learned about then we will
be learning about the application of
omics technology in different type of in
alzheimer's and then we learn we will
learn about the complex diseases so what
we are learning here from one session to
another is also uh how the
use of bioinformatics uh which is which
is such an interdisciplinary subject and
with substantial and growing influence
so bioinformatics as you see that it has
a huge application it has huge
applications in in several of these
interdisciplinary subjects so what are
these subjects so health health is one
of such important topic another very
important topic is environmental
sciences and society and
which is utilized by scientists from
many diverse academic backgrounds so
education in bioinformatics therefore
necessitates effective development of
skills in interdisciplinary
collaboration it involves not only
skills but also communication ethics and
critical analysis of research so in
addition to practical and technical
skills insights from bioinformatics
training can additionally uh you know
inform
and uh that's what one of the that is
what one of the agendas for the today's
presentation that how this training and
collaboration and integration of
academia and industry who are working on
data science and artificial intelligence
and cutting-edge technologies
can be accessed and everyone is now has
that opportunity to be able to achieve
that and what are these these different
opportunities what are the different
tricks ticks tricks and uh
ways to be a part of this this is
something that we will be learning in
the academic panel discussion which is
happening which is going to be happening
at
after the after the three
keynote speakers uh discussion that uh
how we can transition from uh academia
and how we can learn and get
opportunities in academia and after that
we have the poster presentation session
which is planned at uh after the uh
after the academic session where the
students will get opportunity and will
be reviewed by these experts uh for best
technical and research project for
promising research direction and most
innovative innovative approach and i
would request also
maybe you just to share the final list
of posters who wait who were who got uh
who got to the next step and are now
ready to be evaluated by the experts uh
judge panel for best technical and
research project where uh after after
getting an opportunity and winning there
will be cash prizes available for the
research group or the research student
who will be presenting their poster in
the in the session which is after the
academic panel now that's how it looks
for the asia
for the asia panel and i am hoping that
all of you who have joined us today are
really excited to be a part of this and
to learn but from the experts and also
to connect with all of us and get some
of these opportunities that we are
discussing and be a part of this omix
logic community by logging into learn or
mix logic and also by reaching out to us
and be a part of our social network
now after the after the session that we
have planned for asia we will move to
our next chapter which is omixlogic
africa where we will be discussing where
uh it will be led by mr adekunle adeluyo
who is uh overseeing omisnod
nigeria and is also a faculty at leed
city university nigeria will be
discussing about the programs that we
did in uh that did in africa and the
outcomes of the student training and
what are the different projects and
ideas that students are working on which
universities are applying and
implementing this
and
what are the different directions that
the omics logic community is looking at
now we will also have speakers who are
very
experienced and
experts in their in their
multi-disciplinary research
including biomedical research use of
omics data and computational biology
where we will be looking at specific
problems that are discussed in the
aspect of uh
in africa and then we have sessions
where we are discussing about
opportunities of scientific research in
africa and also opportunities what are
there in in some of these universities
and um where we will be discussing and
knowing uh about these opportunities by
dr marion and uh then we have an
important group discussion with a panel
exciting panel panelists from cameroon
zimbabwe nigeria and uh
and our team members from omixlogic
africa who will be discussing and
summarizing some of these important
aspects and it will be great if if the
participants from africa or
those who are from african origin can
also be a part of this panel discussion
and ask their questions that have been
bothering themselves or or participate
by giving us insights that would help
the entire community
now uh after the omics logic africa
conclusion we will move to the next
chapter which is the omixlogic us and in
the next chapter led by our ceo ilya
brodsky we will be learning from experts
from different uh
areas of research and coming from
different uh
from different areas of research as well
as coming from applying this for uh very
innovative research which involves
machine learning view of how to do
multinomics data integration so some of
these advanced topics that we will be
learning from the t by info uh team also
the topper tower team and dr julia pinov
associated associate director at the
topper bioinformatics research center
she will be talking about analysis of
bulk and single cell transcriptomics
data so these are some of the
technologies that are really now being
used by the pharma by you by the top
research labs and it would be a great
opportunity for all of you to learn from
the tbi or info
or the topper group
from uh
from
single cell to metagenomics data
and
different use of technologies uh of
omics data then we have the keynote
speakers as dr sarah sees the pico we'll
be talking about interdisciplinary
forensic science integration and how
omix technology is used in forensic
sciences and then we have an expert on
precision medicine from pediatric
pediatric oncology on the state of art
and perspective dr louis sokomoto who is
an md physician uh bra in brazilian
pediatric and as an oncologist now then
we have another session next keynote
speaker talking about bioinformatics and
cancer system biology so there are
exciting sessions which are coming up
and i'm hoping that
many of you will be staying tuned to
these sessions and as you as you get
time keep on joining and learning from
these experts and
asking the questions that that you think
are relevant and we will be able to
record those questions that you put in
the chat and that you put in the youtube
chat as well and we will be able to
reach out to you with a relevant answer
if not
by now but we will be able to give that
solution or answer by email so
i hope that you will make this a lot
more interactive you'll get this is a
great opportunity for students so those
students who wants to learn from these
experts and also get wants to get
support on some of these resources could
reach out to us that brings us to um
to our first session and uh really
excited to have dr nishan gupta here
with us assistant professor from iit
delhi to talk about too many ways to die
from poverty 19 results from the world's
largest cohort of lungs so um
dr ishan gupta works with the functional
genomic group at id delhi and develops
and deploy
bench to code noble omix technology to
measure biological phenomena with high
resolution single cell high precision
isoforms and high throughput
technologies so using this technology he
wants to understand the nature of
biologically complex diseases so
with that
i would like to invite
dr professor ishaan gupta so over to you
sir
um yeah hi can everybody hear me hello
yes yes we can you fine
hi is my screen visible
yes
you can see my slides
yes
okay
all right um thanks to the organizers
for um
hosting this talk i think there is some
issue with my computer so i'm gonna
basically be changing like this i hope
it's this is fine
with everybody
yeah
uh does this work yeah because i at this
point of time it's
i'm on linux right now and
yeah
so can you do a full screen or this will
be the screen size yeah this is the
screen size unfortunately
yeah that's fine it's visible i think
it's it's kind of visible for the
audience and they can also like please
let us know in the chat if if you guys
can see the presentation
please let us know if if there is an
issue
it's visible so yeah um it's visible so
you can go ahead professor
yeah so thank you for thank you for
having me um
so today we are going to talk about uh
i'm going to talk about some of the
results in my lab
where we have looked at uh
over 19 patients
from india and we have looked at their
bio like lung biopsies and autopsies
actually autopsies after the patients
are
passing away from the disease
and um
typically there are three messages that
i
we have that i can give immediately is
that it's very important to actually
do such studies on indian patients on
indian cohorts
and not only rely on the results that
have been published from cohorts from
outside india because the genetics
and how
the patients the ex the environment that
is the patients are exposed to is very
different
which leads to very different kinds of
results
so that's the first thing first take
home message the second take home
message that i can give which is from
the title itself we find that there are
two very distinct ways in which
patients um
would be responding to the disease and
therefore
are succumbing to the disease
and and the third thing is there is a
big
underappreciated
role of
the resident lung microbiome or
the microbes that are residing in your
lung
um
that could also play an important role
in kovid as i will try to motivate uh in
this talk today
so the most of the work that i am going
to be presenting here was done in
collaboration with dr dipali
and was led by three students in my lab
anshul um on the left
uh
anubhav in the middle and
on the right
so this is a paper that was recently
published
in
the the journal dmm
disease mechanism this is models and
mechanism about two months back
all right
so covet 19 in india there have been
about
five lakh people
are dead so five blacks would
approximately be five hundred thousand
dead but there is no molecular data from
india
so although we are a country with uh
one of the highest disease burdens of
the top three disease burdens
uh
and
a lot of like half a million people have
died because of this disease
um
there is
i mean very few data is there for
exactly looking at the patient types or
patients of isotypes looking at the
molecular biology of the patient there's
a lot of clinical data epidemiological
data
but very little data from exactly how
the patients
look like
under the microscope or
at the molecular level
so this is what we are setting to do
this is what we had essentially uh
doing so we are essentially took 10
patients uh as controls and 32 patients
who had covered uh
19 also patients who had died of the
disease and we took uh core samples from
those of course samples from these
autopsies um very fast so this is with a
technique called uh mids is massively
invasive tissue massively um uh
invasive i
i don't think it's invasive uh it's just
that you have an injection which gets
like you put an injection onto the
lung samples or the tissue that you want
to sample
and
you can quickly uh minimally sorry it's
minimally invasive tissue sampling you
can quickly get a tissue sample so the
idea was that we sequenced these samples
and uh did the rna sequencing we did the
quality control we aligned these samples
to the human genome
we found a differential uh transcriptome
uh analysis uh for these uh
samples so basically figuring out the
differences between the covid samples
and the normal samples and
besides their data from the human genome
we also had data
from the microbiome that was resided in
the lung and that's what i'm going to
talk about
so one
major
result from our study
was that when we take a look at
the
gene expression level of the patients uh
we find
two kinds of patients so just to show
you the figure in this figure you see
that there are
each dot is a patient
and the normal patients can be seen
in the color red and covet patients can
be seen in the color the steel blue
right and what you see is that when we
are plotting the gene expression
of these patients in higher dimensions
uh specifically capturing
the first two principal components
uh basically
characterizing how the how these
patients could be different at the level
of gene expression we find
that the patients are segregated into
two parts right so on the left side in
the left and the right side of the
of the graph on the left you have sets
of patients um covet patients and normal
patients clustering together and on the
right side you have only the covariate
patients clustering together
so
this suggests that there is a group of
subgroup of covet patients so this is
approximately eight cobit patients
um
who are actually
very similar to normal patients at the
level of gene expression
and on the other hand there's the
majority of the coveted patients about
three-fourths of these coveted patients
look very very distinct from uh normal
patients
so
what could be the reason for this
uh is something that we try to figure
out in this paper
so we had some
clinical annotation for these patients
like whether they had some
cardiovascular complications whether
they had diabetes they had liver
liver complications or other
comorbidities
and we did not find any signature so
basically these comorbidities could not
be the reason why the patients were
separated so here we have colored
uh a no is colored in red and a yes is
colored in this blue color
right so what we find is that it's you
cannot clearly see that okay one of the
comorbidities like diabetes
is more enriched in the patients which
are
similar to the normal patients
versus patients which are extremely
distinct
although we do know that patients with
cardiovascular complications and
diabetes from our own work we have shown
in indian patients that
uh patients who have diabetes are more
susceptible to cobit 19 but that's at
the clinical outcome level but at least
at the molecular level of how their
lungs are looking uh the gene expression
of their lungs are looking that's not
the case
so then what do we do we essentially go
ahead and assume
uh that these
two groups of patients are distinct and
then we compare each of these groups
with the normal sets of patients so
normal sets of patients here would be
these patients in red so what we do is
we do a comparison of differential gene
expression between this group which is
similar to normal which we call g1 and
this other group which is very distinct
from normal that we call g2
when we do this
we find
as expected lots of genes that are
different between these two groups of
patients
specifically there are about thousand
genes in total that are different
between these two groups some of them
are going up some of them are going down
and if you can see on this plot on the
right this is a typical heat map
on the first row
uh each column is a patient the first
row gives you the color
of the type of the patient so a light
pink color means this belongs to the g2
group
or the group that was most distinct and
on the right side top you have the dark
maroon color
which would be patients which are in the
g1 group and you have this blue color
which patients who are normal right
so if you look at the first uh if you
look at the first row sets
first rows each row here is a gene you
see that there are certain genes which
are only expressed highly
in your
normal patients and they are not
expressed in either g1 group of patients
or g2 patients
similarly if you go down
you have certain genes which are only
expressed in the g2 group of patients
mildly expressed in the g1 patients and
not expressed at all in
the normal patients
and then you have another set of sets of
genes which are expressed highly
in both g1 and g2 patients but are
practically absent in
the normal patients
so in order to understand what's going
on what separates these groups of
patients and what unifies these groups
of patients we can actually take these
lists of genes that we obtain after such
a differential expression analysis
and try to understand what are the
common pathways
that these genes belong to all right so
when we do this uh when we are basically
separating these genes uh the
differential gene expressions are
treating it separately
as expected for g1 patients we have a
much less number of genes as opposed to
g2 patients
and what we find when we do pathway
analysis is you have pathways such as
fibronectin beta chain
serum amyloid
apolipoproteins are upregulated these
pathways and
genes which are relating to say
scrna or uh fab p4 they are down
regulated here and similarly in the case
of g2
some interleukins
some angiotensin
by vitronectin
these enzymes are sort of upregulated
and
a lot of snow rnas
or specific genes are downregulated
right there's a very little overlap
between these two patients just to
confirm what we saw in the pca plot
but in order to go deeper we now try to
look at which pathways are enriched for
these genes so specifically i'm showing
you here
the pathway enrichment analysis for
genes that are upregulated in g1
patients versus n patients and what you
see is that lipid metabolism is
upregulated uh coagulation could be
slightly downregulated and there is up
regulation of sorry coagulation would be
slightly downregulated as negative
cooperation
and neutrophil mediated immunity is
slightly downregulated and this is
something that was confirmed in other
papers by other papers and smaller
studies by targeted analysis
and the papers i mentioned here
when we look for g2 patients
specifically uh one pathway which stands
out is complement activation
pathways in xenobiotic metabolism and
peroxisomal protein transport and this
was also supported by some of the
publications that came out uh
early last year
now this essentially means that the
the disease that is being experienced by
g1 patients and the disease that is
experienced by g2 patients
uh may look
very differently uh molecularly
so what could be the reason uh everybody
would have heard of ace2 receptor and
tmpr resist two protease
uh playing a role in search of two so we
try to figure out if
the expression of these two uh
genes could be uh
sort of indicative of what's going on
but uh for ace two definitely we did not
see any major changes in gene expression
and for dmpr assist two as well uh there
were certain changes but when we correct
for multiple testing these changes do
not hold us that significantly
there are other proteins
which can substitute for tmprs2 which is
a protease which helps the processing of
the spike protein
when we tested these uh these were also
not uh really convincing and uh
cannot distinguish between why
these two patients are experiencing the
disease differently
so the next thing that we did was we
tried to enrich for
specific gene sets
uh that were known to be implicated uh
in
in covet 19 basically some pathways that
are known to be sort of
playing a role in the disease
uh some of the pathways uh you can see
here this was done by a tool called gsba
which is basically gene variation
analysis
um so as you can see again we have
similar heat map plot but instead of
plotting genes
as in rows we are now plotting a score
for a pathway in in each rows
so if the pathway is upregulated uh you
would see a more green color if the
pathway is downregulated you'll see a
more purple color
and
you can see there are pathways like
unfolded protein response which is known
to play a role in viral infections you
see that this pathway is highly up
regulated in the g2 cells of patients
those patients are all these patients in
green
your normal patients are in blue here
and the g1 patients are in red
so you see in g2 patients typically you
have high unfolded protein response
there is high oxidative phosphorylation
fatty acid beta oxidation is also high
and all kinds of complicated complement
systems classical alternative lectin
induced are all high
while in the case of both normal
patients
and g1 patients these pathways are not
high
right
similarly there are certain pathways
which are high in the normal patients
and in the g1 patients such as these il1
cytokines
uh which seem to be uh
low in the case of
our g2 patients the other other patients
of type
so what this kind of analysis
essentially tells us that there are
certain mechanisms or certain pathways
that are upregulated in both kinds of
patients so interleukin receptor
interferon response
jack stat signaling is is upregulated
in in both these patient types but if
you specifically look at g1
chemokine ligand signaling
is specifically such as the cytokines is
specifically
upregulated in g1 patients and here if
we go down to what kind of chemokine
ligands specific genes that could be
found upregulated we find that ccl19
which was shown to be a potential
biomarker for patient stratification
uh
in the blood of covid19 patients
that was only upregulated in g1 while in
the case of g2 you had very high
presence of
all the complement system
some chemokine receptors
uh
dnf factors
tgf beta signaling so on and so forth
so with this analysis we can suggest
that why is it that the patients look so
different because the molecular biology
of the lungs
looks very different specifically in the
context of how chemokine signaling is
working and in the context of uh the
complement system uh in the in the g2
patients
and with ccl 19 we actually have one way
uh one biomarker which should be uh and
which has been used for stratification
of patients to tell which patient could
be a g1 type or which patient would be a
g2 type
beyond this we also
can look at which specific
cell types in the lung could be affected
so their lung is composed of many
different kinds of cell types
and what we find is uh
we can have gene sets with respect to
each cell type and what we find is that
in the case of
your uh copy 19 patients specific cell
types like proliferating basal cells or
alveolar epithelial type 2 cells they
seem to be disrupted and if we make a
sort of a plot for what kind of cells
are changing their proportions between
g2 and g1 patients
we specifically see that
on this x x equal to y line uh your
classical monocytes lipofibroblasts uh
dendritic cells they're all changing
similarly so either they're going down
in both g1 and g2 patients or they're
going up in g1 and g2 patients but two
cell types specifically proliferating
basal cells and trem2 dendritic cells
are positively changing in g2 patients
but they are negatively changing in g1
patients which essentially means that
suggests that these cells could
potentially allow you to understand why
these patients are behaving differently
and maybe even design distinct
strategies to uh or or drugs
uh to
treat these two patients differently
one thing that i started with in my talk
was to sort of motivate that such
studies have not been done in the indian
context and why they are important so
in this slide i would like to motivate
that so there was a study in 2020 by
nine hold at all where they
took 22 patients
the biopsies from 22 patients
fixed samples
we have fresh frozen samples
and what they found was they found that
there are 68 highly upregulated genes
and 30
uh significantly downregulated genes
because they were using actually a gene
panel instead of doing rna sequencing
and they found that specifically
interferon genes were
changing in this process
and what they did was they were able to
sub classify their patients into these
interferon stimulated gene height
category and low category
and they said that there are two kinds
of patients uh the caucasian patients
that they were looking at there are two
kinds of patients in
which have different kinds of
covet 19 manifesting
now when we do look at the same gene
sets in our patients
uh using gsb scoring
uh we don't find
the results to be replicating we don't
[Music]
don't find
our patient two subtypes the g1 and g2
subtypes to represent the same subtypes
that was found by an eyeball at all so
this essentially means that the kind of
the weight of the disease manifesting in
the indian patients is uh potentially
different from the way it is manifesting
in the asian patients or at least
the uh
we are using rna sequencing uh the
difference in technology could actually
be giving you different results so
uh
therefore this needs to be looked at at
least we are not able to reproduce the
results that they have shown
so the take home message for the talk so
far is that clinical covariates have
little impact on how the gene expression
of covet 19 is segregating between the
two groups of patients
there are two potential kinds of these
patients
the patients recapitulate the molecular
aberrations or the changes in molecular
biology which has been reported so there
is unfolded protein response there is
il1 inflammation
there is change in the complement
pathway there is changes there is
changes in drug metabolism because most
of these patients were uh under
treatment
and there is down regulation of cross
pathways like olive action which was one
of the first signs of corbit 19 where
smell was lost
and down regulation of dendritic cells
and t cells uh which are basically going
to respond to the disease
and we found certain uh specific things
in in our covet samples there was
enhanced lipofibroblast and basal cells
and ciliary cells
and they were diminished dendritic cells
specifically igf-21 positive alveolar
type 2 cells and basophil mast cells and
there were certain cell types as i said
which are distinguishing between our two
patient types and we can
actually distinguish these patient types
based on certain chemokine markers as
well
the
second thing uh that we
try to actually look at is
uh the remaining twenty percent of the
reads which did not align to the human
genome when we were doing our analysis
and these remaining twenty percent of
the genes we found uh by aligning two
custom databases of bacteria viruses and
fungi they're actually coming from the
resident microbiome of the lungs
so
what we essentially found was if we
compare
covet samples
with normal samples
the microbiome diversity
was massively downregulated so not only
did these patients have
infection from the covered virus but as
a result of
infection from the covet virus there was
also
loss in the diversity of of
the bacteria that could be normally
residing in the lungs
and you can also look at this loss of
diversity in the context of a pca plot
where the abundance of each
genome that it was detected
for each microorganism that was detected
is plotted and you see that most of the
patients are on the right side
separating from all the normal patients
unlike at the level of gene expression
so there is definite dysbiosis
in these patients and that is something
that one has to look at so one of the
things that we looked at in the case of
dysbiosis was that we were able to
actually detect
complete genomes of the sarc scope to
virus itself from the sample so we were
able to actually get four
uh samples had high confidence detection
of sarcopte virus and out of these four
samples in three samples we were able to
actually reconstruct the entire genome
sequence of the sarcovirus
and when we
looked at which lineage these viruses uh
corresponded to so they were really into
the next lineage 20a
or tango lineage b 1.36 so this was the
uh the beta variant so this was
corresponding to the time of sampling
of the variant so this sampling happened
in late uh 2020 early 2021
uh and uh it corresponded to the time uh
where the samples were taken so these
samples were deposited i'm sorry for the
image quality if i could have make it
make it bigger you would have seen it so
these samples were uh
submitted on a gsa i8
and we could see that all of them were
actually
sort of clustering with other samples
that was submitted from india and from
ames the hospital
and there were specific mutations that
we could see uh which would be
interesting for people who are actually
uh looking at how the virus is evolving
so as i said the variant that we found
uh were from this late 2020 early 2021
variant which is during the time of
sampling so that sort of is a sanity
check
for the fact that we were actually
capturing
coed samples of that time that we wanted
to look at
now if we specifically look at how the
dysbiosis is happening in these samples
uh i'm instead of plotting all the
coveted samples together and i am
plotting the covert samples separately
the g1 and g2 sample separately from the
normal samples and you see that both the
g1 and g2 samples have dio
has dysbiosis with a reduced channel
diversity index
and although there is no differences at
the level of the g1 g2 groups themselves
that the
way that the dysbiosis has happened in
the two patients is quite similar so in
both the patients
the uh bacterial composition or the
microbial composition actually we are
also looking at viruses is uh is
similarly diminished
and now if we plot
the uh at the phylum level how these uh
in each individual samples how these are
looking at so for example each column
here is normal sample so the first uh 10
columns here are normal samples the next
eight columns are g1 samples in the next
about 24 samples are the g2 samples uh
g2 patients and what we see is that
there's similar kind of trend there's
nothing which is like outstandingly
different between the g1 and g2 patients
at the level of phylum
but now if we specifically go and take a
look at the level of specific uh
species that we were detected
uh there are some trends
so if you look at this heat map again
each column
is a patient uh the patients who are
corresponding to the blue column are
normal patients patients who are
corresponding to the red column are g1
patients patients that are corresponding
to the green column are g2 patients
so now if we specifically look at these
rows which are marked as
g1 versus gn so these are these rows
represent strains which are specifically
found to be present in a high number in
g1 patients
and much lower number in g2 patients so
one of these strains is staphylococcus
epi dermatite
dermatitis so this basically is
an opportunistic pathogen which is on
our skin
and this pathogen was found to be more
enriched
in g1 patients than due to patients
similarly there is staphylococcus coni
that was found to be more enriched in g2
patients
they were present in slightly higher
number right and the g2 patients also
had
pathogens like aspergillus
or isa uh and some some viruses
similarly there was other
other sort of resident microbiome which
could possibly be protective
such as
shown here so all these bacteria
micrococcus luteers
ralestonia
all of these are
the bacteria which are potentially
so no depleted in in the covet patients
so what this sort of suggests
is that there could be
specific species of bacteria which
can
colonize
the immuno-compromised niche of of the
lungs uh of the patients who have been
suffering from covet covered 19 and
interestingly what you'll find is that
the covert 19 was only detected in like
six patients so the lungs had cleared
out the the infection
so basically the take home message for
this part of the talk is that this bios
is uh you see dysbiosis in almost all
the patients of corbit 19 and there is
definitely enhanced presence of
staphylococcus infections in both the
kinds of patients
and we were able to recover cov19 even
in these patients during close to their
uh just before
they gave up uh in 20 of the samples and
we were able to actually recover with
high confidence in four samples we were
actually able to recover the entire
virus itself
so the outlook um that one could have
from such an analysis is that working on
a country-specific cohort like we have
done
revealed new subtypes so it's important
to actually go around
and whenever you are actually looking at
some molecular phenotyping of a disease
it should be done across the world
across different populations and
definitely major large population groups
of the world should be represented like
india uh which is typically not uh
what we find is that there are specific
pathways which are changing between the
patients
uh and there are specific uh suggestions
that we have for stratification of the
patients
based on these pathways or based on the
molecules that could be found in the
blood
that could access a proxy for these
pathways such as ccl19
the fact that we have gene expression
changes can be used to also do some
insilico drug screening something that
i've not shown but if you're interested
you can go and take a look at the paper
and also we could find that these
changes are specifically happening in
certain cell types in the two different
patient types uh which can be used for
designing targeted therapies and then
there is definitely a role of the
microbiome in the lungs of the
covatenting patients
that needs to be further investigated
and we don't
cannot rule out the possibility that the
reason why the patients are not uh
the patients had enough time
could be because of these infections uh
rather than the covalent 19 because
these patients mostly had cleared away
the infection uh we were not detecting
kubernetes and actually majority 80 of
the patients so i'll end my talk here
and i'll be happy to take questions
thank you
thank you so much dr shan for such an
interesting talk
and i have some questions for you uh we
want to understand
is it the normal patients which were
taken on healthy volunteers like normal
patients suffering from uh disease that
yes then water complications who survive
yeah so this is a good question so we
took basically uh autopsies of
patients who were suffering from lung
cancer so typically when you were taking
a topsies for or not opposite biopsies
so you would take
some tissue which would be normal tissue
and some tissue which would be cancer
tissue so we were using the tissue that
was normal tissue from lung cancer
patients so these lungs were already
inflamed
so they should have had some
inflammation signatures uh
so that's those were the available
samples that we had
for ethical clearance
all right
and even within the g1 uh the first
group you seem to have two sets of
patients based on heat map
do you want to comment on that
so
but
yeah some set of patients yeah they are
not really
yeah we are i'm just showing here the
top 20 uh stopped 50 genes
but when we take a look at like all the
genes which is what this these kinds of
pca is taking into account
uh there seems to be all the g1 patients
are much more different than the g2
patient so i there could be some patient
specific variability
uh which is typically taken care of when
we are doing this differential
expression so
uh
yeah
this could be attributed to patient
specific variability but if we would
look at the heat map for all
all the genes which are involved here to
be found differently expressed uh maybe
this difference between sub patients
might not be so stark
12 would you say the cytoplasm are the
cytokines stone signature is different
between g1 versus g2
so actually what we think is that the g1
patients
uh
may represent the cytokine storm
signature
um
the challenge is that in the time in
which the patients were sampled
it was very hard
uh experiment i mean it's not an
experiment it's a very hard challenging
work to do
because
to sub to basically take blood from the
patients and measure the cytokine levels
all the time
typically in the setting that we have in
india is very hard
but yeah so we suspect that the way that
these patients look like
what we could be seeing is actually a
cytokine storm g1 patients versus a more
classical long term covet 19 g2 patients
but this did not correlate very well um
with the data for how long the patients
spent inside the hospital so we cannot
be sure of this
it's a good question
i don't have an answer to that
so we have a few more questions but as
we are running out of time would it be
all right if i made you out of the
questions and then we can answer the
questions for
uh our participants
yeah i'll be happy to answer any
question
and i'll suggest if people are
interested uh please go and read the
paper
um yeah it's available it's it's it's
freely accessible
from pubmed
uh because what i said was a very short
description of what is there in the
paper
it's quite more comprehensively
explained in the paper
so can you share the link of the paper
in the chat with us
yeah i'll do that
okay thank you sir so now it's time that
we do our next speaker i'll just share
my screen
all right
so we learned how omix data can be used
to reveal the biological complexity of
over 19 rupees but how does
bioinformatics come into play during
this process
and what are some other areas where
bioinformatics analysis is used
so now we will hear from dr suchi to
understand the role of bioinformatics in
omix time
dr shoji nagar is working as an
associate professor at diy partel
biotechnology bioinformatics institute
pune she did her phd from department of
chemical technology university of
calcutta in the field of chem
informatics and drug design she has 17
publications to her credit she has
guided around 20 project students
presently she has two funded projects
one is related to designing anti-cancer
drugs and the other is designing quorum
sensing inhibitors
further her expertise is also being
applied for studying alzheimer's
diseases and for generating iron vedic
formulation
we are pleased to have you with us dr
shuchi over to you you may share your
screen now
yeah thank you sonalika i hope i'm
audible
yes ma'am importable to us okay yeah so
good evening to all
so today uh as uh said by uh
miss analika i'll be actually going into
a very brief understanding of what is
omics and how bioinformatics is going to
be helpful in
studying the
data that we get through omics studies
and we've just had one talk
by dr ishan so he has used uh quite a
few places he's used these techniques
that we will be just discussing so it's
going to be an overview
of uh the omix technology with
bioinformatics rather than being some
kind of a specific work that we have
done
so i'll just share the screen
yeah so i hope the screen is visible
yes now we can see our screen
okay so before i start off with this
topic of relevance of bioinformatics in
movies i would like to just introduce my
institute where i am working
and
just to give a brief the courses that
are offered in our institute is we have
v-tech with biotechnology we tech with
medical biotechnology
we've just started with btec with
artificial intelligence and data science
there's mtech biotechnology and msc
biotechnology so these are the proposals
that are being offered at our institute
and we have different research areas
that are there which are
very functional and there's a lot of
research done on these areas
uh it's microbial diversity then you
have plant and environmental
biotechnology you have genetics and
molecular
cancer and translational research
protein biochemistry and bioinformatics
so these are the six
broader areas on which
all the faculties of our institute are
working
and it is
so we really have a good strength of
faculties who are working and doing
really well in all these fields
now to start with the topic of uh
relevance of
you know bioinformatics in comics
i just want to say that when we talk of
comics or when we are talking about
bioinformatics it's like saying that
what has come first has the hen come
first or the egg has come first
that's because it is uh a part of omix
and part of bioinformatics that is
common so you have certain part of
comics wherein uh that part of the omics
is uh you know completely done on wet
lab
then you have the data that is generated
is stored in certain databases so you
collect those data from there
and then you use the different
bioinformatics tools to analyze them so
that is why we can you know it's very
difficult to say whether bioinformatics
gameplay that
so it's like
you know the omics and the
bioinformatics are coming together
joining hands to give you a good
information that will further help us in
systems biology so systems reality is
basically when we are trying to study
different pathways that are there in
very details
and followed with system biology we can
go to studying or doing chemo
informatics studies where we can go
ahead with uh designing of new
molecules you know that could be lead
molecules for a particular disease of
interest or a particular target of
interest that we have
so to ah
just understand the flow chart that is
there with it
what we actually do is this is your
comics part that is there wherein we are
doing certain kind of your
you can say experimental works you have
m number of different experimental works
through which you can get data so all
these could be gene data genome data it
can be on any data it can be protein it
can be any kind of data depending on
what
um
what kind of your
experiment are you doing
that data and then we take it and we are
storing it in different databases
and then
using various algorithms and various
tools that are available we are actually
doing all these studies which is
actually the omics studies okay
so this is your ohmic studies which is
your genomics transcriptomics proteomics
and metabolomics so we can say that
it's a um
the follow-up that is there is you know
it's like um
the central dogma that's what is there
you have genomics that is the g data so
that then you come to transcriptomics
which is your mrna and other data from
there you have your proteomics so that's
your protein data that you have
then comes your metabolox so i the
ultimately the product that is being
formed is what is your metabolism so i
will lead it uh i will uh
discuss on each of these omics in
details as in where can these be applied
and
what are the different tools that are
available for this so what are the
different kind of studies that that you
can do with different types of mixed
data that is available so definitely you
have to have some kind of an
experimental work
only after doing this experimental work
can you go ahead and do this study which
is going to be using the data that is
generated from here
and then the computer and the various
computer
algorithms and programming are used to
study the data to get some kind of an
output
so omix as i said is a kind of different
technique so that is why it is a very
high throughput technique that's because
whatever data is generated when you are
doing any kind of omix work is very huge
and it's not possible for any human to
study it in in that details so that is
why you do require
uh
some kind of an er tools so that is why
we use computational tools now the data
that we that is generally uh generated
through this hydrogen techniques would
be you can have n number of genes data
be generated you can find out the
expressions that you have with regards
to genes
various proteins that are being
expressed
and also it could be a combination of
any two or three all the three of them
so depending on what kind of study you
are doing that will tell you what kind
of data you are getting in and that data
can be then analyzed using computational
methods
which is the bioinformatics part because
the bioinformatics is taking into
consideration the biology as well as the
informatics it is
combining it to give you or helping you
to solve certain problems that otherwise
would have been difficult
or you can say it could be time
consuming at the same end say for
instance you have generated a lot of
genes
around thousand genes for instance so
analyzing that genes and seeing
which gene is the most apt is very
difficult if i say it from human point
of view
using computers that is what becomes
more simplified
so
and
so omix is basically signifying the
measurement of the entire complement of
a given level of biological molecules
the information that is obtained is
basically
a variety of technologies
and uh that helps us to explain
how there is a differentiation that
might exist between say for instance a
normal and an abnormal cell
and when i'm talking about the
differences that is there between normal
and abnormal cell i'm also talking in
terms of whether it is there is some
kind of a pathway that is affected
whether there is some kind of a gene
expression that is getting affected is
there any kind of a mutation that we
have come across
or whether everything goes good but at
the end point when there is the final
product that has to be obtained there is
a problem with that so whatever the
place uh
which we say the four omegas all these
is what we can study using the tools and
the databases that are available for
uh
analyzing
things
so why do we use bioinformatics is
obviously because computers
is very much helpful and giving us
faster results along with computers we
also include certain statistical
approaches and that's the best way of
studying the variation
and it helps us to perform
extensive omics related research that ha
which is present in the biological
database and that helps us to do some
kind of comparative studies
thus at the end it helps us to identify
sequences of proteins that differ
between disease and healthy tissues
so the branches of genome omics are you
have genomics which is nothing but your
quantitatively studying of protein
coding genes
whether you have regulatory elements and
non-coding genes so these are few things
that we study with regards to genomics
then we have transcriptomics that is
your rna and gene expression then is
proteomics which is focusing more on
proteins
and metabolomics after proteins whatever
we get as a by-product or as an uh
end product of any kind of a pathway is
metabolomics and that also indirectly
helps us to study the various pathways
that are involved in that
so it is a clear you can say very much
clear uh
follow up from your central dogma from
genes to mrna to dna to mrna to proteins
and then to the product
so what can we achieve at the end or
what are the things that we can get
after you you know do any kind any one
ohmic study or a combination of image
studies
you can do data processing
you can identify certain proteins that
are being expressed
you can uh go away with statistical
analysis you do pathway analysis and at
the end you can also do various type of
modeling studies wherein when i get to
know so
target identification is also one thing
that can be there when i'm talking about
your pathway analysis
so now focusing on individual
omics that we have so when i'm talking
about genomics we always obviously get
sequences from various
experimental sources and then they are
stored in the databases now you have two
kinds of databases that are available
you have primary database and you have
secondary databases now how they are
different is when i am talking about
primary database i
simply have done some experiment and
that data is stored in the primary
database
if i further analyze that data and study
has to
uh say what is its functionality
where is it expressed what is the
situation under which it is expressed
all these things then the information
that can be stored would be the
secondary database
from here then we can retrieve the
information so since it is genomics we
tried the sequences that are available
over here and after getting the sequence
we can do various studies
the first thing that you can see over
here is we can do sequence similarity
and this sequence similarity
you have it you can do various types of
sequence similarities over here
okay so sequence similarity would be say
you are doing pairwise alignment so two
tools
so you have a sequence similarity which
can be say pairwise alignment wherein i
am trying to see whether the the same
gene from two different species how far
they are different from each other or
how close they are to so what is the one
thing that is varying say for instance
if i am talking about hexagonist that is
present in bacterial genome as well as
in say a plant genome for that matter
so how are they different because the
length of the genome is different
sorry the gene is different so what is
it that is varying that is going to help
me to understand
how there are things that are changing
down the line from
uh by evolution and even though you know
there's a change in the
length of the genes that you're getting
though both of them are for the same
enzyme but still the length is different
so what has changed down the
evolutionary tree because of which even
though it is coding for the same
particular enzyme still my sequence
length is different
or what kind of a variation is actually
existing
the second type that we can do is we can
do multiple sequence alignment wherein
we can actually again compare and find
out similar genes or similar enzymes
from the same
um
same species so i have say just e coli
under e coli i have different
sub sub groups that are there so how
these are different from each other a
particular
amount say a particular
protein is present in all the sequences
but still what is that that is different
at the genetic level
is what we can do with regards to
genomics and a very frequently used tool
that you have is blast that is used for
doing that
or you also have embos that is used for
your multiple sequence element
the next is gene prediction
we get to find out because we already
have databases that are stored so in
case when you get some kind of
a sequence say after performing any kind
of an experimental work
now by doing uh
searching for those genes that are
present in the database whichever gene
we see that there is a similarity that
is there that is one way in which we can
find out the genes on the other hand we
also have many tools that are available
for example gene parser or eugenes
which help us to find out which gene it
is what is the functionality of the gene
what is this gene coding for
or is there any kind of a difference
that is there in this g say i have got
this gene from some kind of a diseased
person so what is it that is different
from this person and the normal person
for that
matter any kind of a mutation can be
studied using the tool mutation testing
we can study the variation that is there
within the species
so n number of different species that
are there we collect the genes of the
similar kind and that's how we can study
the variations that are existing
obviously we can study the evolutionary
relation that is existing among various
organisms that are present okay so these
are uh different types of tools that are
available for doing their individual
tasks
so
we can at the end what are what all
things that we can do
we can predict
or go ahead and find out biomarkers
we can obtain evolutionary history
we can assess risk management we can
also know about the bioarchaeological
anthropology evolution and human
migrations so it's not just restricted
to any kind of disease related stuff you
can also go about doing a lot of things
over here like your archaeological
survey anthropological survey or even
for that matter human migrations
so these are the applications
so you can use the genomic study to find
out molecular medicines and it's very
much
going to be effective with regards to
doing personalized medicine
then you can go ahead and study
microbial genomics so
as uh in the present scenario you can
see that the gut microbes are
you know said to be of
very much you know playing a very high
role in any kind of a disease state
so you can obviously go with the
microbial genomics where you can study
the gut microbes microbes in details
risk management would be with regards to
whether you are
capable or whether there are chances of
you
having a particular disease in the
future so there are certain diseases
that are genetic in nature certain
diseases uh that you have it from due to
the environmental stress that is there
so you do uh you can definitely go ahead
and do genomic studies to find out if
there is any kind of risk related to
these things
bio archaeology anthropology evolution
these are again
various ways in which we can use the
genomic studies
then you have dna identification
you can also use it for agriculture
livestock breeding and bioprocessing so
in
short what i can say is with regards to
genomics it's
not just restricted to your
disease and non-disease states or things
like that but you can also have its
application in various categories
next coming to transcriptomics so that's
transcriptomics means now we we have the
mrna that is available so you do have
again databases that are there which can
be used
where you have the mrnas that are stored
now what you can do first is you can
find out the exons that are available
or you can directly use the database
that is stored from there you can obtain
the rna sequences and convert them to
your amino acid sequences
after doing that part
you can do again various kind of studies
that are there
you can study the gene regulation
studies so after you get these same
sequences you have
a lot of genes
so how well are the genes regulated uh
say again here what you're going to
actually do is you're going to take it
from
a set of people who are normal and says
a set of people who have some kind of an
abnormality or something which is
different from others
and accordingly we can see
say for instance if i just talk about
a situation improve it where we had seen
that you know the indian population
were not that much affected as against
the u.s population or the european
population so we could always do this
kind of a study to see what is it what
is one thing or two thing that is
present in the indian population
or absent in the indian population and
vice versa with say u.s population or
the
european population
wherein this kind of discrepancy is seen
you can so this is just one instance you
can have plants that you can see that
they are growing having the same
environmental conditions they are going
in
a particular area but they are not going
growing in some other
say country so what is it exactly that
is affecting how are the genes getting
regulated which gene is the one that is
being uh regulated at a higher level or
regulated at a lower level
these are the regulatory genes studies
that we can do which can give us some
kind of a solution to solve the problem
that we are facing
at the same time you have gene
expression studies also so again gene
regulation when we are talking what are
the genes that are expressed so many
times it might be possible that it is
expressed but it doesn't go further so
those kind of studies are also there we
can get to know what are the genes that
are
upregulated what are the genes that are
down regulated and that helps us to
understand
the
biochemical reactions that are taking
place in the system of one group and the
system of the other group
you can observe mutation at the mrna
level and obviously you can go about
doing the evolutionary variation studies
that are there
so that will help us in prediction of
biomarkers and also help us in searching
for new targets that are help that would
be helpful for drug development
so various approaches or applications of
your transcriptomics approaches are
you have you can do transcript of
assembly and profiling
you can do small rna characterization
you can do mapping of the metabolites
protein and transcript profile
you can
do population breeding studies
and you can do regulation of gene
expressions
so these are the various tools that are
available for studying the transatomics
data that is available or that we can
get it from the
various experimental techniques that we
have
next coming to your proteomics data
again we definitely get the rna sequence
from there
we can go about doing the predicting the
uniqueness within a family of proteins
we can predict the structure
of the protein we can study evolutionary
relationships we can observe the
sequence changes that occurs between
normal and disease states that so most
of the applications you can see is quite
common to all the women studies that is
going to be there it's just that
depending on what data is available to
you you are going to do accordingly
one more thing that we need to keep in
mind over here is as we go down the
ladder from say genomics to
to transcriptomics to proteomics to
metabolomics
we are narrowing down so it becomes much
more reliable data the
observation that we see with genomics
data compared to the observation that we
see with proteomics data would be very
different proteomics you can rely more
on as compared to genomic state
okay
so all these things are there you have
you can always when you have the
proteins you can always obtain the rna
state and then the second is where we
always get the 3d structure available in
the databases
from there we can see we can do any kind
of an interaction studies so if we get
to know say from transcriptomics if you
get to know certain genes you know that
are playing a very important role or
says there are certain genes which are
getting upregulated in a particular
disease so those becomes
those genes become our target
and from there we can if the structure
is available well and good we go through
this protest if the structure is not
available we can do the prediction of
structures
using the information from the
evolutionary relationships or
some kind of uniqueness that is present
in that protein family so this
information as well as the domain
information help us to predict the
structure of the protein and after
getting the structure we can again go
about doing all these studies
okay so when we have the sequence itself
we have the structure itself by doing
functional similarity we can go ahead
and do functional predictions
we can predict the domains within a
family with regards to
the known structure
as well as just through the sequence
so at the end we can find structural
changes for the same gene expressed and
different environment and tissues
so you have
you have one gene that is coding for say
more than one proteins so we can also
see that whether the same gene is
expressed at the same level into
different environments or not or what is
one
environmental conditions or what is one
condition in which it is expressed in
tissue eggs and uh in the
change in the condition is helping it to
be getting expressed in say the tissue
wire so those kind of information again
can be gathered through the studies of
proteomics
so again the various applications that
we have is you can go for proteomic
you can go for protein expression
profiling post translation modification
protein protein interactional structural
proteomics protein quantification or
differential analysis and functional
proteomics
thank you dr suchi actually i think we
are running out of time
so if you can conclude the session
yeah so these are the various tools that
are available
then you have metabolomics that is
helping us at the end
and this is also a very important place
where you can go get good prediction of
markers because the initial um
you can say the samples that are there
is not something which is going to be
invasive so that's the um importance of
metabolomics you can use just say blood
sample urine sample these samples are
enough so we do not have to go through
too much of ethical
issues when we are doing metabolomics as
compared to genomics proteomics and
transcriptomics
so these are the various applications of
your metabolomics so very quickly i'll
just
discuss a small work that we had done
that would probably help you to
understand the omics that is there so
what we had done was we had uh taken few
data sets from your jio ncbi data set
and then applied
geo to r to get
the information that is there with
regards to test and control sample so
our actual work was to uh sort out the
differentially expressed genes which are
ex up regulated and down regulated for
parkinson's disease and those who are
tobacco smokers and those who are not
tobacco schools because it was seen
through literature that tobacco is
helping to delay parkinson's disease so
we were just trying to see
how this is affecting the effect of
tomato is there on the express genes so
which are the genes that are being
expressed uh upregulated and which are
being down regulated then those genes we
had taken in david and we had seen what
are the different pathways that they are
getting affected so we had obtained
around 17 genes that were there and now
we are in the process of finding out uh
new molecules you know that are
interacting with these so that we could
suggest some new molecules that could be
helpful for delaying of the parkinson's
disease so that's how we can actually go
about using the whole omics study
using different bioinformatics
applications to get down to the
conclusions
okay so take home message would be you
understand what is omits you understand
the you are able to do personalized
medicine which is very much coming in
the near recent uh
future
you get to know about the different
pathways involved and the genes that i
expressed and the whole study is
actually very much helpful in prognosis
diagnosis and treatment of any kind of
disease or conditions
and i would like to acknowledge
our director my colleagues
my students and my family members for
the constant support and last but not
least i thank the organizers for helping
me uh for allowing me to giving uh
giving me this platform actually to
share the information that i have
thank you and any questions
thank you dr suchi uh for this in depth
no no no problem
thank you for this in-depth presentation
and highlighting genomics and its
application transcriptomics and its
application and the entire flowchart or
one of the common pathways to do various
bioinformatics analysis showing how data
and bioinformatics could be applied not
only to diseases or healthcare but other
areas like evolutionary studies and by
other biotechnology areas i think the
audience
and our participants have been benefited
a lot from this talk and knowing some of
these resources that you have
that you have discussed and also the
case study thank you so much
for your time and for this presentation
thank you
all right so now it's time for our next
speaker and uh we are really excited to
have dr anshu bharatwaj with us
uh who would be talking about
understanding uh and addressing genotype
phenotype correlation in complex
diseases as we have been discussing dr
anshu bharatwaj is a biologist and a
data scientist she has obtained her phd
in 2008 in understanding of genotypic
phenotypic correlation in human
mitochondrial diseases from csir ccmb
hyderabad she has over 40 publications
to her credit and have trained over 500
young students and also has served as an
associate uh scientific advisor for
science
for science translational medicine and
is on the editorial board of journal of
genetics and frontiers of system biology
protein bioinformatics computational
genomics and f 1000 research galaxy
gateway where many of our students have
already
published some of these
some of these articles that they have
worked on so we are really delighted to
have you dr anshubart watch and we are
looking forward to your presentation and
learn from your talk thank you over to
you ma'am
thank you
so much for that introduction so uh can
you hear me clearly
yes yes
all right
uh are my slides visible
yeah they're coming up yeah they're
visible now
all right so first of all thanks for
giving me the opportunity uh to actually
talk to students that's my you know
that's that's my lifeline so what i
decided today since the entire symposium
is organized around bioinformatics and
data science training and research i
have kept the talk very very simple but
we have included one component of our
work so that you can also see the
application of how it can be done again
in the most simplest possible fashion
so
my lab
primarily
works in two domains one is basically
genotype phenotype correlations
when it comes to
infectious diseases as well as
mitochondrial diseases and the second
vertical which is a smaller component is
computational drug discovery
so
just a second so as you can see here uh
there are several projects that we have
done over years but today i have
selected projects which are on the
bottom panel of this timeline which is
mostly to do with mitochondrial diseases
because i thought genomics is something
which is basically picking up the base
so it's important that we understand the
genomics basics in terms of where are we
going where do we stand today
so as we all know dna is the blueprint
of life and one of the first uh
objectives is to actually learn to read
this dna right that was the first thing
we started doing because till the time
we read what is in the blueprint we
cannot make sense out of it right
so in early sequencing days in like
1960s the first rna sequence which is of
alanine trna was sequenced it took five
people for three years working to
determine just 76 nucleotides so this is
how we started sequencing we were not
sequencing genomes in the in the
beginning we were trying to standardize
the technology to understand how you
read this
and subsequently over years we started
taking
like baby steps where we went ahead from
that to one base per month
then to a thousand bases per day and by
the time we sequenced the human genome
we were already doing 10 million bases
per day
right
and till that time is when you know we
actually this is a quiz for kids who
would like to enter their answers um to
say what this event is
so this is basically a landmark event in
the history of current biotechnology and
data sciences is when we launch the
draft of the human genome project right
and this is the big machine that at that
point was used to sequence it
it took effort from several countries
and a very large number of sequencing
centers to give us the first draft of
the human genome sequence which was 23
human chromosomes with 3 billion bases
right
why were we interested in sequencing
simple reason to understand human
disease and evolution if you can compare
the genome sequence of somebody who is
diseased versus somebody who is normal
the uh
anticipation was that we will be able to
understand diseases better at a
molecular level and if you can some if
you can understand something better it
is easier to treat it so as the previous
speaker was referring to a large number
of methods for this kind of data
analysis the objective is very clear
that you need to understand human
disease and evolution and that is why
there was an intense amount of effort
put into place
but this was only a project where you
were trying to understand and sanitize
the technology
and then we went ahead from this basic
sequencing methods to something we
understand as next generation
sequencing methods
and with the advent of ngs
now there are a very large number of
sequencing projects going on across the
world where a few countries are actually
sequence their entire population so
these sequencing efforts actually have
gone uh the scalability is unimaginable
we are generating data at a base and we
don't really know how to analyze it so
that is where the power of data sciences
lies in
it is very critical right now for
students who have disabled basically
deciding on uh
you know a research objective try to
learn data analysis because you actually
have a lot of data available that needs
to be analyzed in context of what is now
dizzy associated among all this plethora
sequence that you see
and the starting resource that i would
recommend to all of you is genome maybe
so genome aggregation database is trying
to aggregate all the genome sequencing
projects at one place so you don't have
to wander around several places for this
kind of data so you can go to genome
ready for that reference
now when you say you are trying to
compare individuals with and without
disease what are we trying to compare or
what are we trying to look at we are
trying to come back at a point where we
can look at genomic variations right
now genomic variations can be of several
types the most common ones are single
nucleotide polymorphism these are called
in general language substitutions
we will read more about them in the next
slide then there are indels which is
insertion deletions and they can
actually change the protein function
then there are structural variations
then there are tandem repeat variations
segmental duplications translocation and
most of us in our undergrad or in
masters must have come across these
terminologies where these actually are
impacting the way the chromosome is or
the sequences arranged in an order and
then when that arrangement goes here
you do you expect to see um that there
can be a disease phenotype
now when you talk of single nucleotide
polymorphism it means that it's a
variation at a single nucleotide say for
example
let's say there is a gene a and that
gene a has an exon right we all know
what exons are
in exon one at some position let us say
500 in a population you either see a or
c
now in technical terms we call alleles
at the nuclear level so there is an ale
and there is a cla
now let's say a is the most common
allele like ninety percent of uh of the
times the thus like a is observed so we
call it as a major alley
and c is observed the rest 10 percent of
the time so it's a minor array
so since humans are deployed we get one
pair of chromosomes from our mother the
other from the father
then so basically what you actually will
see is that either the individuals will
have a a
ac or cc right at this particular
position
now how do you decide that it is an snp
is when the minor le and in this case
that is c is present at a frequency of
more than one percent in the population
so let's take two examples in the first
case if 94 people have c which is the
major lead and six percent happy which
is a minor le you say this as an snp
in the other case if you see a similar
situation
but the percentage of the minor allele
is not even one percent that you start
calling it a mutation now this you need
to understand is heavily context
dependent
the reason being that if you are looking
at rare variation then this definition
will change
and that is one has to now look at
single nucleotide polymorphism
definition or with or genomic variation
in context of what you are trying to
look for and obviously when you are
looking for rare variants you need to
sequence a very very large number of
individuals and then of course when both
the maternal and the paternal allele are
same that's an homozygous snp when they
are different it's a heterozygous snp
and they are present everywhere like
they can be in utrs introns right side
they can be encoding regions where they
may or may not change the amino acid in
most in almost all these cases they
might have an impact on the phenotype
now the question that you might ask is
that you sequence an individual sequence
another individual so one person has
disease x the other person does not have
disease x just compare the sequence and
you are good to go right you can now
actually identify the differences and
say this is what is causing the disease
it is not that simple and that is where
what we are discussing today
any complex disease is not happening
because of a single genomic variant
there are many genomic variants which we
call as polygenic
in interaction with the environmental
factors are actually causing the
phenotype in this case i have shown the
example of coronary artery disease
so complex disorders i must repeat this
because this is a very very important
factor
results from contributions of
multiple genomic variants
and genes and that is why they are
called as polygenic and they work in
conjunction with the physical and the
social environment to bring out the
phenotype and this is the challenge we
are trying to now resolve
when you compare to individuals you will
get anywhere between three to five
million snps which are different
which of those snps are associated with
the disease that's the first question
second which of them might cause the
disease there can be several reasons why
the disease is manifested
and that is where the challenge lies in
order to
address this challenge
there are two basic approach that
approaches that are applied one we call
it as a candidate gene approach the
other one is a genome-wide association
studies and we'll very quickly look at
both of them what do you mean by
candidate gene approach
so in a candidate gene approach what you
actually are doing you are basically
making an intelligent guess
like say for example you are interested
to identify a genetic risk factor for a
particular disease condition which is a
complex disease
and you now need to know what are the
genes contributing to this phenotype so
that you can now look at the variation
in those genes
now this mostly is done within family
members or it can also be unrelated
cases but the point is you need to have
some estimate
of what kind of biological
components might be involved say for
example i have taken an example here
if you are studying alcoholism why some
people are getting the data addicted to
alcohol and you want to know the genetic
components of that
uh the most logical choices would be to
look at their alcohol
metabolic pathways and a particular
genes like alcohol dehydrogenase or
aldehyde dehydrogenase these are logical
options for you to start
and if you do see that there are several
alleles of this genes in the population
making it a very strong case that you
now know that they are actually very
among individuals now you can actually
apply a candidate gene approach
start looking for variation only in
these set of genes and then identify
polymorphism which might be associated
to the disease
and subsequently establishing why this
might also cause the disease so here you
are actually also digging deep into the
mechanism of what that variation might
be doing
the problem is in most cases this kind
of educated guess either has failed or
it is extremely difficult to make and
that is where genome-wide associations
are association studies are done where
you are actually following a very
data-driven approach you take two
cohorts two groups of individuals one
normal for the phenotype the other one
actually has the phenotype and when i
say phenotype i am saying the disease
and then you sequence them compare
identify snps and then start looking for
association
of these snps with the disease phenotype
now the word associated is kept or we
know very categorically here reason is
association is not equal to causation
you may find snps which are associated
with the disease they might not be
causing the disease as such so jivas
actually will help you
identify at least shortlist those
candidates and then explore them deeper
with respect to what is their role
in disease manifestation
several studies have actually there are
many many jivas that have been done till
date and do we do have some success
stories where if you look at this
publication they actually have listed
several traits
against which genes were identified
using jivas and they ultimately actually
allowed discovery of
drug candidates who treat these diseases
so we do have success stories means
these methods work obviously the number
of jeepas that has been performed versus
the outcome is
not comparable so we need more
intelligent methods of doing that and
maybe a better readout
so what actually uh is going on right
now is there is a
very big effort going on to catalog
genomic variation
of different populations all across the
world and then also trying to assess
which of these genomic variations
might have a clinical implication so
there is if you look at i have listed a
few papers from last two to three years
some of them are old like clinvar but
clinvar keeps updating very regularly
then there is a genome
100k project but some of them are very
new as new as this month so i would
recommend that you actually read these
publications it will give you in context
of what is really going on how are these
genomic variations documented and
analyzed and why do you need these kind
of resources when you actually have a
reference you know so you actually
reference you know is just uh
it's like 70 percent one individuals
read out despite the fact that when the
genome sequence was done they were like
the pooled sample of 20 individuals but
it is mostly laid out from one
individual so it's not really
representative of how diverse we are and
that is why you need to sequence from
various populations in different
contexts
now for today i have kept a very simple
example of what we did in our lab and i
will be very quickly describing that so
you need to focus because i have very
very quickly finish this
so our lab has been addressed
to understand what is the role of
mitochondrial dna in human diseases and
if you look at the this is i've just
shown a representation of mitochondria
if you look at the
electron transport chain it has five
complexes the ones which are shown in
green are encoded by nuclear dna the
ones which are shown by red are included
by mitochondrial dna it is not very
difficult to make a judgment that there
has to be a very
intense crosstalk between the two
genomes for mitochondria to function
properly
and it is not just the energy metabolism
mitochondria is involved in practically
all central metabolic pathways in the
cell making it an extremely critical
organelle and given that this organelle
has its own dna makes it a very strong
case to look at what mutations in
mitochondrial dna
might lead to disease
phenotypes
now one of the things ah not everybody
understands the structure of
mitochondrial dna so i have kept a very
small introduction
it's a circular molecule it is 16 kb in
size it is mostly maternally inherited
there are two rnas 22 trnas and 13
protein coding genes in mitochondrial
dna a single non-coding region which is
d-loop
and over 3000 other proteins are
required for mitochondria to function
properly which are encoded by nuclear
dna right
and there is a very very big repertoire
of genome sequence data available across
different populations that one can use
to now look at disease association
context of
mitochondrial diseases the problem with
genotype phenotype correlation in
mitochondria is that
when you actually see these point
mutations the symptoms manifest in many
many different ways making it very
difficult to understand uh or establish
pathogenicity of change in mitochondria
and that is where
we developed an algorithm which we
called as bit snp score it was published
long time back
and the objective is how do you
score variation
for their disease association again i am
not talking of causation here so it is
very important that i keep using the
word association again and again
and comparison is performed against
normal data sets so i'll very quickly
show you what we did
so first things first was
i needed to understand which kind of
mutations in mitochondria
have an experimental evidence that this
actually might cause the disease so that
was my first objective is to first list
out
reported biochemical defects which are
like low complex activities or
functional studies which are done using
trans mitochondrial hybrids to establish
that some of these mutations are
actually causing the disease are not
just associated with them
use them as a basis to select which
tools are good to now select these kind
of variations from the plethora of other
variation that i see
and then subsequently i designed a
scoring scheme which i will not have
time to explain today
but the whole point is if a variant is
of very little importance it was given a
score of one
if it is of very you know if it is
really causing a problem with
mitochondrial replication shift for
example it is given a score of ten
so between this one and ten the other
scores as you have seen here are
assigned based on the anticipated impact
that these mutations or might have on
the mitochondrial function
and then when you actually have several
such mutations in an individual we
multiply all the scores and not add them
so this is the and logic i would request
you to go and read the paper on why we
applied this logic it's very interesting
and once we did that and the pipeline
was ready
we actually applied it on patient data
sets
which are ataxia and snp and we applied
it on almost 600 individuals
uh which are both having metabolic as
well as neurodegenerative cases okay
for normal sequences we use the context
dependent normal for indian ataxia
patients we use the indian normal data
for japanese
disease individuals we used japanese
centenarians so that the background
variation effect is not there
and centenarians were an extremely good
uh controlled set because these are
people who were 100 years old and they
were absolutely healthy which means
any mutation in these
individuals might not be causing the
disease by themselves
so when we applied this whole uh
algorithm on this 600 plus individuals
whose you know mitochondrial dna data
sets
we could actually prioritize only three
to four percent of total variations
it's not five or six hundred between any
two individuals we actually could
prioritize very very small set
and obviously we also were able to
identify novel variations in some genes
which were not reported before so it was
very interesting to see that the method
was working and we were able to identify
some noble variants which were not even
reported by that time
ah so basically this is a new uh this
actually still is something which most
methods cannot do
uh one observation we made back then was
that
rare variants are high scoring variance
as opposed to the general understanding
that common variants are disease
associated we didn't observe that even
at that point and now there are more and
more papers who are actually trying to
scout for rare variations for the
association so this is one of the first
studies where we could actually observe
this and reported it and we could find
noble disease associated variants with
this application
moving forward again i will not be able
to describe much of this work but since
you know that in each
cell there are several mitochondria and
within each mitochondria there are
several mitochondrial dna
and we could actually assess this
mitochondrial dna for disease
association the second logical thing was
to now look at more than 3000 proteins
which were coded by nuclear dna but have
a mitochondrial function to see the
holistic impact of variation in an
individual
both for nuclear
and mitochondrial dna for disease
association studies
now here we used uh several resources to
identify which nuclear
encoded proteins have mitochondrial
function
and just bear with me on this slide for
a minute
so if you look at the left hand panel we
utilized several resources
to identify
uh nuclear encoded proteins with
mitochondrial function identified which
of the mutations in these proteins
actually have been reported to be
pathogenic in clinvar which means they
are clinically actionable
and map these variations onto the genome
asia 100k project which actually also
has data on almost 600 individuals from
india
we then took all these uh mapping where
you actually found this and can map this
to disgenet data which is genes and
variations associated to human disease
so we could generate a mitochondrial
gene disease in network
and in this network we could also
identify loss of function variations
from genomic datasets if some of you
actually find it difficult to follow in
this presentation you can always
write back to me because there is a lot
of background information one needs to
know to understand this
the logic that you need to understand is
what we are trying to do we were trying
to see whether
pathogenic variations reported for the
rest of the world
are they also pathogenic or are they
also loss of function in b
in the asian subcontinent or
particularly for indian population or
not
what we actually observe that is that
that one needs to perform population
specific mapping of clinically relevant
variation we cannot rely on a loss of
function variation data coming from the
rest of the world to our population
because we don't see that happening
so this is very important now that one
has to generate population specific
references
and population specific variation data
which might not be reported actually for
the rest of the world because they are
not yellow up there but they can be here
so this is a very important message and
this recently was also endorsed by
genome media in the recent paper where
they actually say the same thing
now one of the things that one can do
with this kind of platform is you can
study code morbidities because now it's
a network we are saying may be one
disease
and several genes and one gene and
several disables so this is something
that we are looking at and particularly
from indian population context
when we did enrichment analysis we could
see that certain pathways like defects
in vitamin and co-factor metabolism
productivation
dna repair pathways these are very very
important to study in asian population
context
so this is the first platform that we
have identified to look at comorbidities
i didn't actually focus it from a
co-operative perspective because it
requires a little bit more background to
uh
you know understand it at a more
detailed level but if any one of you are
already working on this kind of strategy
we have actually provided all of this
resource as a workflow system in galaxy
so no programming experience is required
if you have a question you can come on
this platform and generate all your own
custom workflows on the fly you really
don't have to learn anything to make
this
but you know to basically ask questions
and a lot of information is already
provided as part of this platform and we
have already analyzed more than 150 000
individuals with almost uh
six hundred thousand thousand variations
it's a very large data that we analyzed
for this project
now some of the things that i am not
discussing today but i would really
recommend you to go and read them
is that some many many times you will
actually hear that synonymous variations
the a variation that do not change the
amino acid
will not have an impact on the disease
phenotype uh that is not true we
actually have shown in this work that it
actually can have disease association
impact
and second is since the data size that
we have now looking at is going to you
know by 2025 in another three years
the genomic data will bypass the data
that we generate on social media so now
you can imagine we are talking of
exabytes of data we have not even
talking of petabytes now
now that kind of data when you have you
don't not only have the challenge of
genotype phenotype correlation you also
have the challenge of analyzing and
handling this data and that is where we
developed frog again
it's not for discussion today
so basically what we are now doing with
all this computational platform you
might say what is the application of
this so the application is pretty
evident in 2016 the mitochondria
medicine society actually recommended
next generation sequencing as the first
line of diagnostics for mitochondrial
diseases so it is not something that you
might do this is something which is a
highly recommended method to diagnose
mitochondrial diseases
and i am part of the clinical domain
working groups we are actually trying to
map every variation as per the uh
approved guidelines by acm acmg and amp
standards that we recommended
two years ago and were approved by kenji
and now we are working as a clinical
domains working group with a very large
team of
clinicians to see how do we actually
translate this knowledge
into a clinical context
now my lab has been developing these
resources over a very long period of
time and we continue to do that from
different contexts now we are now trying
to see
in one of our new projects is how
pathogenic variations in mitochondria
make individuals more predisposed to
infections because the other vertical of
my lab work on infectious diseases so we
are now merging the two domains in in a
very logical context
now
i would like you to tell that why is
this important because these are
basically the four tenants of
personalized medicine personalized as in
you need to know how genetic variation
drives individual treatment it has to be
predictive
one should be able to identify what kind
of disease condition one is predisposed
to it should be preventive if i know
that somebody is predisposed to diabetes
at the age of 30 there can be lifestyle
changes introduced and the person may
not manifest the disease at all and it
should be participatory like the patient
has to have informed choices and take
responsibility of their own health
now one thing that i would recommend all
of you to go back and check is the new
developments happening in precision
medicine
so we have evolved from the reference
human genome
as a reference to population specific
genomes to human pan genomes because now
we know as and when we are sequencing
more and more human genomes there is
additional four to five million sites
that are getting added to the data sets
which means that we need to now capture
the complexity of human band genome with
respect to precision medicine if we have
to go anywhere forward from this point
onwards so have a look at the human pan
genomes progress that's something that
is very very recent and is still being
discussed on how to really do it there
are recommendations but they are still
not implemented so this is something
which is an ongoing activity so i would
recommend anyone of you who is
interested in genomics
should be reading about this context
now i would like to basically take last
five minutes to before i close is to
tell you that genomics is not only about
personalized medicine and i'll give you
an example here
now kathleen falbeck actually was
imprisoned uh for killing all her four
babies right it's some of them it is
actually told said to be one of the most
horrific crimes that somebody can
perform now the problem was that
scientific evidence uh so mayo clinic
pediatric cardiologist actually michael
ackermann and a team of scientists
linked the death of these babies to a
specific mutation which was leading to
sudden infant death syndrome
so this lady actually has not killed at
least two of her babies is that what
they could establish
for the other two they require data from
the father which was not available but
the whole point is that imagine uh
genetics actually
freed this woman who was convicted of
killing her four babies so genetics and
precision medicine you know this
precision medicine is for health but
genetic genetics and genomics in general
have a wide array of applications like
even within our lab which i have not
told you today we actually use it to
understand emr
so there are a wide variety of array of
applications that you can think of and
these are all places where you can probe
as uh you know as future prospects for
your career
now as i told you that my lab works on
two domains one is amr and the
antimicrobial register of infections and
the other is mitochondrial diseases i
would like to show you something very
different in last two minutes that we
have done
so for some of you who does not
understand what antimicrobial resistance
is
so i'm actually shifting gears here so
there's no more genomics
from now onwards
so i'm pretty sure all of you know about
the discovery of sir alexander fleming
he discovered the first natural
antibiotic penicillin and in his noble
speech nobel prize speech he actually
said that
if we don't take
penicillin or other antibiotics
carefully the bacteria will develop
resistance against these antibiotics and
they may no longer work now this was
something that he said in 1945
and this actually is coming out to be
true because now we are dealing with a
problem of antimicrobial resistance
it is a major issue i wanted all of you
to know about it it is called a silent
pandemic because we don't discuss it the
way we discuss covet
but who has declared amr as one of the
top 10 global public health threats
facing humanity today so it's a very
major problem and that is why we thought
it is important to sensitize younger
generation about the issue of amr
because it cannot be solved without
participation from all of us
and we also wanted that this
participation need not start when we are
already adults
what if we can explain this concept
to young children as young as 11 12
years old 13 years old can we explain a
very hard scientific concept to them in
a manner which allows them to change
behavior it is not just understanding
something it should influence uh
individuals in a manner where they are
able to change their action against
something which is not happening right
so i'll with the permission of
the organizers i would like to play a
one minute video and i hope you enjoy it
this is basically a teaser for the game
so that you know what the game actually
talks about
uh i hope it works here we go
[Music]
so
she
peace
[Music]
so this is a video and i thought
it's important for the community as you
know we are scientists so if it is a
problem that impacts all of us it's
something that we have to collectively
do and we are very happy that when we
developed this game it was it became one
of the finalists in the international
educational games competition
across the world so i would really like
all of you to go to the gyasa or my home
page and
play this game popularize it so that we
actually can contribute to this social
issue which is amr it's not just a
scientific problem anymore
so
as mohit was saying i work with a very
very large group of people who are not
always sitting in my lab so i do a lot
of crowdsourcing projects and i work
with some brilliant kids they are doing
excellent
work right now
these two kids happen to be my favorite
because they published in international
peer review journals from my lab when
they were still finishing their school
so they were very very young at that
point in time
but extremely talented and it actually
what i could see in them as talent was
later endorsed by the fact that puja
became the gates cambridge fellow
ashma became the gold's water scholar
and they both are on full scholarship
for their masters and phd programs
so this is a message to the students out
there we will be discussing more in the
panel
is that you don't need really an age or
a degree to do science
passion is what should drive you for
doing scientific discovery and i have uh
i like my experience with school kids
it's extremely rewarding in that context
a recommendation which i'll again
highlight in the panel is that be like a
space knife interdisciplinary
today if you are doing biology learn at
least one programming language very
strongly recommended the kind of data
that is being generated it will be
extremely difficult if you don't know
data analysis so do that
and with that i would like to conclude
my presentation for today by thanking my
lab members both in india and france and
i thank all the funding agencies who
have supported our lab over the years
i would also like to thank my institute
and i'm also happy and very proud to
tell you that we are among the top
four institutes worldwide who actually
contribute to biological databases open
source biological databases to the world
and they are highly cited so this is a
very
this is a proud thing for india because
we are actually in line with ebi and
ncbis i'm really really happy to share
that with all of you
uh we do some 3d printing not bio
printing in the lab so if some of you
are interested in doing that you are
very much welcome to come here and use
this device
and of course there are open phd and
postdoc positions in the lab so if any
one of you are interested and you saw a
brief of what my lab does if you need to
know we can chat and take it forward
from there so with that thank you so
much again for having me and i'm happy
to take any questions
okay thank you so much doctor that was
indeed a very interesting talk and yes
we have a bunch of questions that we
would like to ask you but as we are
running out of time i would be emailing
these questions and then get back to the
participants with the consensus
and
it's time now that we move to the
academic panel discussion
all right so from cover 19 disease to
alzheimer's disease so far we have
learned about the various active fields
of academic research in india but as a
student interested in pursuing a career
in academic bioinformatics research few
questions might arise such as what is
the future of bioinformatics and data
science in india what are the various
challenges and opportunities that the
paint might face
i would now like to invite all our
panelists
and our moderator for the session dr
mohit mazumgar to please turn on their
cameras
and
now it's time that we have
the academy panel discussion on future
of bioinformatics and data science in
india challenges and opportunities
as i had introduced dr unsure and dr
suchi i would now like to take this time
out to introduce dr sagan
dr sagar is working in the area of
computational biology
from last 15 years he has served as
various academic and administrative
positions in academic institutions he
has published 30 plus research articles
in peer-reviewed national and
international journals and
has one patent as well he has received
foreign grant from bst so to conduct
research on asthma and allergic diseases
he is a life member of resigners and
related disorders society of india and
bioclue society of india as well he has
delivered 10 invited talks in national
and international conferences and
seminars we are pleased to have you all
among us and
uh dr muhammad i would now like to pass
on the stage to you to take this session
again
thank you sunalika and it's uh it's an
honor to be here on this academic panel
as a moderator with all the educators
here amongst us
so um one of the main objective coming
to this session and learning about the
different application of bioinformatics
and leading to the fact that uh the very
important fact is about the
interdisciplinary nature of this uh
subject bioinformatics and with the
substantial growth and growing influence
of bioinformatics in health and
environment and the society how we can
utilize this uh how we can integrate
this into our education how well we can
integrate this what are the challenges
and where where are we with all of this
uh
in india and specifically what are the
new
uh
opportunities that we see in india in
terms of uh the new educational policy
and then the challenges and the benefits
of bioinformatics being a subject or the
research behind the bioinformatics could
be
something that could be done online and
like as
dr ranchu said that many of her projects
are are between labs and it's
collaborative in nature so how different
it is from you know traditional research
versus bioinformatics and the
collaborative nature of all of this and
then uh the the some of the promising
areas because we have a huge community
of students who are biologists who are
coming from a background of
biotechnology and other life science
backgrounds where the
they would help with the promising areas
that an expert is seeing in india and
asia where there are opportunities which
would bring us to the last point would
be the job opportunities in india and
academia and uh like for students from
different backgrounds who are competing
masters some of them starting at a high
school level versus someone who is doing
masters in phd in bioinformatics and
starting from there so these are some of
the questions that our team thought
would be helpful for the students based
on their feedback as well as
based on what we have been observing as
a bioinformatics edu training and
educational company working with some of
these students who are joining us and
working with the expert and developing
some of the uh some of the projects
while
learning a lot of skill sets so with
that introduction um i would want to
invite all the panelists to have this
academic to be a part of this academic
panel discussion to help uh find answers
or to have that discussion to give their
opinion and with that like let's uh we
would want to start with this
question of
is there a need for data science
education for life-size students now to
define this uh question uh because
bioinformatics we as we know and as from
our experience has been evolving really
rapidly and that's what we have observed
in the presentations as well that uh
i mean the the integration of new
research there are thousands of articles
getting published there are new
algorithms which are coming up and there
are new uh new data types that we are
now uh
um that we are not now looking at and
during dr anxious presentation we saw
that there are new updates which are
really important now uh to cover so uh
like how can we do this effectively and
is there a need for like education and
revision of those curriculums so
uh maybe we can start with uh
dr sagar who's joining and he's a
seasoned uh
um educator so
welcome sir and uh what are your
thoughts on bioinformatics and data
science education in india and uh
especially your experience in amity
university mumbai
uh thank you so much for a nice
introduction
uh is i'm audible properly
yes yes
so as we see that uh
data science requirement in the life
sciences actually it is a must
if we see that in the biotechnology and
other courses are there
uh now the experimental things that is
equipment things are tremendously
developed that is if you know that is
earlier
before their peoples are doing
everything in the labs with the help of
doing essays and so on
at that time the limited data is there
limited outcome is there if suppose
someone doing an experiment on a protein
it's just going to uh purify the protein
and then they're just doing a acid along
with that if someone uh
doing a work of genomics in that case
also they just went to amplify and deal
with only
single
gene molecules but now there are the
tremendous advancement is there i think
in these techniques for example protein
purification is
so
there is a large amount of the data is
generated if you see that
if single run of iron torrent machine
they just give you uh 300 gb of the data
and
then it is very much important to
analyze this data how you just process
this data and analyze this data now the
efforts of experimental biologists is
reduced in some extent but they need to
learn this data science
and once data science because the data
which is generated by these techniques
that is there our mass spec is there so
what data output is there that is huge
data is there and you need to process
the data and you have to come up with
some useful information out of it for
example if
you run the
uh
mass spec then also you will get the
large amount of the masses you have to
analyze
which are the important molecules or
which are the protein expressed by a
particular cell mostly uh we talking
about the
cancerous cell and healthy cell so
suppose you
perform the mass spec analysis
then
uh to
identify these masses and proteins
are you need to uh learn this advanced
data science then and then only you just
able to handle
so for that you need to learn the
perl
requirement is there python requirement
is there our requirement is that so
these languages will be helpful to you
to process the data and associated tool
which is able to analyze what components
are there and then you just come up with
a
particular protein or particular gene
which is expressed or expressed in that
diseased cell and uh which is not there
in the healthy cell
so
if you see there is a perception in
india that is the bioinformatics peoples
are
looking at bioinformatics that is they
just only
give some artistic images and for
publication only means peoples are only
in that area that is only blocking
simulation and we just creating a
picture for publication itself means if
you uh see the approaches of the
experimental biologists they just want
only you just to do the talking and give
it to us then we will add it and we will
publish the data but
these things are now changed that is all
companies have developed a lot of
pipelines are there and even the normal
biologists able to do this talking and
simulation stuff now the need of the
data science that is people need or
student need to learn advanced languages
as well as advanced tools to process and
analyze big data generated by this
genomics and proteomics
machines which
currently people are using
you thank you so much for your insights
on that so to summarize it i think uh
you're saying that and also like that
could be seen is that the wet lab
technology has evolved and the data
generation is now easy now compared to
before when we were focused more on
single experiments generating now we are
discussing and we are generating high
throughput data which is uh simpler to
generate than before and also less cost
effective i think and the
the
requirement is now more for the analysis
part because the data generation
capabilities have increased the
technology has evolved
so that that's how data science is now
becoming a very important tool to handle
this in your data to get meaningful
insights from it uh that requires coding
uh some of the coding
challenges then someone has to be
maybe
learn more about how to apply maybe than
a hardcore coding but to be able to
apply that basic coding is of course is
needed and some bioinformatics related
coding information would be needed for
the students to
dive into this field which is getting
now uh maybe
the
way to access this is becoming easier um
with the
com with the companies
bringing this
pipelines and also
labs such as dr ranchos
are generating those resources to be
utilized by the students
yes
okay that's uh that's something very
insightful i think
maybe now
we learned about that that why data
science is important from a
bioinformatics prospective and how also
bioinformatics has been seen before by
the by biologists where they can see
very few applications and as the data
has grown i guess uh so tremendously now
we are getting all those insights and
that awareness is somehow coming into
picture so um the the question the next
question that i would want to ask
dr anshu is that how how do you tackle
these challenges or integration of this
information into students
curriculum and the courses like are are
the university adopting to these new uh
new technologies and approaches and
integrating them or there are other
opportunities that the students are
getting to learn about this uh through
some maybe internships or something like
that so is there a structure or is there
a is there a way that the universities
are kind of incorporating this into
their
into their
core structure
right so so
in the new education policy as you know
the way the core structure is to be for
undergrads is that after first year they
wish to move fields they should be able
to do that
so
recently i have designed a course for
the new education policy for undergrad
and data analysis
for madhya pradesh so i'm on the board
of studies to basically design that
course so the problem is not designing
the course but i have also told them
parallely is that who is going to teach
it
you we don't have enough people here in
the country who can really take up these
courses with the students of course
design is not the challenge here we can
write anything on paper
but the ultimate challenge is to put
that to practice
now national laboratories are not
equipped to handle the size of students
that we currently generate in university
systems
we cannot do that despite the fact we
try our best we can handle probably a
few thousands but we are not talking
about numbers and thousands here so and
we need that kind of a workforce to
really understand it
so then it everything boils down to the
fact that how motivated these students
are
to learn these skills
so i think the job that the universities
can do here
even if they cannot teach the students
the hard skills
if they can convey the message that this
skills are critical
it will allow these kids to actually
start taking up assignments in that
domain
because i think data analysis skills if
you one has to learn it has to be the
best learning happens when you do it
partly as structured teaching
but majorly as project based learning
reason is it is it cannot be structured
to a very large extent because as you
rightly said it is an evolving field
and it is evolving so fast that by the
time you bring a structure into practice
it will change
so we need to give them the basic
fundamental understanding of what the
field is rather than start teaching them
very you know only very specific methods
they should be able to adapt to new
methods and that is where
training on what is fair data
what are ontologies
what is basically when you say reference
human genome what is reference and i
think all of this can be taught by life
science faculty in universities you
don't need any kind of data analysis
skills to do that
so i think the way to approach this
problem
is to have to train the teachers
to convey this message across to the
students
and then you will actually see the real
impact of the new education policy also
if we do it the more traditional ways we
have been doing will not be able to
scale it up
and that is i think a more logical
practical way of approaching this
problem
yeah that's a great point actually
um which act which kind of simplifies
this for many faculty who might be
saying something
yes yes i was coming to you
so as she rightly said that you know
it's uh obviously the manpower which is
missing but at the same time at the i
think uh
at the school level when we are having
eleventh and fifth uh what i have
observed is you know the
boards have actually given them choices
of taking either biology or mathematics
so many times you know the students are
not taught mathematics and when we are
talking about data science you cannot do
without mathematician that's a very big
um i think negative that i can see and
for that you know it's very difficult to
tease them
so the people who are actually coming
from with the biology background
they are actually uh because they are
scared of mathematics and uh without
mathematics it's very difficult to get
people and train them as well
right so i was under the impression that
people are allowed to take both because
when i did my 11 12 there was no minding
on not taking maths and biology together
yeah i i agree that even i was of the
same impression but then
that this is my personal uh experience i
would say so one of my very close
relative actually she told me i was like
forcing her that don't do that but then
she said that no the school is straight
away saying that either you go for
biology of mathematics so when the
students used to concerns to take up
first-year students when they used to
say i did never believed it but you know
having a experience of this kind i saw
that that's not the fact
so i think you cannot just segregate
biology with mathematics when we are
talking about data science and something
which is really
the need of the r we can say
um i just want to add here that maybe
there is a silver lining which is uh
statistics so uh statistics i think uh
by utilizing statistics and uh we
we do have those in the curriculum in
most of the
most of the
biotechnology and all those allied
fields and uh we think that maybe data
science is an advanced way advanced
statistics that we are utilizing and
maybe if it is only application based
not like coding based because when many
of the bioinformatics challenges are to
develop maybe
some of these pipelines workflows but uh
many of the biologists are just trying
to find uh ways to analyze it and get to
the biological part of it more deep dive
into the pathways and look at the
mechanism and understand all those
things maybe they can utilize the data
science as a tool rather than data
science going in depth of data science
what do you think
yeah i think what you are referring to
is something which in uh which is gaming
terms see i'm also a gamer so i always
go back to the gaming concept so
uh it is called as onboarding
so the learning curve cannot be very
steep
so you need to first on board and then
there is a concept of scaffolding where
you really get people involved in the
process
so i think before the the anybody not
just school children anybody coming into
data sciences there has to be an
onboarding step which has to be a small
you know learning curve
and then you start going on from there
and that is why i think project based
learning is important because you have a
question in mind
there will be some basic interest
because normally what i see in a lot of
universities because i actually go and
teach at a lot of places
is that the compute the programming is
taught by computer science faculty
there is no context of biology
students fail to make the connection
between why you know where do i use what
so i think that is where you need
interdisciplinary faculty who can bring
that context
and then if that is not possible do a
project-based learning at least the
question is clear in their mind so no
they at least understand what they're
doing i completely agree with you
now i think this makes sense in the
context of the presentation also that dr
anshu's presentation covered very basic
uh understanding of where these
technologies can be applied so maybe a
keyword based like you're saying that
people need to be more like students
need to be become more and more
comfortable with this
basic part of the the these like
reference genome you said ontologies you
said fair data so these are very common
um terminologies that could be a part of
the basic training and after the basic
training when they are comfortable
it would be more about project based
training so that would be a proper
pipeline maybe after the basic
understanding you do a project based uh
learning and choose your own
specialization choose your own um maybe
application of bioinformatics that in
metagenomics i'll do this in
transcriptomics i'll do this and uh in
structural bioinformatics i can do this
so that clarity if it's there and you
also said that if if that is something
that a life science
faculty can easily teach can easily help
the student community understand some of
those facts to get them more interested
and more exploring exploring by
themselves and get that enthusiasm
which is
right now missing maybe due to
not being aware and also some fear of
mathematics and algorithms and all of
that
see i think what i'll just take uh 10
more seconds is to also understand that
till the time the research faculty get
convinced that data sciences are
important the message will not trickle
down
and i think the alpha fault
has
been able to make that mental impact
where experimental biologists are able
to appreciate why data sciences are so
critical i think before that there was
partial acceptance with alpha phone that
acceptance was gone multiple force so i
think this is a right time for us you
know it's like when the iron is hot kind
of the situation so right now is the
time when it can really make them
that message has to trickle down and i
think that message if only comes from
data scientist people will not accept it
it has to be the entire community
speaking the same same language
so you're saying we were looking for
more validation maybe a few ai based
drugs and
then we will be more uh accepting
it
which is i think more acceptance uh for
the insidico part of the work rather
than you know just
uh
allowing that wet lab
believing the wet lab results more yeah
all right that's i think that concludes
this is a great point and i think we can
now uh maybe move to the next point
which brings us to the
challenge of how like uh you think that
integration of this hybrid training
which is like many university they
believe and many institutions and many
students they think that uh maybe uh
going to
uh the university and working uh is the
right uh way of learning but uh during
the covet uh many universities face this
challenge of training students online
and
and then they they were able to do this
successfully but do you see an
integration of both of them because uh i
i saw that uh latest um
latest announcement by our prime
minister and he was emphasizing on that
that there should be an hybrid model so
what are your thoughts about this hybrid
model and is it possible because in
bioinformatics and data science yes that
is possible but in an educational system
is it something that is going to happen
so
i make some points that is uh
when in the pandemic situation
so
we
turn from offline to online suddenly
and uh it is difficult for first one
semester uh we have found a lot of
difficulties that
students not able to understand anything
and a lot of issues related to
the biotechnology subject those are
molecular biology or microbiology and so
on
uh the students are theoretically they
understand
[Music]
and also
uh in virtual world uh you need your
proper attention uh when the lecture or
anything is
if you just sitting in front of
computers or time being and if you not
listening in properly you not understand
and you need to revise uh and you read
it again
so
that issues are there in the online
system but
we are escaped from that for
computational biology because we
successfully conducted all the
practicals all the theory lecture but
also uh that is the students
in your presence when they are learning
then it is uh some a different impact is
there
impact is there if everything is online
it is a little bit difficult to not
understand and uh
we also evaluated the student uh
after examination
oh the score of means passing percentage
of the student
uh in lockdown periods of university
around 95 to 98
and
then after uh
now uh physically they are attending and
in this semester it is suddenly dropped
till 70
so huge different 30 percent difference
is that
why this
people's means many peoples are
qualified this because mcqs are there
and open book exams are conducted by the
colleges and universities
and that's why there are
uh what we can say misuse of this and by
and even though the knowledge level of
the student is not that much means if
you just uh
when as a teacher you just recall the
previous thing because the syllabus is
designed in such a way that you need to
remember the earlier semester thing then
you just um able to go for the next
subject but when you just try to recall
the back subject they're not able to
understand what actually they learn
so it is very difficult to teacher
to
teach each and every subject in one life
only the thing is that if they
are doing the specific courses
courses on their own
on their own means
the university system is different but
if the students are doing a process in
online room paying the money
then they have tremendous attention
but that attention is not there
[Music]
that's why
a little bit problem but finally
the system is online or offline
doesn't matter
education policy i think uh they have
implemented a lot of
he can off the subject and so on because
if you know the first time 12th past the
students they actually don't know what
subject is this actually what i have to
even though it is imposed by the parent
that is you have to learn these and
this subject is
subject
but student come to know after two three
years when he is in last year of
graduation
he come to know this
they can switch and they just go into
the
thank you so much i mean that kind of uh
is
in between and i think kobe 19 has
helped us
maybe through these challenges to us
and now we have this experience of
working online and saw those challenges
now there are good things that we can
take from there and that has been taken
up already and uh there is an
integration and there is more
flexibility and customization that could
be more personalized and that
personalized training is maybe an answer
is one of some of the answers required
for maybe better training and better
outcome for every student because we
also get like good students but there
are some students who are uh who are not
been able to do that in in such focused
way which which they should have so i
think great point and that's uh that's
something that is a great thing for
moving forward that brings us to our
last uh last question
one thing here
so see the hybrid mode that the prime
minister is talking about so there are
two ways of doing that first is we can
actually have d by i kids
and this is not something which is
hypothetical we are already making a lot
of dyi components and sending to the
students and they can actually try it
out at their home so they actually learn
to do experiments hands-on
second is we are also generating a lot
of
you know this virtual reality content
where you actually have that haptic
sense of controlling things and doing
the experiment sitting at home
so obviously the hybrid method will
actually involve both but yeah but this
is something where the content is
increasing day by day and dyi kids are
also increasing
i would strongly recommend people not to
do this but if you really need to
generate a
mutant
fly
or to do crispr believe me every single
component of that is available on amazon
so you don't need any lab to generate a
mutant fly as of today you can do that
this is a very heavily unregulated
domain that requires a lot of regulation
but to tell you that if you really want
to do experiments possible so we need to
put that to good use now
yeah that's great to know that diy and
vr is making to the education where this
has a maybe huge huge
future and impact and also maybe
business opportunities for startups and
students who are graduating now and uh
they would be the ones who can maybe do
this more in this in their field so yeah
great
point to great
hybrid mode that all of us have gone
through so it's not only just the
students like it is uh saying it from
from the point of students even with
regards to teachers also you know it
becomes very difficult to convey your
message because it's not we cannot see
the expression of the students
and uh you know so that also makes it
demoralizes ourselves to some extent
because we don't know whether what we
are saying are they able to grasp it or
not and whether you know we are just
talking to walls so that again makes it
difficult and with regards to when we
are talking about bioinformatics or any
computational uh
experiments like
work that we are doing we are also
unable to see what they are doing is
correct or not it might be they have got
some result but is it the right one or
are they going uh by the right way is
what which is very difficult to monitor
also
so you know it's it's both sided and
once the person who is delivering also
becomes monotonous that obviously
whatever interest is there that also
goes on
so
hybrid does uh you know restrict even us
to uh get to some kind of innovative
measures to help them enjoy learning
yeah so you're saying that
so i think many institutions made the
video compulsory so that they can see
the students and but it's not possible
when you're looking at a bigger class
it's just does not make it say we have
connection issues you know
and another challenge that you have
mentioned is also to track progress like
how to properly track progress of the
students who are doing these things
online where you don't see them
actually completing or maybe how they're
completing it and if they're learning
all of that or not and then all of this
is
kind of like uh maybe at one time you
see the expression and as a teacher you
understand that this is the this is what
he the student has got but that is
missing and which is a demotivating
factor but yeah i mean pros and cons
some of the things that we have learned
is that by using technology this
experience can be improved
far uh better and that's where we are
heading so the use of technology and
then use of
mentors and the requirement of mentors
in this field is something i also like
to point out that is also a requirement
and those students who are now getting
educated and trained would be
could be those resources so there is
this need of capacity student capacity
based
that is required for the industry as
well as for the academy
so those with those points
i think
we can maybe move to the last point we
are running out of time
but about the promising areas that
please i think if you all of you can
just tell two of the promising areas
where uh where this
biotechnology and bioinformatics and
computational biology is heading so
precision medicine is one such area that
dr anshu has already recommended and i
would like to ask dr suchi and
dr sagar also to recommend students that
maybe these are the promising areas
where the industry will be requiring
students the academy i would be
requiring students for research
yeah so uh
like promising area obviously one is
precision medicine that we're talking
about personalized medicine is something
which is really a promising area
that is there uh by using uh you know
bioinformatics and the omix technologies
that's because uh by
studying a particular
person's complete dna i think we can
actually find out
the the things that are specific to that
person
and that would actually help us to be uh
you know giving a personalized medicine
in fact using the uh data that can be
generated so simply like
uh we are talking about uh taking the
all the
you know data from blood sample and
urine sample we can actually analyze and
generate moderates where we can see what
is one thing that is increasing in a
particular group of people and not in
the other group so comparing those kind
of
information that is available now if you
see it practically when uh there are
loads of people who are getting their
blood test done every day urine is done
every day but that data is really very
important from the research point of
view which is actually going ways at
present
so that's one area where we can actually
think of exploring and that would
actually help us to generate quite a few
models you know so there are certain
parameters where if it fits the dynamic
okay this model can be used and that
would help the doctors to
prescribe medicines and also help them
to uh you know uh
guide them as to the right lifestyle
that they could lead for helping them in
a good
way so they can lead a good life
accordingly so that can be obviously
with regards to various diseases that we
have
all right i think electronic health
records and analysis of that data you're
saying is very important and they could
play a important role
so
from my point of view there are
a lot of opportunity actually
in the market
people are searching for
data scientists if you see that machine
learning is there artificial
intelligence is there ngs data analysis
is there
so
our r is there those people are able to
handle the python is there
so
those people who have expertise if you
just
put a single cell
on job.ac dot uk
you will find there are the thousands of
positions are there
that people are waiting for skilled
manpower
who have expertise in this particular
area
that
people's biologists are there the issue
is that biologists are there or hardcore
biologists they don't know
and computational biologists
computational people are there they are
good in uh
the computation but they don't know
biology so
bio uh
bioinformaticians or data scientists
that is uh
in one
hospital they just collecting a data
and
they
um their requirement is
of the person who is able to process the
data medical data and present in the
graphical representation and the
searching for the person
uh who
have experience in our package
process the data and represent and they
say that
any amount means package they will offer
so that is the
opportunity which is already present
outside
but
people need to learn the python or
machine learning our artificial
intelligence and english data analysis a
lot of opportunities are there
and
now the university systems are also
implementing this but uh there is also
limitation for msc by technology how
much subject you incorporate of data
science rather than uh
means you need to focus more on
biotechnology best that some additional
subject you can
add but those are interested they can
learn these uh
additional courses from i hope you are
offering the courses in data science and
so on so
uh
student can join and they can
learn the data from a specific component
from
uh
other
institute as well
so
now this is all about the opportunity
which are there
and i i hope that
if the student developed the interest in
the computational biology
it is
very uh
flourishing and now the advanced feeling
but the thing is that
uh you need to update yourself every
time
because the thing which are there in
last year it is tremendously changing
next year so you need to keep you
updated and then you will survive in
this area
thank you thank you thank you dr sarker
for those insights and
important skill sets for students to
take home uh take notes of data science
machine learning and python
so maybe if dr anshu you can conclude
shortly we are just out of time for the
next student poster presentation
so i think what the what shuji
very very critical components
so what the actual students got a lot of
keywords
they may add network medicine to it
because it's like you know combining all
of that together so if you have the
right keywords on google
you will be able to fetch the right
information i think searching is also a
very important skill set don't
underestimate that if you don't have the
right keywords you may not be able to
land on the right resources
so i think all the faculty gave you a
very good set of keywords today
go for that and a request to dr sagar if
you can list sites
where
you know there is a consolidated list of
what the current requirements for
industry and academy are i think
students can take a look at that and
take cues from there to start practicing
all right thank you so much all the
panelists for being a part of the somix
research symposium and we are really
really um happy to have you all and
learn so much from these sessions and i
hope that the same goes for all the
participants who have been part of this
uh discussion and we have also this
being shared live on youtube where we
have a lot of users watching this and
this will be also shared uh for those
who have missed this session so
thank you again for being a part of this
and helping us all learn about these
different aspects of bioinformatics in
education and both in research
we will now have the post representation
session and we'll be happy to have you
around but again thank you so much
thank you
for your invitation for this parallel
discussion and i think you need to
extend a little bit
more time because to discuss on lot of
many points we need at least 20-20
minutes to discuss on single national
education policy is different
it was really nice having this kind of
discussion
and share a lot of points
that could be helpful to all of us and
as well as the students
thank you perfect
thank you thanks now it's time for the
creating this network so thanks for that
i otherwise would not never have met
probably dr sagar and dr
thanks for doing that
it's great to connect and i think we can
connect and
help each other in some of those aspects
and collaborate maybe thank you so much
one of the advantages of hybrid mode
where you know we are sitting at
different places and we can still
connect
yes and that's the advantage all the
students can also have connecting with
the mentors and i think it's a great
platform together we can provide to the
students in india
so thank you again and we have some
students waiting to show their
presentations and
it would be an exciting part of this
research fellowship research symposium
so now i'd like to invite uh
miss shrigory
krishnan
who krishna kumar she is going to help
us help the students go through this
entire experience of showing their
posters that could be evaluated over to
you um shri gauri
all right thank you so much dr mohamed
so far we had an exciting sessions that
talked about the various active areas of
research that are happening in the field
of bioinformatics and data science in
the academic industry in india and we
also discuss some of the what are the
various opportunities that students can
access and where to access these
opportunities and how to access them
keeping these in mind there still
remains one of the challenge that
students uh
face that is they don't get the
opportunity to showcase their project
after completion so that is why the omix
research symposium encourages students
worldwide to present their to present
their research project and network with
peers and experts in the field
so
the topics of the symposium is omics and
bioinformatics ai machine learning and
data science astrobiology and spaceomics
computational biology in biotechnology
and pharmaceutical industry the
submission was open to all registered
participants from high school
undergraduate graduate as well as
citizen science projects and out of the
25 plus abstracts that we have received
we have selected 12 of the finest
projects for further rounds of review by
the judges now let me take a brief
moment to introduce you to the judges
who will be reviewing the student
projects
first we have mr dr ramesh kumar he is
the assistant professor uh at brevard
university we are also joined by dr
harpreet khal she is the postdoctoral
researcher at nci nih we are also joined
by dr aguinder lakshmi narayan he is the
research consultant at fine biotech and
dr abhishek sengupta is the assistant
professor at mit university and finally
and last but not the least dr julia
panel she is the associate director at
turbo bioinformatics research center
australia the presentation will be
judged in four categories that is
introduction methods and results
discussion and conclusion finally if the
students are able to showcase a quality
driven project within the timeline the
best posters will be selected on
uh on the following different categories
that is best technical research project
promising research direction for future
potential and most innovative approach
in an established domain
and the guidelines for the competition
are simple the participants will be
given five minutes to present their
poster once the time is up you'll have
to stop your presentation and move to
the next candidate so kindly make sure
that you complete your presentation
within five minutes with that let me
invite the first uh
participant who will be presenting their
project that is doctor park sergal she
is the professor at ranka college of
science and technology chatham
and she and her team will be presenting
her project on characterization of the
hypothetical protein sequence of nigeria
fabulari using bioinformatics approach
so over to you dr
[Music]
uh yeah ma'am am i audible
yes you're audible
i'm i'll be
mom is my screen visible
yes it is visible
okay thank you so much
okay
uh
good evening to all the judges myself
doctor parekh sagan and i am
representing roonda college of science
and technology polite and my colleague
is pratikya das research associated at
the biotech
we have chosen a topic to work on
characterization of a hypothetical
protein sequence of negative
foliary
using a bioinformatics approach
now this particular amoeba is causing a
disease which is called as pam okay so
pam is primary amoebic meningocephalite
this disease is basically cause when
somebody goes for swimming in the open
uh kind of water environment so this
particular amoeba is inhaled via nose
fills and this can cause a lot of issues
and can be very infectious and can be
fatal for one person's life
so uh particularly when it is taken
inside another three uh lives in the
life cycle of nagira flow very there are
three phases so one is cyst phase
another is tropozoid phase and and
there's a third one so in these three
phases uh the trophozoites are the most
severe one which causes the infection
because they can uh they can
multiply themselves with the binary
fusion method and they are they can
cause that much of infection infection
that a person can die in seven days okay
so by looking into this uh particular
slide we can see if uh cerebrospinal
fluid the diagnosis is cerebrospinal
from cerebrospinal fluid that gray to
yellow color is changed and when
one ml of blood sample is taken and it
is being checked so it is found that the
red blood cells number is very high so
person can be suffering from
this particular family disease there are
various type of treatments known for
this
so this is a life cycle we i've already
told about cyst trophozoite and
flagellate phase
so we can see here the uh division of
the cyst2 trophozoite phase which is the
infectious one
okay so in this particular project i
have tried to
find some details about the hypothetical
protein which is not available in the
database so i have tried to find all the
information about it using various
bioinformatics tools and there is
something new which i have discovered in
the project while uh doing the
calculations with the bioinformatics
rules about negala flori which causes
this disease uh so we can see the list
of the bioinformatics tools i have used
i will tell you what a new thing which i
have discovered when i was doing the
project so this is the approach i have
used this is the hypothetical protein
and this is the id number of enflory
that particular protein which uh with
about which the information is very less
available in the databases its structure
is not there its detail is not there its
protein protein interaction was not
available so by the approach i was able
to figure out about this so this inflow
very this particular id was i have got
this from the uniprot database and i
have tried to perform the blastp by
which i was able to figure out the list
of 10 sequences uh similar to this
particular id and that was easily
available and they were around 82 of the
sequences but i took the first 10 to
understand what would be the maximum
similarity with its co similar uh kind
of species from the same family so the
first 10 sequences i have taken enflow
very five and the next thing which i
what i was was to tell you was that
there is another species called as
ngruberry okay so negala gruberry i have
taken five sequences of that and five of
uh flow very just for the support of
study so after i generated the multiple
sequence alignment of these ten
sequences enflovary and ngrubery i was
able to see the conservation of the
amino acid pattern in the sequences that
supported the data that they belong to
the same family and then i have tried to
discover the
kind of
family they belong to the same family
and there was some patterns uh common
patterns were seen in the pro site
database and
something which was different was in the
string database when i wanted to see
about the protein interaction i was not
able to figure out anything for n flow
very but when i took the next five
sequences of n grew very i was able to
figure out some similarity in uh the co
similar sequences of n group area so
this was something new which is not yet
reported so i figured out this and after
the structural characterization when mod
base i have used there was no structure
which was modeled for n flow very and i
was able to make it with the help of
swiss automated modeler the results i'll
be showing soon and more information
about this particular sequence i have
figured out an amoeba database which
shows that this particular hypothetical
protein is very important uh in some
kind of keg and metasec pathways which
i'll be showing later so this is this is
uh very much important in doing some
metabolic activities
uh so we are going to the results
section from the uniprot this is the
idea i have retrieved for uh negala flow
very and this was all about the project
where this was the main idea to figure
out the details of it these are few
sequences which i have taken for enflow
berry and gruberry together just for the
supportive study
this is the multiple sequence alignment
so i can show you the conservation over
here the sequences are very highly
conserved among amongst these 10
sequences
and
i was able to figure out from
the pfam and the cdd database that they
are all belonging to have the
hsp70 domain so this confirms that it is
also having hsp 70 domain like rest of
the sequences
then
from this particular analysis of cdt
database it confirms that they are
belonging to the same clan three six
four nine five uh they're having the
same accession number and the same super
family ptz uh four times zero nine
then from the interpro databases these
are few of the patterns uh from the
domains i was able to figure out ipr
numbers are given so i was able to
figure out that they are belonging to
the same family and clients
then i was able to figure out some
patterns which were similar so i can
show you a heat shock protein heat shock
hsp 70 patterns are present so they are
having around five sequences when n flow
variables they will run 15 hits i have
got from pro side this is the string
result so this tells that when i have
used inflow very there was no result and
just to support my study i have tried
that if uh enfory is not there and
gruberry can be present for protein
protein interaction which is just
similar and belongs to the same family
so i was able to see that there are
co-occurrences there are some
literature-based reports available uh
these are those id numbers which are
which i've shown you in the blast
results so they are having some or the
other relation between them
then using the sys model i was able to
figure out that uh with this template
number of 4a and i1 it was able to
generate based upon sequence identity
that the structure can be like this for
the hypothetical protein which is not
available in the database and very much
important it is based upon sequence
identity it means that uh it this model
has been generated based upon the place
of the amino acid so this is based upon
the sequence identity
then using dr
could you please copy
yes ma'am yes okay so this is the last
result where i can show you the amoeba
database has shown that these are some
of the important pathways like it is
involved in the purine metabolism and
thymine metabolism
so overall conclusion of my project is
that whatever information was
available for nfl very was very less to
enterprise in india there are only
around 15 cases reported and with the
help of n group area data i was able to
support my studies that some information
can be said that gruberry and flow berry
are similar they belong to the same
family and the results can be
checked that way thank you so much
all right thank you so much
thank you mom
the judges already have any feedback to
give to dr parrik
uh i'll just show my poster as well
uh judges do you have any feedback to
give to dr parrik
about her project
uh yes hello um hello dr parrik
yes it was nice work so i have one
actually suggestions maybe when you're
choosing like 10 sequences
so
instead of choosing 10 sequences it
would be better if you use some criteria
like maybe percentage of similarity so
maybe 90 percent similarity of the
sequences so maybe that would be the
better criteria rather than just using
the top ten sequences
so because when we comparing some
sequence so we should consider its
similarity or dissimilarity score so um
my suggestion it's fine for this one if
you're just doing for the publication
perspective it would be much better like
if you consider that yeah
thank you so much for the suggestion um
i'm just i would like to say something
uh because the idea behind this project
was not to figure out the similarity
initially it was just about to figure
out only the information about the
hypothetical protein so that criteria i
may have missed as per you have said so
but yes for the publication point of
view for the next i will consider this
thank you so much for the suggestion
yes
all right thank you so much dr paddy uh
could you please stop sharing the screen
yes ma'am yes
thank you
all right uh so let me invite the next
participant uh
mr kashish kundu he is the postgraduate
student of bioinformatics and
computational biology from amity
university
and he'll be presenting his project on
in silico analysis of transcriptional
responses to uv and ir radiations so
over to you kashish
thank you so much ma'am
[Music]
uh yes
so good evening everyone myself
and um about my
poster
in skin in skin cancer uh many genes are
involved in known dna damage response
pathways for cell cycling and
proliferation
and also in apoptosis their dna repair
repair or in
other stress responses
however majority of the
these genes are involved in unexpected
pathways with functions in
single
in signal trans transduction rna binding
and editing protein synthesis and
degradation
energy metabolism and cell structure
i was interested in knowing these
responses hence i chose a particular
data set to work on
uh the analysis was uh on the data set
was done on t by infoserver along with a
few other
tools and
platforms
this part of
poster represents the
uh wait a second
yeah so this was the introduction which
i gave about my poster
yes
so this part of the
poster represents a methodology that was
used along with the flowchart
illustrating the uh
by the pi the pipeline that was followed
firstly the dataset was identified on
ncbi using geodataset database a
database was downloaded and filtered and
grouping of the sample was done so of
the samples was done
pc and other statistical analysis were
performed manually as well as using gui
platforms
later on uh
pathway analysis was done using links
tool and uh
panther db links database that is
library of integrated network based
cellular signatures takes up input as
gene ids full change information and an
optional field for p values
protein analysis through evolutionary
relationships abbreviated as panther
it links protein sequence
evolution to the development of protein
activities and biological functions
separated files of genes are accepted as
inputs and as output graphical
representation of gene expression levels
are plotted against the pathways they
are expressed in
from here further biological
interpretation was made
from the top uh broad sets the ir
responsive genes
like atf3 map 2
mef 2c were involved in stress response
genes like pvt 1 mmyc
were involved in cell cycle and
proliferation there are there were many
genes with involvement in
signal transduction and apoptosis
for uv responsive genes similar results
were calm with entries in stress
responses signal transduction
energy metabolism and ebolatic pathways
from the results recorded it can be
interpreted that
abrupt activities of cell cycle and
energy metabolism
may cause ir as well as uv induced skin
lesions apoptotic cycle in
showed an increase in the expressions
which can be inferred as immune activity
to tackle the lesion development or it
can also indicate the breakdown of
essential cellular components that were
aided in prevention
of further proliferation of abnormal
sins
the outcome proposes that
protein translation is
additionally
hindered by a halted transcription of
trna synthetase genes
now here you can see the pca result
which was uh
drawn out and this shows the panther db
result along with the bar charts of
the
genes that was uh
expressed now using panda db
these two tables shows us the threshold
that i took that is the nine gene
from this table and i studied these
pathways
i haven't covered all these pathways
because instead of going into an
extensive research i was more
focused on the highly expressed genes
and
hence i went for these pathways
uh sorry to interrupt you you have less
than 20 seconds now
okay yeah i'm concluding so
the conclusion section gives us a brief
of overview of the interpretations of
the analysis and the bar chart
represents the probes and information of
induced and
repressed genes of ir and uv
and for future perspective about this
project and now i'm looking into
the method comparison of
this data set that was uh that i chose
along with the method that i used and
looking i am looking forward for its
validation now
thank you ma'am
all right thank you so much uh does the
judges have any feedback
for
kashish
[Music]
uh dr raghav dr harpreet
do you have any feedback
kashish
so um
i have uh just a few things so it would
be better if you just also show like how
many samples have you used maybe i
missed that so so that it is it should
be like statistically correct another
thing when you actually uh this is just
for the uh i mean from the analysis
perspective i'm not going into the
deeper science so another thing in your
principle uh pca results and uh your
pathway results so it would be better if
you maybe do it based on the
sample group because when you're drawing
this pc it is difficult to understand
like what is actually which group is
there or which is not i i guess you just
assigned it
yeah ma'am uh actually i before i have
the result for both uh before grouping
the pca
how
actually i was looking if there is any
similarity or any plot interpretation
which can i take
which may
which i may find without grouping the
data once it was grouped into ir uv and
separately for uv and ir
i have inferred that information also
there
so it would be much better when you're
doing even in the first group before
grouping you can take actually
uh i mean you can color your sample
based on either this
radiation type because it's difficult to
interpret anything out of this like
whether these groups are different exist
from each other or not so that's
something that you need to maybe
uh
must do this or reanalyze it
so because it is difficult to interpret
at the moment yeah okay okay okay
really yeah that's all
alright uh kashish could you please stop
sharing the screen yes ma'am thank you
ma'am
all right
so
next i would like to invite uh
mr uh emmanuel uh and team will be
presenting their project on
visualization of the chromosome 1
genomic data from the african american
asian and european populations over to
you
emmanuel uh are you there
all right then so let's move on to the
next participant uh miss annika ghosh
she will be presenting her project on
transcriptomic analysis of hippocampal
subfield ca1 in alzheimer's disease
over to you anemica
hello all
uh
so i am sharing my screen
is it visible everyone
yes it is visible could you please zoom
in all right thank you so much
yeah so i can easily zoom in here uh
okay so hello everyone so today i'm
going to present my project topic
transcriptomic analysis of hippocampal
circle ca1 in alzheimer's disease so
what is alzheimer's disease alzheimer's
disease is a neurodegenerative disorder
or may affecting mainly the elder
population
uh
epithelial it could be observed in the
younger population
but its prevalence is more in the older
generation there are several hypotheses
that exist behind
this alzheimer's disease however
some uh
some of like
not all of them are really
accomplished or really found enough
evidence so here is a comparison between
the healthy brain and and a brain that
is
affected by severe alzheimer's disease
and here is another diagram that shows
uh
hallmarks of alzheimer's disease which
include accumulation of amyloid blood
proteins nutrient climation
mitochondrial dysfunction autophagy
autophagy dysfunction and polyneric
insufficiency and uh
last but not least the neurofibrillary
tangles
so in our here is an overview of uh the
methodology of what we have uh done so
for the second project we have used the
this data set
from june's uh gene expression omnibus
the pre-processing of the dart
data was carried out with the help of
microsoft actual 2019
after processing of the data we have uh
quantum nominated our data and labeled
it
followed by this we have we done
principle component and analysis and we
uh detected x119 as an outlier and
removed it
and
then we ran dc2 and insert enrichment
analysis
after uh
determining statistically significant
genes say we validated our results
uh results
so here is an overview of
like our results section so as we can
see here this is the result of the
principal component analysis
so the pc one it accounts for
223.01 percent pc2 accounts for 18
18.19 percent and pc3 accounts for
14.75 percent variance it's 119 as
mentioned earlier is detected as the
earlier
is detected as uh the outline and we
have removed it and proceeded further so
here is a volcano plotted showing the
upregulated and down regulated genes say
and
the right side shows the positive
approaching and upregulation ferrous and
left side social negative upregulation
here is the gene ontology analysis
for our uh data sector so activated and
suppressed pathways are uh separated by
two separate boxes
and
the gene count is reflected by the size
of this
circles
[Music]
gene ratio is mentioned at the bottom of
the boxes
and here is the mention of the p
adjusted
values
and there is this is the c net plot of
our genes and gene ontologies so uh both
these are the genes that are the full
change is negative so they are basically
down regulated
and there are some gene ontology terms
again they are also down regulated
here is the uh
yeah here is the result of our uh cage
enriched pathways uh analysis so here it
we can see again that activated and
suppressed uh
pathways are separated by two boxes gene
ratio is mentioned here in the bottom
and here is the uh like we can see the p
adjusted values the red uh signifies the
most significant ones
the statistical significant oneself
okay so next so for the sake of the
validation what we have did is uh
we took the gene list of the table uh
supplement supplementary table is 5 of
the main paper that is associated with
our data set and we compared it with our
results
uh the output file that we got after uh
this analysis so we mainly uh
went for the uh statistically
significant uh
values
statistically significant ones so our
results saw sure that there is zero
percent there is no overlap between this
uh two
list of genes so therefore we concluded
that uh
therefore we concluded that uh that it
might be due to the fact our uh uh our
my our project is very much focused on
the hippocampal subtle ca1 uh whereas
the main paper was uh
was taking into consideration
consideration other hippocampus uphill
say so uh that is what i can say about
the conclusion section and here is of my
references
and
last but not least is i would love to
acknowledge my research mentors mr
doctor raghu bender lakshmi narendra and
elia broadsky said for helping
me out to carry out this research
project i would also love to uh thank
all the uh members of the pine biotech
thank you
all right thank you so much uh does the
judges have any feedback for animaker
yeah i can uh i can ask this time maybe
um
thank you very much for the presentation
and um just a few questions about your
presentation so you mentioned that there
was an outlier in your data set
and that you included it so um did you
try to find out and understand why it is
an outlier
um did you go back to the data and
try to understand
why the sample is an outlier maybe
some normalization was done differently
because the main paper as i understand
did not mention any outliers
correct
uh yeah the main paper
actually to be honest i uh
back searched about the sample uh it's
119 but i could not find anything really
significant to tell actually
but that's
i could not find anything
okay yeah just uh
just you know just uh
uh remark that usually
an outlier is something that you should
probably go and really
uh
dig in into and try to understand why it
is an outlier maybe the problem is not
with the sample but with the
analysis so maybe you know analyzing and
looking at the data a little bit
differently would yield
different results
so also uh you mentioned the down
regulated genes and upregulated genes
and um and the pathways and everything
you
you know those graphs that you talked
about
uh what i'm uh kind of was a little
missing is uh your interpretation so is
it are those uh pathways or genes
mentioned in literature
have they been found in
in alzheimer's disease before
you know some some of your in uh
input on you know on the interpretation
of the results
so that was a little bit missing for me
um
and also uh yeah the last graph where
you have the venn diagram and you show
that you have
nothing actually in common uh with the
with the main paper uh maybe i'm
um uh maybe i didn't uh you know i
didn't have time to go into the data set
itself
but
you probably took only part of the data
from this uh
big data set i i'm guessing
right
uh actually we have i have cons we have
considered the statistical significant
genes only that is p value of less than
0.05
so
it was mentioned in the supplementary
table s5 in the main paper that is the
last one and here is actually my 181
gems so i compared that
right so you so you said that none of
the genes actually
were the same
so i was wondering probably they had
more samples and maybe did different
[Music]
differentiation
or was it the same because if you had
nothing in common
um
that's a little uh
you know concerning i guess
that's
that's just uh interesting uh
actually i take it another in another
way uh like i
that paper the original paper uh the
what they did was related to all
hippocampal
circles and also ec or adrenal cortex
but i when i did not find any like
overlapping gene
i uh went back to the data right the gse
file uh and where i what i found out
that the data submitted in the geo or
gene expression omnibus
database that is very specific to
hippocrates a1 that i have mentioned so
i am very positive about my results
actually
because i think my result is specific
for co1
okay no problem just uh
can i
can i interrupt uh actually i was
expecting animaka to tell this and the
comparison that she did was with the
differentially expressed proteome from
proteomics data analysis from different
regions of alzheimer's disease patients
so that's what the paper actually they
said and that's what she took to compare
her differentially exposed genes list
that she got from hippocampus
i was
yeah that's why we did not or she did
not find a lot of uh common genes uh
between the differentially expressed
proteins analysis from proteomics data
which is proteomics okay averaged out
data from several regions of alzheimer's
disease patient from one specific region
that is hippocampus that is
differentially exposed genes that she
found out i see
yeah and i think this is pretty much
known that there is little
actually a lot of times there is little
interaction between the proteomics and
the gene expression uh so yeah this
makes sense
thank you
cheers
uh that's all thank you
thank you for all right with us
thank you thank you ma'am for valuable
people thank you all
all right thank you so much
so now i would like to conclude today's
uh poster presentation competition
unfortunately due to time constraint so
uh during the march 2022 symposium uh we
we brought together a panel of experts
from africa to discuss about the
challenges and opportunities that
bioinformatics education in africa faces
so with those points in mind now i'd
like to invite for the symposium mr
adekunle
to start with uh august 2022
over to you
could you start with the session
[Music]
i please collaborate with the
visualization team we are here to
present also
i was unable to mute my mic the other
time
yes uh due to time constraints we are
having to wrap up so your posters have
already been sent to the judges and will
be reviewed and the results will be
declared more thank you so much
all right thank you
hello good afternoon
can you hear me
yes i'm able to hear you could you
please share your screen
all right um sorry about that i needed
to get permission to share my screen
earlier
okay
guys can you see my screen
hello can you see my screen
uh yes but uh it's yes now just specific
okay great thanks
um good afternoon everyone
um
i'm happy to be with us and once again i
want to welcome all participants to this
only
who makes research
focus
on bioinformatics and data science
research and training
uh beginning with a session by the
mislogic asia i have no doubt that the
entire symposium will be an enriching
and stimulating
scientific discourse over this two days
period
so moving on here within the omislogic
africa section
we will in the next uh an hour and a
half be looking at humans logic africa
programs and the scope of bioinformatics
training within the african continent in
the past 12 months we will equally be
taking two important keynote
presentations by two notable scholars of
repute um firstly is uh professor kim
today
sorry akindeva bhattandi who will be
doing justice to the topic advancing
biomedical research with omix data and
computational biology in africa
i'm talking from insights from our
researches and then that will be
followed by dr mariana dpu who will be
speaking on opportunities for
bioinformatics and computational
approaches in scientific research in
africa
and importantly we will be taking on a
panel session afterwards to discuss on
bioinformatics education training and
research
in africa
before then let me
quickly
give an overview of the introduction on
omislogic africa programs
and which
as well as partnerships and some of the
outcomes we've achieved
in the past um
12 months so moving on
allow me to introduce myself
um my name is adekunle adil i'm a
faculty unicity
university here in nigeria and i'm an
associate with medical laboratory
science council of nigeria i'm also a
member i'm facilitator with time biotech
incorporated
c and troubles as the program director
for mislogic africa and eureka
i am therefore pleased to introduce you
all to miss logic africa programs during
the next um and 10 minutes
equally um permit me to quickly
acknowledge here the omis logic africa
and working hard to advance the omis
logic training across
africa
so the omics logic sets of
bioinformatics and big data analysis
training programs of the fine biotech
incorporated which has been globally
proven by peer reviews and curriculum
experts in partnering stations is being
eventually explored in closing the
needed gaps
with regards to bioinformatics education
and training
globally
of course this is of great importance
for us here in africa in terms of
building
these scientific capacities among
students
researchers young scholars young
professionals
and faculties across the
african continent
so
um the
postulation rather
with omislogic africa that is anchored
by eureka is that by increasingly
advancing the knowledge of
bioinformatics and its use in obtaining
scientific insights from sequence data
there will be a significant growth and
development of the bioinformatics
community here in africa and its
considerable implications for
translational science from understanding
of gene functions um as well as its rule
in biology agricultural medicine i mean
just um a
variety of feeds for addressing
challenges that are peculiar to the
population here within the continent and
so the goal of omisology programs
therefore is to provide this training in
bioinformatics by enabling students
clinicians and faculty of all
backgrounds to
develop novel and independent research
that is guided by mentors and peer
examples and so the only logic programs
boost of everything the participant
needs to get started and grow in the
bioinformatics and big data analysis
space for scientific research and
practice our programs combine online
interactive sections and self-guided
study materials and practical
assignments for an immersive experience
proven to have been very effective in
our well-known and respected mixed logic
bioinformatics and training programs so
um while the growing interest in
bioinformatics and big data analysis
continues to grow here in africa many
are still far from being able to gain
this key set for utilization in their
scientific research um and as well as
practice
but we are glad that we do miss logic
africa training programs of primeval
incorporated these gaps are being
breached for students faculties and
researchers across the african continent
and so i'd like to quickly share
here a few of such programs which over
the course of the past 12 months we have
organized um you know to bring
bioinformatics training with project
guided learning and resources to a
cross-section of participants across
you know a continent ranging from
beginners and students many of whom are
new to bioinformatics to
postgraduates as well as researchers and
faculties wanting to develop skills and
research capacity to explore the world
of umic sciences and using
bioinformatics and big data analysis to
answer research questions so um this
high training of course includes data
science for biologists in tradition to
bioinformatics
as well as
with bioinformatics and computational
biology and also we've gone into
bioinformatics for biomedical drug
discovery these are some of the programs
we've run lately and equally
at least this program is the umix logic
training for students and researchers
which is a basic bioinformatics
introductory workshop
that was recently concluded and this
program actually had over 200
participants who participated and gained
the requisite skill to get introduced
and to get introduced into the
bioinformatics space
equally we recently conducted omis logic
genomics workshop
which we just concluded and it's amazing
the outcome we got from these programs
as we have currently a number of
participants moving on currently into
our research fellowship program so this
trainees essentially prepares these
participants and some of the training
program participants
who have gone from being beginners in
bioinformatics to learning requisite um
skill sets that they can apply into
their own personal research and practice
um include stem multi um um some of the
um you know
of the things that these platforms have
learned and equally acquired a number of
expertise in a cross section of um
domains
learning domains on our learning
platform equally we have ujubisola a
pharmaceutical microbiologist who has
seen her practice on application of keep
informatics concepts in her practice
significantly
enhanced and
in addition to that we have jason lee
flordrey from cameroon who now sees
ourselves
well prepared to take on our research
and um you know journey into the marine
biology study space leveraging of key
skillses from our mislogic
informatics trainings
so surface to say that and we have also
forged no partnerships with institutions
towards integrating our hands-on
mentor-driven globally proven training
methods and resources into university
education across africa both at
undergraduate as well as postgraduate
levels
just to help scale rapidly the growth
our capacity of bioinformatics
researches and
you know um across the continent and so
few of such notable partnerships include
you know partners we listed university
in nigeria
we also have a partnership with um
crescent university as well as ocean
state university and most most uh much
recently we had a working relationship
in with
university of yande that is in cameroon
um similar luminological africa team has
participated at notable regional
scientific workshops uh such as the
nigerian bioinformatics and genomics
network where we had a poster
presentation on the topic experimenting
with
21st century e-learning design for
bridging bioinformatics education groups
in africa a test case with mislogic
activity rubrics
and moving on i'd like to quickly
mention our next um training program
that is around the corner which is
another introductory information
workshop abused to take place between
the 7th and 13th of september
it's an introductory
beginner level workshop and the goal is
to bring a number of participants into
the
omics logic as well as bioinformatics
and big data science skills and
knowledge and space and so this program
will be happening soon
shortly after that we also intend to run
another omics logic meta genomics
workshop and i will encourage
participants to please stay on the
lookout for these programs
so moving on um in conclusion um the
african continent uh has been regarded
as the crowd of modern humans and also
the african genuines
known to you know contain more genetic
variations than those from another
continent um across the globe um thus it
presents a reach for course for
scientific studies bioinformatics has
become definitely an indispensable tool
for management of this hugely generated
data in modern biology medicine and
related feeds however infrastructural
graphs and other challenges with
educational systems within continent
remains a cause for concern hence the
need for innovative approach to
advancing performance sex education or
training across africa and of course our
mixed logic programs of the primeval
technology occupies a strategic role in
scaling the bioinformatics education and
training needs um for today as well as
um you know in the
in the future to call and so we hope to
continue to play a significant role in
this space
so on that note i would like to mention
that a panel session will be coming up
shortly where we discussed in detail
about the bioinformatics education
training and research in africa i want
you all to um please stay tuned and join
this section so thank you for listening
and you can reach us at african kind of
dog um in case you have any um inquiries
or no full-on questions
um at this point
without taking time if you have
questions please i will not hesitate to
attend to that you can please drop them
in the chat post but at this point we
want to move on
and um this is my hope our next speaker
is available online already
hello professor kelly are you there
hello i am are you there
yeah i'm around i'm here
okay please having a challenge presently
um
he's having a challenge connecting
presently so he's writing that he's been
having issues connecting
yeah that was the last message i got
all right all right so uh then uh
perhaps we'll move on to the next
speaker um that will be dr marion
rdb
is dr maria db online
hello doctor mario
hello dr murray
i doubt if dr mariano is available
okay perhaps we have to move on and take
our final discussion and then
uh come back to
these presentations i remember um
professor
i kinda mentioned he was having
challenges connecting a hero and i told
him to connect via
the
incognito mode perhaps he's having
challenges with this team and so um
without wasting time i think we should
move on to our partner discussion
and why we're engaged to see that these
speakers are
on
their sessions afterwards so over to you
yeah thank you so much thank you so much
participants so lovely to have us all
here i can see
dr francis over here hello dr francis
are you there
and then i can see rissy hello rissy are
you there can you say hello
yes please kenny let me allow them to
okay i'm here
okay okay i can also hear you uh wow
that's so lovely
that's so lovely
um thank you so much for joining this
section i want to also confirm eva
if our consultant doctor is also around
the person of dr shauni barry hello dr
shannon barry are you here
okay in the absence of that i believe
that uh we will just start straight away
with the
panelists section then go back okay
doctor
barry is around hello sir are you
welcome can you hear me sir
okay you are actually
we can't actually hear you we can't
actually hear you dr shaun america can
you say something again
we can't see you but we can't hear you
so i'm i'm asking you to on the mute dr
shonenberry
or maybe reconnect we can't hear you
okay hello hello how are you
can you hear me now yes yes yes we can
hear you okay
wow okay that's so lovely that's so
lovely i want to welcome everyone to
this section and we will be having
a lovely discussion this evening because
we will be
bringing
the scopes at africa
and we will be checking around our
continent seeing how
how and
what is actually going on in africa
so the topic for our panel discussion
today is bioinformatics education
in a research in africa
uh we have here on a panel missouri c
wizonga she uses color and she has
actually had a trans african
or an intra-african education
i so lovely to have you
uh here with us miss rissi resonga
thank you
yeah then we also have dr francis dr
francis can you say hello
yes i can share you everyone good tv
yeah so we have dr francis uh
sue king he's a faculty at the
university of view in cameroon
uh he's actually representing west
africa
and is an associate researcher as a
biotechnology center
of
the university of
yangon yeah so lovely to have you here
with us thank you so much
thank you sir
okay
i will also be calling on i will also be
introducing dr samuel adidas shawnee
he's a consultant a practicing physician
and a clinical microbiologist
um especially i mean a specialist doctor
uh
who
who works with a clinical microbiology
department at the national hospital
in abuja
nigeria
hello doctor can you hear me
yes i can hear you clearly
yeah thank you so much for joining us at
this section
yeah pleasure
yeah then we we also have as part of the
panelists our program director uh the
person of uh
adequate delhi
he is our pro is our program director at
ole miss logic africa and prime biotech
incorporated usa
is also a faculty at the medical
laboratory science department
in literature university in nigeria
he's also a ceo and founder of digital
health tech projects pretty diane
unscreened here in nigeria
um
i'm so loved i mean i'm i'm so honored
to actually introduce you mr adekunle de
la hoya you're welcome
thank you very much it's a pleasure
being with you
all right so some people are wondering
who is the person speaking
right now so uh i am i am
i am the
community engagement manager for
omixologic africa engagement as a whole
and i have a practicing
molecular biologist and
and geneticist i am a postgraduate
of bioinformatics in the institute of
of psychology and genetics in novosible
russia so lovely to actually have us
here so um uh going straight to the talk
going straight to the talk um
i would love to start by saying that
despite the poor capacity development
for genomic research in africa and the
effort of to empower african scientists
get involved in genomic research
particularly
those research that involved
african populations
uh we we had consortium coming up the
likes of human hereditary and health in
africa the history africa
consortium then we had other initiated
initiatives that actually came up
such that we could have databases and co
i would love to
to throw out some
some some some questions in a bit
here in africa before the year 2010
by informatics and genomics
training was largely done by small
groups
at very few institutions
and they heavily relied on visiting
expats in
in europe and america and some of our
african expats had
had to go to europe and america to
to to get this experience firsthand
however we have seen
we have actually seen how the effort to
change this
this this as i mean has actually
searched so so far we saw the african
society of human genomics rising up to
the human registry and held
uh consortium in africa we saw them also
coming up in 2011
gerald was
empowering the africa
that is i mean that that actually have
the bioinformatics education the african
researchers that that that are properly
trained and african researchers that
could actually engage proper
bioinformatics
research in in africa so um
fast forward to today we also understand
that individuals that do not have access
to formal graduate trainings others big
big universities like we used to know
um
we we understand that there are actually
some challenges that
that the present day
researchers actually experienced so i
would love to call on
on uh on dr francis dr francis i'd love
to ask from you
ah so far so good i i remember that
recently
you had a training in
bioinformatics in your country
and
you tried as much as possible and in
your institution you tried as much as
possible to
to
work i mean to work towards towards
bioinformatics training can you just
share with us the challenges that you
actually met during this training
and then and what were actually the
constraint what was the success you were
able to have
so thank you thank you mr alabi tutu
thank you all to all the panelists and
it's a very great pleasure to be
amongst you this evening
and to discuss about the challenges of
bioinformatics in africa
and
thank you also for introducing that
great
workshop that we recently organized in
january 2022
at about the news center of the
university of the only one
and talking about the challenges and
even the
of
that training
i'll start by saying that talking about
bioinformatics in africa there is no
more
no more a challenging talk
it's no more a it's frequent aspects
because it's something that people are
getting involved and involved
and the interests has been also
increased as you just include introduced
from your initial speech and
regarding that
special training
it was a little to be striking because
it was a first kind of such training to
be organized in our
institution and we even went too far by
training people on ngs
which is very very very new aspects in
the research domain in cameroon
so definitely
having people of a very good background
to get involved in research training was
a very great challenge
you have people from different
backgrounds people who have never
worked on molecular biology and we want
to get involved into bioinformatics you
have biologists you have
engineers you have you have you have
but definitely the first challenge was
to get them
to bring them together
how to try to have people with the same
background
in order to assess them that at least
we moved together during the training
and
this was achieved
this was achieved because we mainly
focus on those who at least has a good
background in molecular biology even if
they
are going to work on bioinformatics and
they don't yet have bioinformatics
background
at least we are certain that they can
have a very good background in molecular
biology knowing that if they are
acquainted with biological data it will
be easy to talk with them about those
data and how to handle those those data
and we finally um
got something very interesting from
those that we selected because the final
number of participants selected for that
workshop was 20
and i can say that yes yes
the workshop was not to bring them or to
build them as part of bioinformatics but
direction was just to get them
acquainted with the introductory
knowledge of bioinformatics and i think
the goal was set
but
as soon as you run a search training
and as soon as you introduce people to a
new discipline
you should ascertain that they continue
building that skill
to be able to have this they find out
the price care that you plan
before you are training and that's why
during that workshop we bring in pan bio
or omega and omega logics to be sure
that after immediately after the
training those participants will have
other platform other learning platforms
other windows where they will be able to
continue getting much training about
bioinformatics so definitely it was a
very good experience and
we really we really really need
such experience again we need such
training again in africa and empire
cameron in particular to get other
involved to introduce order into the
discipline of bioinformatics
yeah thank you so much mr francis
that was so but that was so detailed
because
uh you you were with the i mean you were
uh
from the from your first and experience
looking i mean experiencing experiencing
bioinformatics training even as a
trainer and in cameroon was actually
a a
a great tax for you so um i i really
really appreciate those those inputs i
would love to call on someone in the
field before i call on risi yeah so that
she can share i i experience our kenya
babuan uh experience with us
how she got involved
involved in bioinformatics and how she
was able to cross over but before i call
on rece i'd love to call on
dr
shauni barry dr shauna barry are you
there
yes i'm here okay so uh the the the
quick question i would love to ask it's
still kind of still related with this
question is
um
what do you think is actually
uh
the obstacle that is actually preventing
the the public health sector for example
in west africa using nigeria as an
example what do you think is actually
entering them from i mean from from
really engaging molecular research and
molecular diagnosis
that would actually
bring into use the expertise of
bioinformatics knowledge
yes like you said i'm a clinician i'm a
medical microbiologist and i i want to
look at you know
discussing with all mixed logic you know
about health research you know uh and
diagnostics and in treatment
so and um i i i just recently got
introduced to omix logic
about three to six months back and i've
been following and like i
i want you to know that in my country
nigeria we're actually into molecular
you know research a lot of centers now
have molecular laboratories but we are
very like you said we are at the team at
the very baby phase
of uh bioinformatics a lot of a lot of
centers have not killed into
bioinformatics
and then you like
my center is service oriented it be that
as it made i also enjoy no research in
diseases and diagnostics we wouldn't
don't mind but a lot of hindrances a lot
of encumbrances are there in my country
right now you know that most of our
training institutions most of our
educational institutions are home they
have been on strike for the past several
months
and it's only those institutions that
are not public that are running and then
because of the challenges which is
global you know the economic meltdown
everything going into research
researches especially molecular uh
training molecular research is a little
is seriously challenging although it is
not on daunting it's not something that
cannot be summated
and that i believe that like the first
speaker from caberus said africa is in
the eating phase africa is learning and
i'm sure that nigeria will also catch up
quickly because i as i've been following
the presentations this morning i've been
hearing people from ocho state you know
show state university i've been hearing
other people who have logged on to the
omixlogic platform and already doing
well are catching up i had the first
speaker talking about what they do they
understand and then the training that
they've been giving people even
spreading far back as cameron spreading
back to neighboring nations in nigeria
so i know i i can i can see a future for
nigeria with comics logics and
bioinformatics so that's that's what i
have to say for now
okay thank you so much thank you so much
uh we can
actually draw it draw a summary that
um
that even if the government is isn't
actually helping to push this to work
uh people are still engaging
the knowledge which is actually a very
very good one so i'm going to call
on risi at this point too to actually
share with all so recent from your face
and experience
uh
i understand that you you you actually
had some some entire intra-african
education
what
is actually the gap between i mean in
molecular studies for informatics
studies um between kenya
and zimbabwe and uh and what has the
experience been so far for you
okay
thank you so much for the opportunity
so
my introduction to the field of
bioinformatics actually started in kenya
my background is in biochemistry and
molecular biology so i had my internship
at the kenya medical research institute
and at that point my boss at the time
had some projects that required a bit of
genomics and bioinformatics knowledge
and
by virtue of that he organized a lot of
knowledge transfer seminars whereby you
would have people coming to teachers
different things
so back then i wasn't confident enough
that i understood by
such because when you say bi-informatics
um you'd have to be in places like ilry
where they offer a bioinformatics-based
internship or you would have to be in
the en bid program because it's one of
the major programs that offers
bioinformatics training in africa
and
with these few centers it means that you
needed to know someone with knowledge um
in terms of bioinformatics or who knows
a sort of training a sort of institute
that is offering that kind of training
for you to be able to be exposed to this
kind of knowledge
um then
transitioning into my masters i'm
currently doing my master's in genomics
and precision medicine at the afghan
institute of biomedical science and
technology in zimbabwe so apes as an
institute they have a bioinformatics and
genomics cohort and they are also part
of one of the nodes for the h3 bionic
program
so transitioning from kenya to a beast
um
despite my program being genomics i you
cannot afford to
like ignore bioinformatics because
i think where we are going in the life
science field
knowledge in bioinformatics is very very
crucial so past part of my uh course
here at apes is in bioinformatics i had
to do a module in bioinformatics so that
was like in class sessions and then
in addition to that we also had to take
up some other online classes in
futureland um
where they do like bioinformatics
training for biologists because uh you
need to
match both
into one and then being a note for h3
bionic um
we i am actually a beneficiary of most
of the trainings at h3o bionic and um it
has been a continuous process because
the more you learn the more you're
curious you want to know more um and
that's how i ended up at the omics logic
research symbolism uh like i've been
attending a lot of bioinformatics
research symbols and because i want to
be familiar with the kind of research
that is currently going on
and
through this uh the gap has been that
there's no systematic training in that
uh you need to start with this part and
move to this part so it just happens
that um
in your journey as a student when
there's need for bioinformatics training
that is when it it comes up
but i don't really think it should be an
excuse because
with getting knowledge from bits of
beats i
came to grew up to a position whereby
currently
by attending uh what you call codathons
whereby you meet and you're grouped into
different kind of groups then you get to
run a project um one such program is by
the african society for bioinformatics
and computational biology
so i joined it last year in october i
was a participant then but then based on
how they were running things i i decided
to pitch a project which i'm currently
leading it's called the gn base explore
project whereby we are trying to explore
the feasibility of using genomic skills
bioinformatics in newborn screening so i
would say that it it is a really an
appeal tax for a student in africa but
you still need to understand like what
is driving you and
be able to connect with the right people
who um know the right resources that you
need to continue building your career
because most of this knowledge is in
informal setting unless you actually
enroll as a bi-informatics student
full-time uh you shouldn't like limit
yourself to say that since i'm not
training in bioinformatics i don't want
to get that kind of knowledge so that is
the gap i would say stay
in brief
yeah thank you so much thank you so much
i
i actually love those submissions that
you actually brought because they're
actually actual for a lot of presents um
and how actual are they
uh
for
for some some persons they actually
they're looking hard at having a
systematic way of
of of learning but it wouldn't it would
may not actually come to them like that
some other persons actually
need to do bioinformatics at a
particular time of research and they
have to catch up with the reality of
what bioinformatics is and you know
the accessibility of trainers
and and
and and so on we are things that you
subtly mentioned over there
and
and that will actually take me to the
next to the next
to the next question
i i hope to call on
mr dickonley after i throw this question
to to a lecturer that is over a year and
the question is today majority of
bioinformatics teaching is at
postgraduate level and student tends to
enroll in these programs from different
backgrounds
and terms of amount training received i
mean in terms of
receipt
uh
and this training both the lecturers and
the students they actually have to face
their own challenge of catching up with
the know-how so the question is um
dr francis the question is to you
what do you think is the biggest
challenge of owning bioinformatics
skills
for
for
trainers
and
for students and those
in the field
and those and those that are actually
working yeah so that's the question
okay thank you mr vitte tutu
for the question
that's a very very tricky question
because
the problem is there
and i think we all know the problem we
all know the problem you know
bioinformatics is practical
practical
and most of the time those getting
involved into bioinformatics have never
practiced
bioinformatics
and i said initially they are from
various backgrounds
they don't know what
is decoding
they don't know what is programming
they
finish with their undergraduate level
they reach the graduate and the postdoc
graduate level and
degenerate data and they want to analyze
the data
so definitely definitely
bringing together those individuals from
various background
into the same discipline which is
bioinformatics
is
or is it very very difficult
as a lecturer imagine that
i start teaching bioinformatics at the
postgraduate level
means that someone who started
his undergraduate in biology
in biochemistry
in mathematics
has never joined
those skills together
to make the discipline of bioinformatics
as he restarted or he will start
at the post graduate level
so for you or for me as a lecturer
is already a great great challenge
and this brings in the question of of
what or how is our national education
policy being established
because a new discipline like a
bioinformatics to get involved
this policy
had to develop global guidelines
to establish new bioinformatics degree
program at
different institutions
for us to asserting that those getting
involved into the bioinformatic
disciplines
for the practical
session or at the practical level which
is generally the postgraduate when they
generated
their own data
they already have a very good background
to get involved into the discipline and
to master easily what they will be tough
i will take an example of one of my
lecturer from kenya um
from erie he told me that he started
decoding at the age of 10.
he started decoding at the age of 10.
and me when i started with in forget it
i started getting involved in
bioinformatics i was already 30
and i want to master
the skill he is using to analyze his the
biological data that i generated during
my phd
imagine the difficulty imagine the
challenge
the guy was just playing with the court
the guy was just playing with the
programs and when you are looking at him
is like he's coming from a new planet a
different planet
which unfortunately
is not really really really really easy
to
go to
accept but definitely it's a real
situation it's a true situation because
of
that
system
which
unfortunately
did not allow us to start or to grow up
by getting familiar with those basic
background
and bioinformatics today is something
that
as a biologist
you can't move without it
if you are dealing with
biological data if you are generating
data
you need bioinformatics to analyze those
data
so
at this step i think
we just need
to bring it our government to bring it
our
policy
to interpret
them for them to understand the needs of
this new field
of study
to allow those
interested to start at the basic
background level to get familiar with
the discipline
in order to become the good spine
information that we need as trainer of
the new generation
because today
i started biochemistry i continue with
molecular biology
and i'm getting familiar with
bioinformatics definitely definitely my
background or my skills
my experience will never be the same
as the one of my instructor who started
at the age of 10.
so this is one of the aspect that i
think we should have we have to bring in
and that has to be considered
by our
our policy
yeah thank you so much for that for that
submission it's actually very very
actual yeah because our realities in
africa isn't the same realities with uh
with with other places
and now that you mentioned about
about
one of your instructors that started
coding at the age of nine
i remembered working in an academic year
i had to go join some
some basic python class
over a year uh even though i was a
teacher in that academy i had to go to
join joined secondary school i mean
uh
from from seven from eight students
learned some of those coding and i
actually didn't experience it a lot
until i was already my postgraduate so
that's actually a bridge that's actually
bridge yeah so i will be between a
similar question
yeah
maybe uh maybe i feel soon
before we move in another challenge is
the method of cheating
you know
most of us get involved into
bioinformatics
during workshops
or maybe during short-term internship
and most of the time those functions of
my internship have been carrying out
abroad
and we do it for a very short period of
time and when we come back
the facility we are getting there
are no more available in our
institutions
and definitely
definitely this also impacts
our training experience
and also our long-term training capacity
so definitely
this is also something that has to be
addressed
if i'm getting trained how long
what sustainable measure is putting in
place to ascertain that
as soon as i'm starting
my training will get continued till
i
acquire
the best experience that i need
so thank you
okay yeah yeah thank you so much for
that yeah because it's actually there is
power in continuity like
like um
like
like like risky actually shared so i
would be drawing almost the same
question to receive but uh i will be put
putting it in a in
in a different way because doctor just
said that there is a systematic way of
teaching about informatics so let me ask
you uh receive have you recently joined
i mean
joined um
a training program and you you are
actually stuck in the process of
training uh what part of bioinformatics
training seems seems hard
hard for you
yeah
uh okay thank you so much for that
creation
so indeed a majority of the trainings
that i have joined are usually at the
basic introductory level but then when i
started working on this particular
project uh
the genomics screening um i i tried to
join different training that now you
know you've been learning these skill
sets but you need to apply them
so at the application phase is when you
actually realize oh
so they used to say we call for variants
but i can't actually call for variance
like how do i go about it so
you usually get stuck when it's now time
to actually apply the skill sets that
you have gotten so the training might be
nice um structured well structured you
are following it but if you don't have
actual data to actually apply the skills
that you have learned then it becomes a
problem
so uh what you're trying to say is that
okay
sometimes we have
we have the right access to these things
but
we still need some
hands-on practicals that
mean that we can do by ourselves so
that's actually the application phase of
the training
so the application phase of
the training many times people get stuck
i'm not just about the coding now but
what what about
they already have access to the database
i mean to the database and to the data
as they actually need
at the same time
um it's it's actually getting stuck i
mean they actually get they actually get
get stuck
uh in the process
wow wow this is actually true and real
and and i i know some questions are
actually boiling in the minds of some
some persons i want you to start to
write your questions down so that uh so
that we can start to to answer it before
we round up this this this session i
would love to call on
on
on doctor
uh
on our consultant doctor to ask
him um
hello dr shawnee barry are you there
yes i'm here
okay uh lovely to still have you here
with us um
uh the question i want to ask from you
is uh to
understand what is actually the
bottleneck really affecting
uh
professionals
in the field
from accessing
uh bioinformatics knowledge from your
own from from your own perspective what
do you think is actually the bottleneck
that is that
that actually affects professionals
maybe genetic counselors maybe um
clinical um
biologist uncle
and and these other professionals that
we have
on the field what do you think is
actually the bottleneck that's actually
stopping them from actually getting
access to
this information
thank you very much
the major challenge is in the curriculum
of training
you know everything is dynamic now
bioinformatics is coming i can tell you
that when we started training
there were no molecular techniques you
know in mexico and then gradually
molecular techniques came in and then we
were drafted into doing molecular you
know researches although this has been
far in other climbs
but she gradually got into our system
and a lot of us in our training got
involved in molecular techniques
molecular analysis of our you know our
samples
molecular techniques in diagnostics and
things like that and then we gradually
get started imbibing it and the
molecular techniques
cropped into our practice a lot of our
practices now we use molecular
techniques in diagnostics and things
like that and so bioinformatics will
gradually get in when he gets integrated
into the training a nurse said to the
next crop of professionals as a comment
as they are trained even the young
government and the educational
institution gradually putting
bioinformatics into our regular
institutions so that these things are
readily available and people get into it
as they as they are trained
so as as the trainer comes up they get
into biophobia i get to know that this
is a useful tool in diagnostic and
research
and it gradually creep into our system
and clip into our practice i am looking
forward to a kind of cooperation among
researchers so that those of us who are
in the field who are clinicians will be
able to you know our diagnostics will be
best i would have people we can rely on
to talk to say okay you can make my
diagnosis better right now we do a lot
of molecular diagnosis we want to go
into bioinformatics too this is a new
area of you know research and
diagnostics we want to collaborate what
the join people to do this so the bottom
next is that for now bioinformatics is
relatively new in our environment a lot
of people have not caught up with it by
the time the research decision started
catching up with it by the time the
training institutions start catching up
with it by the time the postgraduate
medical colleges catch up with
bioinformatics as part of diagnostics a
lot of doctors a lot of professionals a
lot of physicians like me who are
research oriented would go into that and
a lot of the research centers in nigeria
would also when we get into
bioinformatics when these things get
into our training into our curriculum
into our practice will graduate so what
i'm looking forward to as part of this
uh uh workshop it's called mixed comics
logic workshop is an and a further
introduction and further furry into our
institutions so that a lot of us can you
know
get introduced to this and get involved
in it
thank you so much for that and that's
actually very very
very very true
uh
in recent times i
acted about nigeria
this year uh meeting with
with um heads of department and me just
takes older
uh stakeholders in the different
faculties and i was so surprised that
our informatics wasn't
on the syllabus
even for the common biomedical student
so it's actually something that is uh
that is actually
uh very very important that even the
medical schools the medical
student their medical students will
actually start to engage with
mathematics okay so at this point i
would love to call on uh mr economist
hello mr decon are you there
yes i'm here
okay so the quick question i would love
i would love to share with you is
uh you have actually in recent time you
have you have actually engaged training
training
individuals in the field of bio
bioinformatics and the question is
uh
what do you think are actually the
the
the challenge why
to why um
uh the trainers the students and the
lecturers
uh
what what do you think actually the the
entrance to these people opening up to
bioinformatics training in africa
because they need to actually open up to
it before they can actually
get the training so that's the question
sir
all right thank you for that question um
i would say that um like the speakers
that have spoken earlier on our state
there are a number of challenges when it
comes to
africa also catching up with the um the
speed of
brain
use in
umic sciences generally but nonetheless
we have seen from africa that
particularly here in nigeria that more
and more people are getting interested
in learning these skills
all right um how be some of the
challenges we have noticed from our
works um you know in recent past um
ranges from
um
you know issue of an economic power to
be able to assess this um training to
assess these um i mean discourses these
programs um also to some of the
technical challenges that participants
have during these programs all right um
you agree with me most of um
we condone
most of our
studies our programs
researches we do them online and we've
seen situations where participants
begins to complain about even
good internet accessibility okay and is
quite a huge challenge
um equally uh most of these programs um
come at a cost um and um because of the
economic power also a number of persons
get to complain they have the desires to
join these programs but then
they have no choice to draw back at some
point
and that's why we've seen more more
people join our free webinars and maybe
workshops some of the workshops that are
sponsored
under the prime biotech scholarship all
right and then to get the full loan
build up training because
what we do with umix logic is a
pedestrian car um training building up
the skills from the very business okay
so you see them drop away from such and
full on trainings but of course i want
to sincerely
acknowledge here
you know what mixed logic is doing um
here in africa particularly the support
of the pembroke um international office
to ensure that this the cost of these
trainings is
is made available with a lot of partial
scholarships
and the rest for participants from
africa all right
that's quite very very helpful
but nonetheless um these are some of the
challenges we will talk about the
technical aspects talking about internet
um
i've seen people even on some of our
workshop programs complaining that their
internet is not strong enough not
necessarily that they are complaining
their internet is not strong enough or
you find them difficult
having difficulties and systems some of
those pipelines are
platforms i mean and you get to let them
know
that it's about their internet network
you have to change locations
change you know their source of
connectivity and we've seen that get and
resolved and then they move on then
lastly that i'd like to mention is um
you know bioinformatics also comes with
um
you know
i wouldn't i wouldn't say beats me a
good knowledge of coding skills okay and
then we have seen that but because they
are getting introduced yes many of them
like dr suny barry mentioned earlier
um while in school they were never i'm
introduced even to molecular techniques
let alone bioinformatics okay and so why
going through these programs they're
getting to see new concepts and learn
new things and especially when we not
get to the coding aspect a lot of them
get lost and then get discouraged but
that is why also i want to acknowledge
what we are doing with the omis logic
platform the lenders miss logic platform
because participants can get to
i mean get introduced to
these new feats these new um concepts
starting from the bites and molecules
the business and then they build on dust
cases so with tenacity definitely we've
seen people move from that very basis
being a novice with bioinformatics and
moving on to become an expert and even
conducting their own research is now
currently in their research fellowship
so um these are a plethora of challenges
we've been having but thankfully we are
trying to bridge this gap with our set
of programs and it is our hope that um
we can contribute to this until we have
uh most of our institutions partnering
with programs like us and
or you know reviewing the curriculum to
accommodate these changes
so i think until we get to that
stage
keep making
the progress assets
maybe in bits and pieces
yeah thank you so much for for that
um thank you so much for that it has
actually been been very very
enlightening from from this part because
um
bioinformatics
bioinformatics actually has and promises
a lot and uh
this
this
section
has actually
opened our minds and our eyes to
actually see the challenge i would love
to give us all um the ability i mean
just i mean a a closing i mean a
privilege to actually share a closing
remark
on
one thing you think will fix
bioinformatics training in africa so
just just uh just round up i mean give
us a closing sentence about one thing
you think we we fix bioinformatics
training in africa
so i would love to call on
on
on on
on racy
okay thank you so much for the
opportunity so from my part as a student
and having experienced bioinformatics in
africa i would say we need to start
small
maybe reach them when they're young
like go to don't just train um post
graduate at post graduate level can we
try from high school level like keep
telling them there's this thing called
bioinformatics um
keep introducing them to coding and um
also the way i have understood it is
you don't need to be in bioinformatics a
bioinformatician to learn bioinformatics
because even in the life science field
you'll have to apply bioinformatics so
if we encourage more people more
students like you don't need to be
really like it once they understand that
you don't really need to be a buy
information to get the bi-informatic
skills then i think more people will be
open to learning and then if you like it
then you can go on ahead and do it
full-time so that would be my fighting
rematch like
uh let's get them young and let's
encourage
them to get thank you
thank you so much get them young
encourage them to keep learning they
just take it from primary school
separate schools
yeah i love that i love that okay over
to you dr francis
yeah so i think um
one of the most important thing is
that in addition to current
bioinformatics training capacity
building environments
like the h3a bar nets like omix logics
like the erie
we need additional
[Music]
flexible sustainable and high quality
bioinformatic training environment
and i think that's filling this gap will
help us to ensure that the biology
digital data
graph of sample generated in africa
will finally be analyzed only by african
bioinformaticians
wow
that's that's actually very very
powerful no one will actually care for
our africa like we do
so
we actually need to become the expert
that we need to be able to solve the
problem that we have thank you so much
for that that's so short and very very
very powerful okay i would love to call
on dr shauna barry if he's still with us
uh
doctor sean sean barry are you there
hello doctor scholar are you there
okay so i will give the the final word
to to um
mr adekunle adele
uh just give us a closing sentence here
on how to one with this
okay please um
can can you please repeat that
yeah so the question is
yeah can you give us a last advice or a
last take home
to
the solution that you think we need
in our bioinformatics training in africa
just a closing sentence
all right thank you very much i think
personally we need to begin to engage
more and more the policy makers the
educational policy makers you know um
indeed in this continent about
bioinformatics and the need to integrate
this into the curriculum
there is i i want to believe so much
that we can actually scale the
accessibility and the you know the the
the use of bioinformatics in
our educational space with with that of
course most of our engagement personally
as an a group as a team here i've been
much um within the universities
individually and
it has been quite
a welcoming one so but i think at this
point with the various programs out
there history boundaries and the rest of
mixed logic we might need to also begin
to engage policy makers and ministries
of education to let them see we need to
actually
take bioinformatics actively into our
high institutions
that would
yeah thank you so much everyone for
joining us it has actually been a a
teachable moment for a lot of us because
a lot of persons have actually been
thinking how do i cross from this page
to this page how do i actually face this
this this challenge and how do i
overcome this truth is that it is not
new we actually have to to
to cross and jump over our own way uh to
build our own ladder our own way and
like we've heard from the patients on
the field that when bioinformatics in
our medical schools we need to eat
everywhere we need it
for the for about medicals and for the
sciences for every aspect of what we do
we need a curriculum that is changing
and we need you to actually be the
change you need to take it to the
schools and so on thank you so much
everyone for joining us i would love to
call on doctor
for him to continue
because we have the representative of
prof on ground now
thank you so much everyone
thank you
all right thank you very much for for
that thank you um rissi thank you dr
francis i want to thank dr s as well i'm
so at this point i want to
um welcome now dr
hello can you hear me
hello me
yeah yeah yeah we can hear you
okay great so um at this junction i want
to welcome the representative of doctor
i'm professor kindy
i
am aware professor kindly is unavoidably
able to join this meeting however i
think an argument has been made to have
someone stand in for him so um do we
have
um
dr xi here
hello
yeah yes
yeah it was here some minutes ago i
think he's here yes he's still with us i
think i need to grant him
um ability to share his screen
so please kindly um on me to yourself
all right done that
okay lovely to hear you
thank you so much
sorry
yeah yeah yeah lovely to have you here
sir
i'm glad to hear your voice too
okay please you can go ahead to share
your screen
hello
i'm sharing my screen already can you
see my
you have to enable me from your head
yes please go ahead
you can go ahead
yes please
you see my screen
hello
are you seeing my screen
hello
can you see my screen
yes we can yes we can see your screen
[Music]
yeah we can see your screen
and uh but it's it's not in presentation
yes we can see your screen and you're
breaking up
and you're breaking up
your network is breaking up
yes we can see you're saying everybody
now clear me up
can you hear me now
okay yes we can hear you now
all right now i'm so sorry
okay i'm so sorry i'm all on you
lua paul representing professor akindi
which is on another university
assignment that is very urgent he's in
this early year but we are so sorry for
not bringing him in however i'll be
stepping in for him
okay okay
all right thank you yeah according to
him the topic given to him is advancing
bio uh biomedical research with omics
data and computational biology
in africa inside from our researchers
i hope i'm horrible enough can you hear
me yes we can follow yeah we can we can
yeah all right
all right that's good okay
now we cannot proceed to this uh
[Music]
we cannot proceed in this presentation
if we did not understand the
significance of biomedical research
a medical
research the any
chaos
i think we are actually losing use huh
i think we are actually losing you
i think we are actually losing you
either
maybe we can move further with the u.s
panel
they're also waiting with us
yeah i think hello uh
dr shay
hello dr shay your your internet is
quite bad
we can't seem to follow
i
i think i think we may have to
to uh
to move on to the next
i mean today to the next presenter your
internet is actually breaking
and uh your voice is not actually coming
true so we may have to move to the next
presenter i don't know dr steve can if
you can actually hear me
yeah
i think we we can't actually hear you
i'm sorry for that but
we may have to move to the next
presenter
um hello jasmine are you there
yes yes yes
okay okay
um
i i believe the u.s team can just take
over from here because we
actually lost them because of the
internet issue over there
then the other presenter cannot actually
access the link
okay no problem
so we have grant with us
maybe he can
take over the stage now
hi grandma you did okay
good afternoon and hello kind of running
on the uh
on the speed up here so glad to be with
you can everybody hear my voice okay
yeah we can't hear you
very good all right
so thank you all for your patience on
those little uh
things that happen
we are running a little bit ahead
because of that but we want to go ahead
and get started
thank you to that global community we
heard some really exciting updates from
india and africa
and uh we're now going to see
how bio
informatics as a field is evolving here
in the us and the americas
as well as i said in the general
americas
welcome to the americas section of the
omiks research symposium why are we here
well we know you have an interest in how
omiks are being used around the world
and over the next several hours you'll
hear from world-renowned experts in
various omics fields from the broadest
uses of omics to areas of incredible
drill down niches so
stay tuned
my name is grant and i am your host for
this afternoon and i'd love to see where
every once everyone is from
so if you would take a moment to drop a
hello i'd love to see it in your native
tongue because i'm sure we have some
international uh
people on the call
drop a hello in your native tongue and
maybe your
country or locale in english if you
would drop that in the chat box i would
love to see that if we could get some
responses there i know i saw some people
from africa earlier went in that mode
but uh can we get some responses in the
chat box that would be really fun
nice nigeria habari is that your name or
your locale
great india mambo
this is what i was hoping for this is
always amazing isn't it to see places
from all around the world anybody else
want to jump in we've got uh what 60
people are so on the call would be fun
to see who all 50 people on the call
nigeria again malaysia
relocated to the uk i hope that's going
well for you cameroons and bob this is
this is fascinating
thank you all you know at pine and keep
going please don't don't stop because
i'm talking at pine biotech we are
really interested to know the makeup of
our audience so we thought you might be
also i've got a little poll set up and
unfortunately i don't have the official
zoom
poll but we're going to put a little
poll in the chat box
and we would like to see
some more information from you so this
is the
poll and you could just copy and paste
one of those or if you happen to have
two or more things like if you're both
an md and a phd
if you wouldn't mind dropping that in we
would love to see what the makeup of our
audience is and where you are at in your
career
you would be fascinated by that who's
who can chip in and give us some
information on
your current
status
all right pursuing a phd that's
wonderful masters
rissy thank you
phd's a lot of work my brother got a phd
years ago and he always called it piled
higher and deeper i don't know if that's
still the case with getting a phd but
that certainly is
seems like it is pursuing good we've got
a lot of really
high
high achieving people
microbiologists great pursuing a phd
nice well thank you all for that while
we're looking at the poll result results
if you're not yet registered at
learnomicslogic.com
for your free learning portal account
i'd like to encourage you to do that now
i'm going to put a link in the chat box
i don't want to interrupt the poll so
you guys just keep dropping it in but
that is the web address
and you can um
again it's free and it sets you on a
path to learning about this fascinating
body of research and discovery so if you
sign up now at
learn.umixlogic.com and click the
register for free
button that'd be great if you could do
that i'm going to close that poll now so
thank you for those of you that jumped
in on that
a lot of people
really going for higher levels and that
is wonderful and those of you that are
maybe still in high school or something
like that and to get a chance to chip in
it's a great field to be looking at
since you're so willing to help i'm
going to do another one what is your
area of interest and data types so i'm
going to put a lead in here for you so
where are you are your interest are you
still exploring are you into genomics
transcriptonomics where are you at in
your path where do you want to be
uh what is your interest what is your
data type genomics okay thank you rissy
thank you for participating in the poll
another genomics
fascinating
nice drill down there
epigenetics cool nice
nice
these are really great results you know
if if you're wanting to start your
career in this broad field this is
valuable insight to what other people's
are doing what other people are doing
excuse me um anybody else want to chip
in on that we've got a lot of genomics
exploring cerreli if i said your name
right that's great
uh epigenia nice nice all right cool so
what will we hear this afternoon and
feel free to continue with the poll
what will we hear this afternoon
well in the u.s data science has seen
more adoption and more variety so we're
going to hear about some exciting ways
omnicomics data and data science is used
from algorithm development to training
and applications
the need for more user-friendly tools to
facilitate discovery and discussion
around reproducible data analysis
traditional use cases we're going to
look at some increased complexity as
well as the availability of data
and then we're also going to look at new
applications for this data
traditional as in research in clinical
and then today as in wellness beauty and
even supplements now our first
introduction is one of the masterminds
behind this symposium and the pine
biotech
a leading big data organization whose
corporate vision it is to enhance human
health and well-being by enabling
biological research and discovery both
relevant data solutions and support
but before i officially invite elia to
speak
i want him to pop in and see the final
results of our next survey which is
going to be kind of related to what we
just did but a little bit different and
i'm going to pop this in here
what is your application area of
interest where are you going to take
this now some of you put that in above
as you listed your
area but if you can
answer that poll we would be interested
in seeing that also
infectious diseases neuroscience
what else we have out there
oncology fascinating good for you guys
that's really
really fascinating
so elia what do you think about these
results what are you starting to see
thank you grant yes first of all it's
really exciting to see such a diverse
background such diverse interests and
i'm sure that today's session will be
informative because we'll speak about
how all of these different types of data
converge
and as you mentioned
interesting new
applications that maybe some of us have
not thought of
but this is definitely exciting
cool well great thank you for that
response and thank you all for for
playing and since you guys have almost
met him i'll do an official
an official official uh introduction uh
one of the tech masterminds behind the
symposium is elia brodsky elia is the
co-founder one of the co-founders of
pine biotech and serves as ceo
his background is an applied mathematics
and data science and is currently
completing his degree in business and
management from tulane university he's
facilitated and managed collaborations
with researchers at stanford ucsf
louisiana state university tulane in
other academic
and pharma r d teams
mr broski oversees the strategic
development of research projects and
manages the team responsible for
bioinformatics analysis training and
collaborations for biotech ladies and
gentlemen let's kick off our north
american session in our americas session
with elia brodsky elliot did i did i get
all that in there right did i get it
said right
yes i think that was perfect thank you
very much
you're welcome it's all yours
all right i'll share my screen and
welcome everyone this is going to be
another kind of a transition uh into the
rest of the speakers we have an exciting
set of uh topics and speakers that we'll
be hearing from today
and so i am really excited this is the
third time we are doing this group
meeting the symposium
really it's supposed to be more of a
discussion so as you've seen up until
now we've heard from our representatives
in both india and africa
i've really heard some great insights
about how education research are
converging
what are the needs and interests in
these different regions and i'm hoping
that today we're going to
learn more about some of these topics
here in our
americas
section of this
today session and then tomorrow we have
a great lineup of speakers again so
hopefully you will join that for uh join
that discussion as well
so um just kind of like a high level
overview of some of the insights that
i've heard so far
it was really interesting to hear about
the
kind of greater interest and the need
for hybrid education where we see both
online and in person in education and
especially in the domain of
bioinformatics where we see such
growing amounts of data and growing
complexity of data emerge
the need for biotechnology and life
sciences degrees to incorporate
bioinformatics and data science training
into that um teaching so i think that is
really uh relevant to what we are going
to be discussing today
in africa we saw some of the big
challenges that still the continent
experiences with
infrastructure with ability to not only
hear about bioinformatics but use
bioinformatics and actually apply i
think bioinformatics methods to areas of
research that those participants came
and spoke about so we heard about your
interests in environmental sciences
biotechnology infectious diseases
non-communicable diseases right there's
such a wide range of applications for
bioinformatics and so i'm hoping that
today
we'll kind of learn about some new ones
but that
kind of presents a challenge right how
do we actually
learn bioinformatics and align that
learning with those topics of interest
and how do we not only
kind of follow the same technique
that is one
uh type of an approach for everyone
right how do we personalize and match
the training with the interests that all
of you are pursuing so we heard a lot
about that and i i also am learning
about it and it's really interesting uh
to uh be able to find collaborations as
a result of this discussion because
there's so much i think that we can
benefit from by
joining forces and working to address
these challenges together
so
another important announcement that we
heard today is the launch of the india
partnership program and dr mohit
mizunder who is based in india spoke
about
our recent developments in developing
these long-term relationships with
universities and building out a whole
pipeline for students not only to be
exposed to bioinformatics but actually
learning to
answer biological and research questions
with data
and working together with faculty as
well as mentors from different
institutions
to advance publications to advanced
research projects and also to get
experiences
in
industry
and we also heard about the research
projects that different students are
working on right so we heard about
just a few examples
we have a lot more projects that are
available on our portal
so grant already mentioned
our portal is learn.omicslogic.com
and on that portal you can see the
training that we provide but you will
also see some of the projects that some
of the graduates have completed thank
you jessica for sharing that link in the
chat box you can go
and and kind of check out some of those
new and updated projects
of course the benefit of developing a
project isn't only to complete a
bioinformatics project but it's also to
be able to demonstrate how you can think
critically how you can apply your data
science skills to a new and challenging
topic and how you can actually
be presenting the results of your
research or your analysis in a
meaningful way and i think to facilitate
that we've included some of the judges
today
but we've also seen judges previously
that came from a background in industry
and academia and all kinds of
applications of bioinformatics so really
it's an opportunity to develop your
profile
and stand out from the crowd
now we also spoke about
another challenge that i think is varied
across the continent here in the us
and we'll talk about some of those
challenges outside of these major
biotechnology hubs in the us but we also
will hear about bioinformatics in brazil
and we heard about bioinformatics in
africa nigeria
we have people here from south uh
africa from
malaysia right from india from all over
the world and so another
major challenge in all of these domains
is ability to find mentorship
and opportunities to join a research lab
or even an internship or a job finding a
job
so
recognizing this challenge we want to
really connect this ability to showcase
what you have done with the
opportunities out there and so we've
launched
a job listing
site
where over the next few months we will
be interacting with the research labs
with the employers to make sure that we
can build out that pipeline and that all
fits back
into
that long-term partnership program
where universities can join our
community
bring their students to learn about the
basics of bioinformatics for absolutely
free
develop an interest in a specific
application learn from mentors that are
experts in that domain and eventually
showcase their achievements their
projects their
skill sets by
demonstrating their projects and
applying for those opportunities so
if you are here from a university
if you manage as students if you mentor
students we would be excited to speak to
you uh after this symposium is over
so another important aspect of the
projects that we saw in the project uh
competition that we are holding this
time as well as what we've done in the
previous times is we're going to be
looking to
hand out prizes for these three
categories so we have the category of
best technical and research project our
judges are right now evaluating uh the
projects that were submitted over the
past few months
we have the promising research direction
and the most innovative approach so
these are prizes that are going to be
awarded tomorrow
if you have participated in the showcase
uh please join but also all of you that
are supporting these students that are
showcasing their research projects we
invite you to join tomorrow and really
see who won the prize and and also see
some of our past um participants that
have won prizes and and what they did
after they got those prizes right
because they went on to join
different programs where they continue
their study
or have you used it to advance their
research careers as well
now we already spoke
about the significance of
industry participation and so as a part
of this long-term partnership program
we're really working hard to develop
relationships with companies that both
hire and offer resources such as
infrastructure to help advance
bioinformatics and help to prepare
bioinformaticians of the future for the
careers of the future and so we are
excited to now uh work together with a
number of collaborators some of them you
will meet over the next two days uh but
those include the faba academy they
include companies like google and cam4
therapeutics and others and all these
are areas where bioinformatics is in
very high demand um and in a
significantly growing industry and i
think you will be able to see that by
looking at
the diversity of the job listings on our
page
and i also want to mention that if you
are here and you have a job opportunity
or an internship or some kind of an
experience that you would like to share
with our participants please do
submit a job which is
available on that page as well
so what are we going to hear about today
uh today we're going to be talking about
advances in enabling technologies omix
to research symposium is obviously based
on these different types of omics data
so we're going to be hearing about how
the diversity of instruments we have now
illumina oxford nanopore 10x genomics uh
recently we heard about ultimate
genomics right so the diversity of uh
data that is being generated the
decreasing costs that are being
associated with the sample preparation
and sequencing all of this is driving
the need for complex data analysis
cleaning and integration
and importantly in different domains we
will hear about how it varies by
application type so we'll hear for
example about applications in oncology
applications in forensic sciences and
tomorrow we will heard about here about
other applications including for example
in beauty so really a lot of interesting
applications that we need to learn about
and the
choice of data type the choice of the
sequencing platform as well as how to
manage and analyze such data is what
we're going to be hearing about
now i'm a big believer in user-friendly
tools right we all understand the
significance of knowing mathematics and
knowing statistics and machine learning
and also knowing coding languages
ultimately you cannot be an expert in
everything i think that this expectation
from
bioinformaticians to be
both
very sophisticated engineers data
engineers and expert biologists is just
sometimes unrealistic and so to make
bioinformatics more accessible uh more
kind of user friendly we need to make
sure that a lot of these tools can be
used by people with less experience and
so i'm really excited to hear about some
of the updates
that we're going to hear from dr julia
pannov who's going to be speaking about
the analysis of bulk and single cell
transcriptomics data
and uh from elizabeth taranyanka who is
going to be speaking about the analysis
of managed genomic data on the t by info
platform so these are going to be
exciting
sessions where we will hear some of
these important updates and not only
hear about them but hopefully right away
be able to use some of those as well
now i am also excited to announce that
we are going to be hosting a
bioinformatics hackathon so we've
tentatively sent the set the date for
november 17 to 22.
uh where we will get we are going to be
uh hosting a hackathon for omix wellness
and health
and the major
target will be
for students from around the world as
our participants here today from africa
from india from the us from south
america to
find each other build a team
and come together to build an
application and so the goal and i hope
that you take this perspective as you
hear some of the speakers that are going
to be speaking just a few more minutes
this is an opportunity to identify
a really clear application of omix data
in wellness and health and so i hope
that after today's session we will share
announcements about application process
the different resources that we're going
to be making available that will include
computing resources
data sets that you can start working
with
as well as some mentorship and guidance
that we will be making available for
those of you that are interested in this
opportunity
and the winning team is also going to be
getting prizes and recognition for the
application that they built
so let me briefly now describe some of
the speakers that will cover um some
research topics that i think are very
relevant to what we are doing here today
uh we're going to speak from dr nikolai
oskolkov who is a senior
bioinformatician at the department of
biology at lund university sweden and
science for life laboratory he is going
to be speaking about machine learning
for multi-omics data integration
now this is a very interesting and hot
topic in bioinformatics so i hope that
we will kind of see the significance of
uh these challenges that new data types
bring but also to the need in being able
to make sense of how does this data
actually describe biological phenomena
we also talk about another person who is
applying multi-omics integration or
multi-omics techniques to the area of
forensic sciences and that's where dr
sarah zappico who is an assistant
professor in the department of chemistry
and environmental sciences is going to
speak to us about her current research
but also how she got into this whole
field of bioinformatics because her
background is more on the biology
biochemistry side
and i think that this program the omics
logic program in part was instrumental
in her being able to incorporate
bioinformatics into her work
we will also uh um sorry there's a
mistake on the slide but uh we will also
uh hear from dr khasturi kanan
not julia panov as it's written on the
slide the dr kasturi kanan who is
an assistant director at the md anderson
cancer center so really excited to hear
from him about his experience in
applying systems biology to oncology and
i think i will learn a lot about his
area of a specialization as well
now we're also going to hear from a
clinician uh dr luis sakamoto
who is a pediatric oncologist in brazil
and he won't be speaking about precision
medicine in pediatric oncology and what
is the state of the art and perspectives
and i think it's important to kind of
see how these different applications are
maybe different by location as
well
now before we continue i want to remind
you that we offer code or no code
bioinformatics paths for learning and
mastering bioinformatics and
bioinformatics and so we hope that
anyone here today can participate in at
least some of what we make available by
visiting the
omixlogic portal
we welcome everyone to subscribe and
register there for free create a profile
and as this becomes more relevant in
your area of research to start
benefiting from some of the resources
project examples and mentorship
opportunities that we provide so we hope
that really these kinds of programs can
enable research across all of the
regions that we have represented today
we offer big data analysis tools where
you can make sense of complex
relationships between phenotypes and
genotypes we offer mentorship with
experts and
peer examples that you can learn from
and we're also offering training that is
both a synchronous training that you can
leverage as a
as a a faculty member or even a teacher
and uh as a
guided program that you can incorporate
or even offer as a trainer yourself so
one of the important things that we are
moving into is opening up the omnics
logic platform to other participants
so before we move on i just briefly want
to take a pause
and
kind of show you how you also
can
participate in this today
so
let's go to
learn
comicslogic.com
uh and you can follow along
so really i'll show some of the benefits
of what you are able to find on our
portal
i'm going to log out
and the way to sign up is simply to go
to this link
and you can either
sign in with an account that you already
have or create an account like this and
so i am going to
briefly log in you're welcome to log in
as well
once you log in the benefit is that you
actually get
access to all of these resources
including the t-mine for platform where
you can try out different kinds of demo
pipelines and really explore this whole
path from beginning to the end so we're
just going to take a couple of minutes
to take a look at this
we offer here courses programs and
projects and i briefly want to show what
do all of these different things mean so
let's say you're interested in mastering
python or r or you want to learn about
single cell rna sequencing or you have
an interest in a specific project like
maybe kobit 19.
so this is going to be an easy way where
you can find
any kind of a resource with curated data
sets and case studies that are based on
publications you can also look for
things like
machine learning
in r and maybe you want to learn how to
visualize and analyze data using complex
machine learning methods so really
there's a lot of different opportunities
here and a simple way to get started is
just to click right here on getting
started and see a collection of courses
that are only around a specific topic
now once you are here
you also have a personal profile on this
profile you can
monitor and share your progress and
achieve levels of expertise that later
on you might be able to showcase if
you're applying for a specific position
so here you will track the coursework
that you are
completing
you can also
take mentor-guided programs that are
actually led by an expert in that field
and importantly you can develop an
independent project
so developing an independent project is
something that is i think critical to
your master mastery of bioinformatics
not only are you going to be able to
show that you understood the challenge
the problem found a data set prepared a
whole plan for analysis but you'll be
able to showcase what you have achieved
at the end so if you click right here on
the projects tab on top
you'll be able to see some of the
exciting projects that others have
worked on over the past few months
you can see projects in all kinds of
domains from oncology to infectious
diseases to metabolic diseases
neuroscience and others and so
as you can see we also have some
features here that you can comment on
other projects or like them and
highlight them and that really makes it
a much more
engaging platform for everyone to
participate in
now you might be asking well but how
many people are actually using uh this
platform at the moment and so you can
always check the activity
on the portal by simply going to the
achievements tab
and you will see that you know it's 11
47 right now just at 11 46 somebody
already learned about bioinformatics how
to get started with bytes and molecules
so you can see that somebody just signed
it up very recently at 11 16 right so
here you can really see a real
time flow of participation and you can
also comment and like this as well as
long as you are signed in
so
what the omixlogic portal offers you is
a
comprehensive community and set of
resources that you can leverage to learn
and apply bioinformatics
now i also mentioned that we have
this high priority for making
bioinformatics accessible and
user-friendly for anyone that is going
to be a part of these training courses
and that's why we have the t-bound for
platform specifically designed to help
you master analysis of next generation
sequencing mass spec structural biology
and all kinds of phenotypic data types
so on this platform which by the way you
get a free account with if you
complete the registration on the onyx
logic portal
here you will get access to complex
pipelines that you can
try to analyze data
you'll be able to interactively create
pipelines that produce results right
away and learn as you go through this
process to really not only be able to
perform the analysis but understand what
goes on at each step of the way in
addition to that you will be able to
compare and contrast how selection of
different algorithms
defines the outcomes of your analysis
and what are the types of results that
you will end up getting in the end so
you will see here right away we have
some output data sets that we can
explore
in addition to that you will be able to
store your pipelines for later use
and you'll be able to see how this data
could be explored interactively
something that we will talk about in
today's session in much greater detail
but actually play around with your data
and really understand how can this data
be informed uh informative uh for your
analysis and for the types of things
that you would like to understand so
really not only are you getting the
direct access to high quality resources
that you can learn from and utilize to
build upon to make your own research
project but also have a set of
easy-to-use tools that really make this
whole data analysis process much simpler
and user-friendly in the end
so with that
i do want to briefly mention some of our
initiatives in the u.s
i'm excited about just this year we have
started a series of pilot projects with
an organization called the national
association of idea principal
investigators
this organization brings together
members from 23 states and puerto rico
and includes universities like
university of delaware and university of
hawaii and the university of puerto rico
and many others where students are kind
of outside of these major biotechnology
hubs on the west coast on the east coast
we have many universities that
specialize in biotechnology and have
been able to put together impressive
ecosystems that bring clinical research
biomedical research biotechnology
companies funding etc and so
these 23 states and puerto rico
represent areas that are underfunded and
do not have access to such high quality
resources so we've been able to partner
with this network and offer virtual
summer programs such as machine learning
for biomedical data
analysis of infectious disease data
oncology as well as our research
fellowship program and we're excited to
see participation from both
research technicians
students and faculty across many of
these areas that were able to
participate and complete successfully
some of these programs
now the next step as we complete some of
this basic training is to start opening
up this
platform to other universities and
students around this
network and so what we'll be focusing on
tomorrow
is hearing from some of the members of
this community uh from different
locations uh how they see the challenges
associated with training in
bioinformatics and data science for
those who come from a life science and
medical background
and
how can we actually build a more
consistent high quality
and effective resource to advance
biomedical research across these
these regions
now briefly i want to also mention that
we will be
starting our next cycle of registrations
for the research fellowship program that
is designed to help researchers and
young
researchers and students develop their
bioinformatics skills as they
kind of immerse themselves into research
using bioinformatics and so the goal
there is not so much on skill
it is more on soft skills and critical
thinking
how can you pick out your own data set
how can you technically define your
research question and really apply your
skills to answer that question with real
data we have heard some great examples
today
but it is a very structured and uh clear
uh process that we have designed over
the last few years
to make sure that anyone without any bio
bioinformatics background can actually
perform such analysis and be successful
at it and so we'll hear a little bit
more about the need for such uh research
experiences tomorrow but um i want to
make sure that you're all aware of this
program and you are able to participate
if this is something that you would like
to do in the next few months
all right finally
my last uh exciting announcement for
today is that
pine biotech with our omics logic
bioinformatics education portal has been
nominated as the finalist for the edtech
cup and this is uh hosted by start ed
this is the largest edtech accelerator
in the us and
they brought together some experts in
education technology and edtech as well
as venture capital from uh leading firms
that invest in in such companies and we
hope that we can connect with them to
really allow
many more
students to not only participate but
also really advance their careers and
succeed in this field so
over the next few weeks we'll be sending
out information and announcements and we
really hope that we can get your support
in uh succeeding in this competition um
and uh getting enough support to really
advance to the next level
so
again thank you for joining today i'm
excited to hear our speakers and i will
pass this on to grant
uh to um talk about what's coming up
next
thank you eliot i was just about to hit
you with my timer and i didn't need it
so thank you for that
we appreciate all that information uh
thank you for the symposium and the
great lead into our time together today
it was also just uh really fun to see
more about the platform itself so that
was really great
all right so how omics works in our
lives across many niches and specialties
more than we can list machine learning
is a current hot topic and one we can
always hear about in movies
right we all know about the machine
learning thing well one important trend
we've seen over the past few years is
multi-omics the basic idea is simple
we see different platforms and patterns
in genomics transcriptomics or
epigenomics
are these different patterns describing
one complex biological fun famine
phenomenon and if so what does the
combination of these signatures in
various omics data mean together
how we integrate the various features do
we just use a database to connect
mutations in a gene with expression
levels in the same gene or is it more
complex than that
so our next speaker nikolae oskalov has
a phd in soft matter theoretical physics
and statistical physics
in 2016 he joined mbis which is the
national bioinformatics infrastructure
in sweden as part of a bioinformatics
long term support team
nicolet has extensive experience working
with genomics with more acronyms in
exhaustive subject matter areas of
interest and i have time to list right
now
and he's also got some programming
experience just to throw it in in case
you need some software languages written
he'll be talking mostly about the
integrated integration of biomedical
data but also has research interests
including single cell genomics and
evolutionary research nikolay i can't
wait to hear what you're going to be
speaking on today the floor is yours
hi hi everyone thank you very much grant
for this wonderful introduction
um i'm going to share my screen and i
hope you guys can see it
otherwise please let me know
yes so hello everyone um
i am really really excited to to be at
the symposium um and it's a very very
nice
uh to meet all of you guys virtually
my name is nicholas kolkov i'm a
bioinformatician from lund university in
sweden
and i'm also
employed by an organization which is
called
scilife labs which stands for science
for life laboratory and i belong to the
uh
bioinformatics platform of science lab
which is called envis another acronym um
the national bioinformatics
infrastructure sweden
and today
i'm going to uh share our experience
uh working with uh
multi-omics
data integration
uh from a machine learning point of view
so i i emphasize specifically that
uh we are going to look at data
integration uh from machine learning
perspective uh because it's it's uh it's
uh this is how we do it it's not the
only way to do it there are different
ways
um but i i i'm going to share our
experience uh that
established in our team
uh in the national bioinformatics
infrastructure screen i hope it will be
interesting
and informative for you
yes so uh this uh project this uh
idea um we started talking about it
a few years ago um
maybe around 2015 2016
because many labs in sweden many
academic institutions in sweden realized
that they had plenty of
heterogeneous biological data
and there was a
and there was an idea whether we can
combine somehow those different
biological data types to put them
together to maybe discover somehow new
biology
so it was a wake fuzzy idea
at that time
not so many people knew how exactly do
it
what are we going to do but since then i
think we
grew a lot
in our understanding
and we even uh now
uh teaching a course
uh on uh biological data integration i
believe a
link to the course material will be
shared with all the participants
um
and
so what i'm going to present here it's
it's an introduction
uh on
how we uh what what exactly we
understand by by data integration uh and
how we evaluate it so i will introduce a
few concepts
without going too much into the
methodological details
so first of all
some terminology
i'm going to talk about particular type
of data integration
it's called vertical integration
indeed there are
there is a little bit of confusion here
so some people uh introduce the
terminology horizontal integration um
and there is a concept of vertical
integration
and those two concepts were nicely
explained uh in a paper of ricardo
galago uh and colleagues from oliver
stegler
lab uh in
in the university of cambridge in the uk
last year um
so
uh basically they
they
explained in this paper that there is a
horizontal
integration when you work within one
ohmic within one data type and you
simply combine
statistical observations from uh
different uh different samples different
cells different individuals
uh different labs um
but you you work within the same
the same ohmic for example gene
expression so you have 20 000 protein
coding genes
uh
their names are the same you are just
collecting
samples from the u.s from sweden maybe
from asia
and uh so that's that's one type of
integration uh it's called the uh
horizontal type of integration
um i will not be talking about this type
of integration because it's a uh sort of
uh it's a known uh
problem
uh in bioinformatics uh
which is called the batch effect
correction so if you uh worked with
for example gene expression data
methylation data
or metabolomics maybe you you definitely
um know about this problem that uh it
you have to harmonize somehow uh your
your data to
uh to to basically to combine to combine
um uh data sets from coming from
different labs
so i i'm going to focus on on the
vertical uh
integration uh because here we have a
conceptual difficulty i would argue that
horizontal integration it's a sort of it
is a challenge uh but people worked a
lot
uh in this area and we made a lot of
progress so we have a pretty good
understanding
of how to do it
uh while with vertical data integration
uh here we are working um we are
collecting
multiple layers of biological
information uh for the same biological
cells
uh samples individuals
uh so maybe we are collecting uh uh
epigenetic information genomics uh and
transcriptomics uh
taken from the same biological cells
uh so how to combine
these different data types so there is a
conceptual challenge here what exactly
we mean here what exactly how exactly we
are going to do it
and
inside that before we start talking
about
integration uh more specifically
uh we have to realize one important
challenge
of working with any basically to my
experience any biological
data
uh it's important to
to realize that biological data is high
dimensional very often
and
what does it mean high dimensional
um
i'm doing analysis so i'm i'm an analyst
so for me uh biological data it's a
multi-dimensional array
or
a matrix simply put
and the matrix has uh two dimensions the
dimension of a statistical observation
and
uh so this dimension uh can be uh so
it's basically just your your samples
cells
uh maybe nucleotides
[Music]
so it's uh
pictures if you're working with
microscopy imaging
and the second dimension is a dimension
is a p dimension
uh so here uh you
you you're measuring certain variables
in your experiment it can be maybe genes
it can be proteins maybe cpg sites if
you are working with methylation
um and you are measuring uh
maybe mutilation of a cpg site for one
cell second cell third cell etc
uh so those are your statistical
observations but you uh but the
dimension of features uh those are your
cpg sites
um
and you can
think about this uh metrics
as um of
n
uh data points living in p dimensional
space
so this p dimension the dimensional
features
it actually uh builds uh
builds the the
the dimensionality of
where your statistical observations live
uh so you have p dimensions and there
are n data points living in this uh
p-dimensional space
and
the thing is that in order to do a
robust statistical analysis
you have to
sample this p-dimensional space really
well
otherwise you do not satisfy assumptions
of of your of your statistical analysis
so you actually would like to have uh
the number of data points n to be much
greater than p
but uh in reality we have the opposite
limit
uh in reality our biological data are
almost always uh have this
dimensionality p much greater than n so
if talking about maybe rna-seq
you have twenty thousand protein coding
genes
and how many statistical observations
you have how many samples if if it's not
single cell genomics i would argue that
maybe you have hundred samples one
thousand samples maybe
but not
not 20 000 really so you actually are
working on this
uh p much greater than n
uh limit
uh the set said thing is that
um when you combine different data types
when you combine biological uh uh omics
uh you actually uh
as i said you you're doing this vertical
integration so you keep n the same
but you're increasing p
so maybe p1 corresponds to
uh genes so it's a gene expression so
the first matrix can be gene expression
and the second matrix is mutilation
measured for the same biological uh
cells
uh so it same biological cells means
that n is the same
but p
uh is actually in increasing now when
you put two data types together uh
because you you have 20 000 genes and
then you you
you add a few millions of cpg sites
so you actually uh you're even
you your your
merged
data becomes even more high dimensional
and why is it bad well it's a it's a
problem because of the thing which is
called the curse of dimensionality
now what is the curse of dimensionality
um
so we are talking about robustness of
statistical analysis for data
integration
and
so by statistical analysis you can mean
different things
people
sometimes think about traditional
frequency statistics with p values
hypothesis tests and power
calculations
but but there are also
other approaches to the statistical
analysis such as basin statistics
or machine learning and deep learning
and the choice of statistical method
it actually uh
it it's actually
defined by by the dimensionality of your
data
so it's very much about uh whether p is
greater than n or n is greater than p
and
so if you're working with this high
dimensional limit as i said
p much greater than n that's a typical
limit for
biological and biomedical data
you
sort of uh sometimes people
do
traditional frequency statistics
i would rather recommend to to to do it
uh in a basin way uh because of sort of
uh
different assumptions um
but what can happen
uh if you
uh if you have this high dimensional
biological data and you continue with
naive
uh sort of frequentist
statistics analysis
uh so here i just give you one example
of manifestation of the curse of
dimensionality
uh there are there are
multiple examples but uh that's probably
most uh obvious uh so this is a
typical problem in uh
in
typical frequency statistics analysis
which is called linear regression
um when you have a linear dependence
between your data
x matrix and your phenotype of interest
more for example if you think about
differential gene expression if you're
thinking about
genome-wide association studies uh this
is essentially what you're solving uh
you're solving this problem a linear
regression problem
uh and this this uh regression problem
can be uh solved in a closed form
in this way
and
basically what you see here in the
middle this is so-called inverse
variance covariance matrix and it can be
shown
that in this limit in the high
dimensional limit so remember your
biological data are high dimensional and
if you do data integration you even you
increase the dimensionality of your data
even more
so it can be shown that in this high
dimensional limit
uh basically you can't inverse uh you
can't compute this uh inverse variance
covariance matrix you you get into
singularities
um and um
so that's a manifestation of the curse
of dimensionality so basically you have
to always uh remember uh
about this this pitfall when you do data
integration you have to watch
for four dimensionalities of your of
your data sets
so that was a warning uh uh fortunately
we have a we have an area in life
sciences
where the curse of dimensionality is
sort of less of a problem
uh and this is single cell genomics
and a few years ago
it became um sort of um
obvious that uh
uh techno single cell genomics
technologies such as 10x genomics uh can
uh leverage uh
hundreds of thousands of cells
and even millions of cells so at that
time a few years ago we were talking
about one million cells
uh then very quickly people started
working it was two million cells five
million cells so we are talking about
five million statistical observation
so here we are into the opposite
actually limit uh where you have n much
greater than p
so in in
for single cell genomics this curse of
dimensionality less of a problem but if
you're doing data integration uh using
bulk uh sequencing next generation
sequencing data you definitely would
like to uh
keep in mind the dimensions of your of
your data matrices
and avoid this pitfall avoid the curse
of dimensionality pitfall
yes and in single cell
genomics there are more and more
technologies popping up basically every
day that can deliver so-called
multi-modal
data
meaning that you you can measure uh
multiple uh biological uh types of
information from the same uh from the
same cells
so here at least a few of them such as
scnmt sitesig the the recent one was the
10x genomics multi-ohm really high
throughput technology delivering
ataxic uh open chromatin region
information and gene expression
information from the same biological
cells
so it's really exciting uh the
development and that's why there is a
lot of methodological development in
this area
regarding data integration
uh so now i will formally introduce of
what exactly we mean
uh by omix integration and how we
evaluate
whether it worked out whether the
integration worked out
uh so what what exactly i mean by by
omix integration so uh it can be
illustrated with this simple cartoon
um
what you see on this plot that's a
number of uh statistical observations a
number of data points
um
maybe cells or samples or individuals
one point is maybe one individual and
these individuals or samples they belong
to three different classes
and imagine that you have
you measured two types of biological
information uh from the same
cells or samples
maybe
you have two omics so your omic one uh
maybe rna-seq
gene expression information and your
omega-2 may be mutilation let's take
mutilation
and
so basically what i'm plotting here is
that
um
so imagine that you take uh your gene
expression metrics and you perform a
principal component analysis you do some
dimensionality reduction of your data
and you take just first leading
principal component
and you plot it as x-axis here and then
you take mutilation data you perform
principal component analysis on your
mutilation data you take pc1 your your
top leading principal component from the
mutilation data and you plot it as
y-axis
uh so
both types of
biological information they are
available so mutilation and gene
expression they are available for the
same cells for the same samples
so in case um
in case there is some sort of
uh so
now imagine that you you project
uh your data points
uh onto the x-axis
and try to uh uh try to separate those
three classes the the black uh red and
green points
uh so they are very well mixed there is
no way to uh separate them
using just one ohmic the same as valid
if you project your data points on the
on the y axis
they are very well mixed
and they can't be separated
on the other hand if you now put those
two omics against each other if you plot
your your data points the way i uploaded
them here
uh you can see that you can almost
linearly separate those three classes
the data points belonging to three
classes
and this is a beauty of data integration
you start discovering
uh some new uh new clustering
new new patterns in the data
uh that were not visible these patterns
were not visible for individual warmings
but they become visible uh once you once
you combine your data i hope that's a
clear what i mean here
so the idea is to see patterns hidden in
individual ownings
and uh so that's all uh can be uh done
uh providing
you have some sort of
covariation between your or omics so
there should be some link some some sort
of connection
uh between your gene expression in this
case and mutilation there should be some
correlation and there is a nice tool uh
it's called move which we are sort of
teaching our participants of our course
that can visualize how well your
different data types are connected uh
correlated so here there are uh sort of
this heat map on the bottom it
demonstrates um it highlights a sort of
linkage uh between three different data
types single cell bisulfites methylation
data single cell ataxic
open chromatin region uh data and single
cell rna
for the same
biological cells and so these colors
here mean that uh you basically so the
idea behind this morphe it's a factor
analysis so that you split your data
into so-called orthogonal latent factors
and it turns out that within the first
latent factor you observe a connection
uh between single cell ataxic and single
cell rna6 so those colors here uh they
they mean that there is some some
covariance some correlation between
ataxic and rna-seq
and uh by sulfate sig and rna6 they're
connected they're linked in the second
in the second factor
so that's a way to have a quick overview
of whether
we can proceed with data integration
whether it makes sense whether we have
something in common uh between different
biological data types
so that was about uh what i mean exactly
by by data integration it's sort of a um
an ability to see something new some new
biology some patterns that were not
visible in individual omics
and now now how i evaluate whether
so if suppose i i performed some
integrative analysis so how do i know
that it was successful
and the way we do it here we are looking
uh we are using the concept of
prediction
uh so we
are looking at a boost a boost in
predictive
capacity so uh let me explain
this a little bit better so imagine that
you have uh three uh different omics
mutilation gene expression and maybe
some phenotypic morphology data uh for
the same biological cells
and these three different data types
they they have very different
statistical distributions so it would be
very naive just you know to concatenate
those three data matrices without taking
into account the difference in in the
underlying statistical distributions of
the data
um
that's why we need integration proper
integration
uh and here in the parenthesis here in
the parenthesis i uh sort of visualize
some accuracy
of uh predicting uh something about the
cells or samples that's just a cartoon
so the numbers here are made up just for
illustration
uh
if maybe we want to to know whether
these samples uh the
cells they came from from their good
cells or bad cells
um and we compute an accuracy of
predicting whether it's a good cell of
bad cell
for each individual omic and we achieve
this kind of accuracy uh displayed in
the parenthesis for each individual
ohmic
uh now
what we want to see when we we've done
data integration is that
the accuracy of uh classification
uh
whether it's a good cell or bad cell
whether it's a sick individual or
healthy individual we want to see that
their uh that data integration accuracy
increased the there was a boost
uh in in the accuracy of uh
prediction and this is actually why i'm
saying that i'm explaining this uh uh
data integration concepts from machine
learning point of view because
prediction it's a sort of very very uh
very very
important concept uh in machine learning
now how how exactly put the three
different data types together uh they
here we have to dive into the
methodology there are different ways so
we explain in all this
uh different uh types of data
integration uh in our course
um uh briefly speaking uh there are
three directions
uh first is a you have to you you can
convert your data to some common space
where the data uh kind of forgets about
uh technological differences so you
convert them to some common space where
it's safe to just concatenate those data
matrices and this is maybe neural
network similarity network fusion or
umap
can do this very easily
second way is uh to explicitly model
data distributions and this is typical
for all bayesian
ways of data integration so if you have
different
shapes of data distributions and you can
model
them you you have some idea what was the
underlying data distribution uh then you
can sort of combine uh these different
data distributions uh in a base rule so
if you know if you're familiar with base
rule that's uh basically joined
probability of observing all your uh
different data types so you multiply
sort of your uh
different data types and combine them as
a base rule and then more for what i
mentioned previously based networks
they're great at sort of
uh integrating data through through
explicit modeling of their distributions
and then the third way is uh sort of
extracting common variation so you don't
really account for for difference in
data distribution but you sort of you
you you factorize your data extract
common variation and factorize it uh and
sort of try to learn
something
some some common factors common access
of variation uh between the different
data types
uh so i'm not explaining here details
i'm sorry um because then it will take
more time but but you're very welcome to
sort of come back to me if you want to
know more
and as i said
so here i'm talking about data
integration
using this machine learning mentality
and maybe it's it's it's useful to sort
of emphasize uh uh
why i'm sort of uh
talking about machine learning here is
is because of the prediction so i as i
said we are using prediction as an
ultimate criterion of successful data
integration and that's very different
actually from traditional
statistical approaches
i would say that's my opinion it's not
written in stone
but i believe uh that if you sort of
work and
if you do traditional
statistical analysis you are maybe
mostly interested in
detecting candidates some drivers of
your biological process
uh maybe if you're thinking about sort
of genome-wide association studies this
is a manhattan plot
uh where you can sort of detect genes
that have something to do with type 2
diabetes but those are separate genes
it's because you're you're testing them
one by one
and the the consequence the consequence
of this uh uh
this type of analysis this traditional
uh statistical analysis that you
sometimes can end up with with a lack of
prediction uh
uh
for for genetic studies this is called
the case of
of the of the misinheritability maybe
you're familiar with this if you if you
have experience in genetics
that's a very well known problem there
and it literally means
that
genes delivered in this way so you can
get a list of genes that should have
something to do with type 2 diabetes but
if you bring these genes to the clinics
you can't predict you can you can't use
this uh genetic signature in order to
take a blood sample from an individual
and uh predict
the inclination um the risk of this
individual for type 2 diabetes it
doesn't work unfortunately because of
this
the case of
misinheritability problem which means
the lack of prediction so
and in machine learning you optimize
prediction from the very beginning
so
maybe you're familiar with this paper uh
where um
it was a very famous paper a few years
ago where
uh people sort of uh demonstrated how
neural networks can be
can be used for
making very
valuable clinical predictions so really
really bringing
machine learning to the clinics um
and
as i said you here here following this
machine learning mentality you you
really start optimizing prediction from
the very beginning and in in
statistics statistical approach you are
not really
uh interested in prediction so to say uh
in the beginning so that i hope i i
delivered my message
about the difference in the approaches
and by the way uh even if you start uh
with prediction in machine learning way
uh you still can uh uh have a look at
the drivers
um uh
you can sort of roll it back
and
explain why
why your model can predict so if your
model can predict you you still can
understand uh what are the genes
uh what are the drivers uh that provide
this this good prediction
um but but this is uh delivered by
machine model as a byproduct as i said
um
you you from the beginning you start
with prediction and then you can
of course try to interpret it and try to
uh take a closer look why your model can
predict
so now very quickly i i i'll give you um
a practical example so this was a theory
this was sort of uh what essentially we
are doing in many many many different
integrative omics methods
uh now just give you one quick example
how well it works in reality
um so here i'm using a multi-modal
single cell uh technology which is
called
sick it's one of the early
multi-modal technologies that delivers
rna-seq
bisulfite uh for the same biological
cells
and as i said it's quite naive to sort
of just merge just concatenate this data
matrices and uh one way to overcome this
problem of
different statistical distributions of
the data uh would be to
as i mentioned previously to convert
this data to some common space which can
be done through graphs
uh so you you simply uh
now one point here is is one cell
and you are simply so the edges here
they simply mean connections
correlations uh between cells
uh so here regardless of the initial
data distribution uh you kind of you
convert your data
uh to some non-parametric uh
representation where the the graphs they
actually don't remember
uh they don't know anything about the
technology that produce the data
uh but once you convert your data into
graphs you you only keep the pairwise
connections pairwise correlations uh
pairwise links uh between your cells so
now once once you converted your
data uh into graphs now you can sort of
use a concept which is called graph
intersection
uh so it's demonstrated here
on the left bottom corner so when you
intersect graphs you simply uh keep
edges that are consistently present in
all omics
so uh looking at these three graphs you
can say that those two cells so it's
highlighted by red the edge between
these cells is highlighted by red so
these cells were connected here in a
single cell rna-seq and they were
connected in single cell by sulfur check
and they were connected in single cell
ataxic so they will be present uh
on the consensus graph
so by by doing this graph intersection
you build a consensus graph and
sometimes uh you can you can actually
see new clusters when you combine gene
expression with uh genetic
uh so this this is uh if you if you want
to build the the graphs manually but you
don't have to do it actually because
there is a grade 2 view map and usually
people use umap for for visualization of
high dimensional data
but you can also use it for data
integration because essentially on the
first step of umap you convert your data
into graphs and then there is a one just
line of code you can use uh to overlap
different graphs
and here i'm demonstrating it for for
technology single cell technology
multimodal technology which is called
side sec which is sort of uh rna-seq and
and protein-level information from the
same biological cells and this how it
looks like if you uh sort of overlap uh
this two different umap plots
sometimes you can see that this purple
cluster here becomes more transparent so
here it was sort of smeared out and
was not really detectable for clustering
algorithm but combining gene expression
with protein level information you can
you start seeing new
uh cell type and perhaps this is this
cell type has new functionality so gene
expression does not always
separate
functionally different cells gene
expression alone might not be enough to
sort of discriminate between
cells
with different functionalities
so i hope
that's a little bit clear and here i
would like to wrap it up and thank you
for your attention this is our team the
national bioinformatics infrastructure
sweden and i'm from lund university uh
really i really thank you for for
listening
thanks
grunt
can you hear me
oh maybe you can hear me now better can
you hear me now yes
all right very good yeah the old
microphone off trick thank you nicolet
that was uh fascinating and thank you
for helping us understand multi-omics
data integration and the challenges that
are being addressed in this way
it uh to me it sounds incredibly
complicated but i know there's out there
others out there that know it better
it's also interesting at the same time
fascinating i'm sure that many of you
are working how specialized and trained
do you need to be in order to use these
complex methods
um
is the question
yes i mean how specialized do you need
to be able to use these complex methods
is it pretty deep
yes so bioinformatics
sort of implies some mathematical
training some
fair
understanding of mathematics and
programming i would say uh so i
would say
that yes and so uh biology plus
mathematics plus program and this is
pretty much what would
build a good bioinformatician
and um
so it depends on the type of analysis
you are doing sometimes you need to be a
better
biologist sometimes you need to be a
better programmer
but what i was explaining so since i i
have a mathematical background i i see
the data in this way and i hope uh you
you can also find it informative for you
for your research
very good i think a lot of the people on
the call like to know that kind of stuff
so that gives us a nice background thank
you again we appreciate your time thank
you
thank you very much
well julia i'll let you undo your
microphone like i just didn't so in a
different totally different omics
universe our next speaker julia dr julia
penov is the associate director at the
tauber bioinformatics bioinformatics
research center in university of haifa
israel
at tauber
bioinformatics center julia together
with the tauber center team are working
to develop a bioinformatics platform for
analysis of omics data the platform is
constantly developed and expanded to
include state-of-the-art algorithms and
approaches for the analysis of various
types of omics data
including single still single cell
transcriptomics spatial transcriptomics
meta genomics and whole genome
sequencing along with a whole bunch of
other stuff julia it's a pleasure to
have you with us i'll let you roll thank
you
thank you very much let me just uh share
my screen
let's see how i do this
let's see can you see my screen or also
my notes
we can see your screen just fine
great
thank you
um
so um
[Music]
just
get ready for this okay um so thank you
very much for the organizers elias
for this opportunity to speak today
and thank you to the audience for your
time and attention i hope it will be
worth your time
i'm very excited to share with you some
of the improvements and the extensions
that we at tower bioinformatics center
together with the pine biotech have been
working on
for the last several months
today i will focus on the transcriptomic
section of the platform which includes
the
bulk rna-seq dedicated to analysis of
raw rna-seq reads all the way up to
differential expression and pathway
analysis
a separate section on the platform for
analysis of already pre-processed
expression tables
which many times are deposited to the
ncbi database and so can be
uploaded to the platform and analyzed
and the uh
post-processing analysis of single cell
expression data
um
which can be either generated on the
platform or is provided by the 10x
genomics
or in the ncbi database
and also can be uploaded here to the
platform
so
before going uh
into the uh
[Music]
the extensions and the new developments
let me just remind all of us about the
basic steps
uh of the bulk rna-seq analysis so the
first step is the pre-processing of data
which includes the quality control
filtering out the adapter sequences from
the raw reads and filtering of the
duplicated reads which are mostly
generated at the pcr amplification step
of library preparation
and the next step is the alignment step
where the user needs to decide
which reference should be used it can be
either
transcriptome which are individual
transcripts from the genome annotation
file
or the genome where it is possible to
identify newly spliced transcripts
specific to the data set you are
analyzing and so
specific to the molecular events
which you are investigating
after the alignment on the reference
we need to
quantify the expression of genes or
isoforms
and they can be presented either as raw
read counts which are recommended for
further downstream differential
expression algorithms
such as dsec2 or hr or others or in
normalized counts such as fpgam or rpm
and finally the post-processing usually
includes differential analysis
some
pca analysis or enrichment analysis
and if you're familiar with a platform
then you know that we have two basic
sections to the platform or two basic
steps of the platform
the data upload section uh where you are
asked to about your data whether you are
uploading reads from your own computer
or from the ncbi database
also the user is asked about the
reference whether this reference genome
can be found on our system for example
here you can see
that the genome is found in our system
already or the user is asked to upload
his own reference and
another
important uh step is
the experimental putting your samples
into experimental groups
so you are asked to drag the samples
into the correct groups so that
afterwards differential analysis can be
performed
on these
groups of samples
and the next part is the part where the
user is asked to choose the algorithms
and options
and again there are many different
algorithms and options for each step
and we try to help the user by
separating each step into a different uh
columns of the platform and also for co
and also by color coding these steps
so pre-processing steps which are
optional so are missed in this pipeline
that you see on the screen
they are color coded in blue when
pressed alignment algorithms are color
coded in pink and quantification of
expression is green and finally the
post-processing steps are orange and
when algorithms have been chosen on and
the pipeline is executed
you can turn off your computer
and
[Music]
because you will receive a notification
email when the pipeline is finished
and uh if you have seen and worked with
a pi with a platform you know that when
you uh when your pipeline is ready
uh you can download all your set all
your results
from this download
folder
and if we look at this folder you will
see
many files
all of which might be important
but at first i think may feel
somewhat overwhelming
so what do we have in this file we have
fastqc reports which will tell us about
the quality of our reads
we have alignment statistic table which
will tell us about the number of reads
successfully aligned to the genome or
the transcriptome
we also have the expression tables raw
tables for our genes and isoforms and
normalized in fpgam tables
in addition we also have the dsec
normalized table with all the statistics
and the pca table and the pathway
enrichment
table so
to make it more readable and to try to
help the user make order in the files
we now offer quick html graphs and
interactive dashboards
with most relevant graphs and tables
so
this is how now the uh
the pipeline ends with
links to the html graphs and with the
external dashboard
for example this first uh graph this
first link will lead you to a graph
with monty qc where you can check the
quality of your reads
and
decide whether the uh
the
pipeline that you chose
uh was appropriate for your data or
whether you have to clean your data a
little more than you thought was
necessary before
so the other html link will show you for
example volcano plot
and here also you can
decide and get a first impression of
your data and your analysis
and finally the last button will lead
you to an interactive dashboard
and the dashboard has
we think has two main functions at the
moment
first you can more deeply explore your
data and it is interactive uh so you can
change the parameters on the dashboard
see what happens to your data when you
change the parameters so for example you
can change the thresholds of the volcano
plot or you can choose the
top differentially expressed genes and
see how they are expressed you can also
see your table and download your table
and
so this is one of the uses that we see
in this
dashboard and the second use that uh
we think can be useful for the users
is that you can also share your analysis
with your collaborators or other
interested individuals
the dashboard is no longer uh dependent
on the pipeline
and even if you if your collaborators
don't have access to your pipelines or
to the platform you can still share the
link with them and they can download all
the results all the graphs and all the
uh tables and they can explore your data
together with you
uh another uh
potential use of these
new developed dashboards is that
many times
maybe you have run into this problem you
are running actually not one or two
pipelines with the same data but you are
trying out many algorithms with
different parameters so for each data
set you might have 10 or 20
data set
10 or 20
pipelines
and
keeping track of all the uh
tables and of all your
graphs
can be
quite a challenge so a dashboard or
collection of these dashboards
can also simplify things uh and can make
order for uh
for the analysis and for choosing uh the
for choosing the pipelines the
algorithms and the
parameters
so uh this was the dashboard for
differential gene expression and rna and
bulk rna-seq
section
and we also developed the same similar
dashboard for the single cell
rna-seq downstream analysis but before
going into the results
let's just go over the basic steps of
the single cell rna-seq analysis
and maybe some of the challenges that
this type of data
actually presents
so in single cell rna-seq
analysis pipeline we have three main
steps of analysis which are
pre-processing
integration of
several samples
and downstream analysis
so let me present each step using one of
our projects where we investigated the
changes in blood transcriptome in one of
the marine tunicate organisms
during hibernation
caused by drop in water temperatures
so we had five single cell rna-seq
expression tables generated from three
active colonies and two hibernating
colonies
so each
sample consists of
uh
several thousand cells
uh and uh is which are represented by
about uh 18 000 genes
and the first step of analysis was
normalizing the gene expression across
all cells in each sample
and selecting variable features or genes
in each sample
and reducing the dimensions
of the
of each sample
using the pca approach
and the second step of analysis was
merging this different samples
together this is an important step
otherwise known as batch correction and
which was also actually mentioned by the
previous speaker
uh
using uh
there are different algorithms uh of uh
of this batch correction of
uh single cell data
so after correcting for the batch effect
we
cluster the cells and project them on
the two-dimensional plane trying to
sustain the local distances between
cells
and
for each cell cluster
we can find now genes differentiating
this cluster from other clusters
also known as marker genes
and uh here in this particular
project we ran into some difficulty
and maybe some of you who are working
with single cell data and especially
with non-model organisms
can relate
actually uh we found that uh the
we found that only a small number of uh
genes that we found as microgenes
matched the known markers for tunicate
blood cells so we were
quite in a puzzle what to do with these
cells
and finally um
[Music]
without much success in assigning a
particular name to the cell cluster or
uh we still uh continued with our uh
analysis
and and we found genes that were
differentially expressed in active
colonies and in hibernating colonies so
so this is how the
actual analysis looked first we did
quality control and looking at the
graphs generated by the uh
by some of these models that were by the
pipeline we can see that overall
expression levels or accounts
in the hibernating colonies are lower
than the inactive colonies across all
cell types or all cell
clusters
also the number of genes expressed in
each cluster is much lower in
hibernating colonies
and when we uh did when we performed
umap and looking at the umap
projection
of cells in the manifold
we can see that there are much less
cells in the hibernating colonies
compared to the active colonies you can
also produce
a graph that will show it maybe a little
bit
more clearly if you have many cells so
here's the number of cells
and the
clusters and you can see that the active
colonies have a lot of
cells almost in all
clusters
while the number of cells in the
hibernating colonies are very low you
can see here it's a 4000 and here it's
just 75.
also the
density of expression per each cluster
was very low in the hibernating colonies
with some clusters such as
11 12 having no
cells from the hibernating colony
the next step was finding the marker
genes for each cluster and using these
markers together with
known markers of blood of tunicate blood
cells to assign a type of cell to each
cluster and again as i mentioned before
this was a major
problem actually for us
and
so for example we identified four good
marker genes for cluster eight
and these genes were highly expressed in
most cells of cluster eight and were
almost not expressed in other clusters
in other cells in other clusters however
when we tried to compare these genes to
known markers of blood cells of this
tunicate and to its uh close
relatives we could not find any
uh genes that matched
uh so in usual cases when you're working
with model organisms
uh there are uh
different approaches uh to finding the
markers and to assigning uh cell types
these use machine learning algorithms uh
and other single cell atlases that are
available for uh model organisms but for
non-model organisms this is a bit more
complicated and
sometimes is not possible
at least for now
[Music]
so finally we could also
find genes expressed only in hibernating
colonies and almost not expressed at all
in cells of active colonies
so we found two of these genes
gene
4248 and gene two two zero one
so i think i made quite clear that
single cell rnac pipeline genera
generates many graphs and tables
which are all collected in a folder in
the result of the pipeline and we
tried to
compress them each
model is compressed into its own
folder to make a bit more orderly the
result files
however still
we
came to realize that it is still quite
complicated to navigate all these
multiple files especially if you are
just starting your
your way into a single cell analysis
and so
we
have also a dashboard where all results
are are collected and are interactive
and where the users can
easily navigate through the graphs and
files changing
slightly the parameters
and we find that this dashboard can be a
huge advantage
uh it looks like unfortunately i don't
actually have enough time to go over the
dashboard but i'm sure we will
be able to
put this dashboard online and put the
video online how you can navigate
through the dashboard
and what you can actually
see
and again i want to
just mention that
the dashboards can be shared after the
analysis is done
and when you have multiple
pipelines
analyzing the same data set with
different algorithms and different
approaches you can collect these
dashboards
in a more orderly way
to remember and to come back to and
reanalyze
your data and share your research
with others
so uh
what we imagine for the future and for
the future we imagine that these
dashboards will gain momentum and will
uh prove to be an excellent instrument
for sharing biological data sets
together with the results for example we
already started some collections of data
sets related to the same topic
and which can become a resources
a resource for researchers
and where
each researcher can just
go
right into the analysis look at all the
graphs look at all the tables download
the tables download the code that comes
with the pipeline
and we believe
that these can really
allow researchers to easily navigate
all of the analysis of different models
for the disease for example
and
may allow
progress and quick interpretation of the
underlying
events molecular events
also we are planning to make these
dashboards
more encompassing including
adding the option to download the data
together with all the code and r in
python so that even analysis not
performed on
on the pod on the platform can be easily
performed
by the researcher himself
and
so we hope that the dashboards will
become valuable tools for our students
and researchers who use our platform
but also more wide community of
researchers who can easily access
these
dashboards these analysis and these
collections
of data
so um
i want to thank again everyone on the
tauber and the pine teams who were
instrumental in all the developments i
have been speaking about
uh
[Music]
brotzky
thank you very much
and of course
thank you for your time and your
attention
and uh if i have i have three minutes of
there are any any questions i'm ready to
take these
all right we've got a couple prepared
for you first of all thank you julie
that was very nice and thank you for
that uh
information what are the specific
challenges that are needed to be
considered when analyzing single cell
data
i think there are many
different challenges we don't make it
easy on you come on now
sure uh
there are um
many different challenges first of all
there are many different technologies of
generating this uh single cell data and
i think uh
one should be at least aware of these
technologies
and
use the algorithms that are appropriate
for the technology that you're using
uh
another challenge is really uh
what we call batch effect so a different
samples have to be aligned with each
other to be able to integrate them into
one analysis
uh and uh
another challenge is really uh
annotation of the cell types if we're
talking about
some
static tissue and if we're talking about
time course then the challenges are even
more
i think
hard to overcome
sounds like a whole other topic to talk
about exactly
we've got a lot of people learning here
so what are some of the different
techniques instruments uh analytical
techniques that you use to prepare scrna
sequence data
uh so i think uh basically the
techniques can be uh divided into two
types there is um
[Music]
well this is a
you know this is a very big topic
actually when i uh come to think about
it and uh
uh really uh you know
to be able to answer it i would need
another 10 minutes so
okay
very good well we're about at a great
transition point anyhow so we really
appreciate all that data
and all of that information and we
really appreciate your time here and so
now that we know and heard more about
user-friendly solutions that make
bioinformatics more accessible i'm
excited to see how researchers and
students will utilize these methods in
fact if i'm right your the platform you
presented is already integrated into the
omixlogic portal is that correct
yes i believe it is
okay and that will allow students to
learn and apply these techniques so
julia again thank you so much for your
time and uh we appreciate your your
being here thank you very much thank you
for the time
bye-bye
our next speaker is lisa taraneko and i
hope i didn't trash your name too bad
lisa she earned a master's in genomics
and bioinformatics at siberian federal
university
so
she is currently a phd student in plant
site physiology her phd thesis is about
plant genomics epigenetics
and genome annotation of oil palm
wow she's interested in all kinds of
areas loves working on mammals studying
genomics and transcriptonomics
another fascinating type of omics data
is metagenomics and we have been hearing
about all the microbiome a lot it's a
role in health disease therapy and even
prevention and now let's
invite lisa from the tauber
bioinformatics research center to speak
about meta genomics data analysis and
how it can be performed in the t-bio
info platform so welcome lisa we really
are looking forward to hearing about
your area of interest the floor is yours
thank you for having me uh can you see
my screen well
yep
okay
um yeah my name is lisa very i'm very
happy to be here and i'll be speaking
about chime um it is a tool
that we use to analyze metagenomics data
and metagenomics is really about
microbial communities we want to learn
the composition of them and compare them
between each other
metagenomics is used in a variety of
areas in agriculture health care
biotechnology where everywhere but this
topic will be mostly about technical
side of analysis on the platform not the
biological one
so
on our platform
um there is a possibility to
sorry
there is a possibility to use two types
of
data um
upload data
there is a manual upload when you have
all the files downloaded on your
laptop or computer
and ncbi upload so the set of files
needed for each is a bit different
in each case you need metadata where you
have the groupings of your interest
but for manual upload you also have to
have fastq files with your reads and
in case it is multiplex data you also
need barcodes
so
maybe you're already familiar with the
concept of multiplex data it's when in
one run we have several samples and they
are differentiated by the barcodes
so
when this file is in chime it needs
these barcodes to
separate the samples again
um and in ncbi we only need metadata and
this metadata is used to download all
the all the fastq files that we need
so on the
upload panel you have to pick your type
of upload manual or ncbi and you also
have to pick if you have single or
paired and reads
and select the file type if it's manual
upload
for in cbi upload this is a
typical
metadata file and the critical column
here is the first one which has the sra
ids and they will be used to download
all the data you need
where to find this file so you have to
search the sra archive and look for the
study that interests you and there will
be this metadata button uh that will
start the download of the metadata file
just be careful because sometimes it
downloads the file uh with commas as
separators but we only
we can only accept tab separated files
so sometimes this file needs a bit of
correcting before running the pipeline
so when the upload is done either
manually or with the help of ncbi we can
start building our
graph
and
chime is separated into five subsections
and we start with pre-processing so
first we import data
data to chime then with filters samples
we can filter out samples that are too
few in the
number of reads
and then we want to see the quality
control the quality of our reads
then
moving on to processing out use that's
oppression operational taxonomic units
and here we have two algorithms
denoising algorithm data ii and the blur
and what they do they create the um well
they identify the operational taxonomic
units and they calculate the abundance
in each sample and with this table we
can proceed to taxonomy
where we classify our otus with
existing database in this case it's
silva database for 16s rna
where you have to pick your region of
the region that was used for sequencing
in our case it was
variable region four
and you can alter your classification
well resulting
data if you want
and then
we can move on to metrics
where core metrics calculates all the
alpha and
beta diversity
indexes and then we can
visualize alpha diversity with box plots
and for beta diversity
we will need to pick a column for
testing beta diversity
and here i want to um remind what beta
diversity is about because for alpha
diversity and this is
measures different measures that study
the community within itself
but beta diversity uh compares the
communities between each other
so here we
have to pick
some
uh some column that uh has a grouping of
samples that in is we're interested in
in my case it was the body side that was
the sample was taken from
and after beta diversity uh
we also can use interactive
visualization and there we also have to
pick two columns to visualize in my case
i picked bodyside and antibiotic usage
so
when we are ready with our table and uh
sorry graph and we ran this pipeline and
it's finished successfully
um you will see this external dashboard
um
here but actually let me try and go to
the
browser
okay it's here
so this is the pipeline that
successfully finished and i want to
check my results with the dashboard
so let's go here
you can see that in the dashboard
there are three areas of data
um this big bar plots
some
nmds and alpha diversity box plots
and apart from this dashboard tab we
also have a table tab
this is the table that all our plots are
based on
and you can have your otu
ids
and all the counts here for each sample
this is rarefied table meaning that if
you sum up all the abundances for each
sample they will be the same
you can download this data and it will
open you the raw
look of this file you can just copy it
and paste it into text document
you can also download metadata or
taxonomy where for taxonomy it's the
same
logic you have your otu id and all the
taxonomic units
so um
and also you can look
what this otu is associated with what
taxonomic
what text it is associated with here we
have family but again you can look at
different
levels
so back to bash dashboard
this verified table is used to
plot these bar plots
um let me make it a bit bigger
this bar plots that have samples and
relative abundance and you can play with
this graph the way you want you can
again pick the different taxonomic
levels you can pick different coloring
to your liking well this is not very
good
okay let's stick to this
you can download a csv for of this
table or anything
and if you're interested for example
this sample
this uh what tax it is and what exactly
the abundance
is for this sample for this texan
next is nmds
this is
something like a principal component
analysis or principle coordinate
analysis also a dimensional reduction
technique that tries to show the
pairwise dissimilarities between the
samples
um
here it's
also
colors are controlled by these columns
in your metadata and if i
want
not two but only one i can pick
the same color here and
it will be like one group
also if we point at it
it will show
what is the symbol and the color and
coordinates in this three-dimensional
space and the sample
name
and also the alpha diversity box plot
here it all
only shows observed otus
and you can also group it by um
any column from your metadata
and for example in bodyside
um we have 71 observed o2s in gut and
779 165
observed otus in
palms a lot more than in the gut
um
but this is the dashboard um
but actually chime creates a bit more
information than that
and if you want to
look into beta diversity
or more indexes from alpha diversity you
can go to download pipeline
output files
and here you will see um a zip folder
for each job that finished successfully
and i'm interested in alpha diversity
and in beta diversity for example
so
um
let me go back to my presentation
sorry about it
okay we
already finished this
yeah
so
here you have to um get familiar with
how actually chime operates it has two
types of data it has qset a files and
qzv files and both are
normally unreadable to us
with our regular tools
cue that a
has all the tables in it and so we
modify it into txt tables for you to
look at but qzv files are visualization
files and they are specifically designed
to be viewed on the online browser of
chime
and it looks like this and you just take
the file with
qzv at the end and drag it here drop it
and for example let's look at beta
diversity
here
break curtis distance is used to
calculate the distance matrix for the
samples
and we colored them the same way uh with
body side we can see
nice differentiation between the
body sides
but
both palms are together which is also
makes sense
another
[Music]
distance metric jacquard is used here
and they both are
visualized in the emperor plot which is
principle coordinate analysis
algorithm
and we have two more
two more distance metrics uh
metrics that are used by chime it's
weighted unit fractional
and unweighted
um
then if we move on to alpha diversity
visualization we can check out a bit
more of the indices that there are for
example faith index that
shows us the evenness and richness of
the community but it takes into
accordance the philogenetic relationship
between our otus and here
we again see that left ball and right
palm are really um
rich
compared to gut
uh but we actually can kinda see it in
our bar plot we can see that our gut
samples which are these
they are
mostly
comprised of three
taxa
and for example these are palms we can
see that there are a lot more different
bacteria are there
so um apart from box plots chime also
calculates statistics
all groups and pair-wise statistics
and
for example uh here's gut uh versus our
three other tissues and we can see that
there is significant difference with
palms but it's not significantly
different from tongue which also makes
sense
and other metrics are the evenness which
shows how
even
each oto is present in the sample
and
just remembering the box flood i showed
you
the palms are
a lot more evenly present um
than the gut where we have only three
like three bacteria there
and shannon index which also shows uh
evenness and richness
so
thank you very much for your
time and for having me here um i'm ready
for questions
all right i am here i just have to
switch toys to help you out here we do
have a couple questions and thank you
for all that lisa that was uh
fascinating so here's the first question
how has metagenomic data analysis been
used in cancer research
i'm not sure about cancer research just
since i'm really never did it in cancer
research
but i believe that
um
just meta-dynamics in general for human
is used excessively to understand some
under um some
physiological problems uh
that cannot be unders
that cannot be explained by
other techniques for example there are
some diseases
that
genetically we kind of understand but
still the um
like the behavior of our uh
gastrin uh gi tract is cannot be only
explained by the genetics that's when
a metagenomics step in and try to
analyze the microbiome in our gut and
explain this behavior
but in cancer
i really
i don't know
how it's used there
okay sorry about that it wasn't an
attempt to throw you off um just
hopefully find an answer there but thank
you yeah what are major challenges faced
during analyzing metagenomic data
well we rely heavily on the database to
classify our otus so
i think this is oh this is one of the
hardest parts because
most of the databases they don't have
ideal taxonomic
information now
sometimes we end up with a
order of the bacteria and that's the
best that we can get this is a bit
troublesome
and um also situation
there is a difficulty with understanding
where when there is a contamination
because contamination mostly is
bacterial contamination and here we
already are working with bacteria so
sometimes it gets tricky
but i think that classification is kind
of the hardest part in metagenomics
okay thank you
how about this one how can one
transition from statistical analysis to
interpretation of metagenomic data
analysis
from statistical analysis
to interpretation of the metagenomic
data
you mean statistical law is not a major
in statistical analysis i just how to go
from this cross colonist test to
understand how it's by like okay
well
you have to work with biologists
sometimes
well if you really know the subject well
i guess you can interpret it yourself
but most of the time it really needs um
understanding of the processes and what
we can expect because
um a lot of things uh
can go in a way that we do not expect
and that is wrong because sometimes
experiments go wrong and we have to
understand when we are wrong where we
are looking at something that doesn't
make any sense
so
um i would pick
a
biologist in my team
if i had
had a chance and
a friend right
sorry
phone a friend right yeah yeah something
like that
exactly
can microbot bile communities that you
study be modulated with bacterial phages
in a targeted way
sorry
in micro microbial communities that you
study be modulated with bacteriophages
in a targeted way
we
target this
yeah bacteriophages so can you
target specific taxa of
microbes
with phages
um i'm not very knowledgeable in this
area but i think yes we can
but
how would you identify such phages do
you know
well um
how we differentiate texture by
different
differences in the genomes in this
variable parts if we uh
i think that we can
target our phages to these sequences but
i'm really not familiar with the process
how to do that
okay
how about this one what are your
thoughts on using mic using the
microbiome as a fertilizer in
agriculture
well
i think it i'm not sure because
there are different bacteria who well
which work in the soil and which work in
the gut i'm not sure if the same
bacteria will do the same job well
but we definitely
use
species from other animals for uh
soil so maybe there is some idea in that
okay well our apologies for putting you
on the stock we never know when the
questions are going to come in and and
if they're all perfect for you so thank
you so much and uh we will let you go
for your afternoon thank you so much
lisa we really appreciate that yes
well thank you again to lisa and the
team at the tauber bio informatics
research center we're hoping to see more
of this in the future as well so i want
to do a quick recap of what we've done
and heard so far this afternoon elias
shared about the important trends in
bioinformatics and highlighted the need
for training as well as the tools for
user-friendly bioinformatics
and then we heard from dr oskalov about
multi-omics integration
and the use of machine learning in this
analysis and then we heard from julia
and lisa about user-friendly tools to
perform really complex analysis
so you might be wondering how are these
types of data being used by researchers
or industry and what problems can be
addressed by analyzing and integrated
integrating omics data
and to speak about that we're going to
introduce our next speaker
many of us know the smithsonian
but
other than artifacts and a wonderful
museum we may not know about the
research they do i had no idea our next
speaker dr sarah zappico is a researcher
there as well as having a day job as it
were as the assistant professor at the
department of chemistry and
environmental sciences at the new jersey
institute of technology her research
interests focus on the application of
biochemical techniques to forensic
science issues like age at death
estimation and the determination of
post-mortem interval with implications
in aging and biomedical research
fascinating it looks it sounds like i'm
going to watch an episode of ncis sarah
then symposium audience is waiting for
more on your topic thank you
okay thank you very much for this
opportunity and introduction
uh let me share my screen
can you see
we can share your screen you might want
to go to uh presentation mode in your
slideshow menu
no yes it's fine there you go yep okay
good
so first of all uh
yes i am working in forensic science but
uh my phd actually was in biomedical
science in cancer research
but i always wanted to be a forensic
scientist so i changed during my postdoc
at smithsonian institution
because i what i did and i am doing
right now is translate what i learned
during my phd
to forensic science issues so i am going
to
go over the different issues we have
there are more but where we could
we can introduce integrated omics
technologies
so here we have a crime scene that you
can watch for example on ncis
and one of the main things
will be identification
of the perpetrator from evidence of the
currency or sometimes the victim which
is mainly what i do
i understand how familiar you are
with identification in forensic science
but we are using what is called a
nuclear dna length polymorphisms
are
repetitions of four to six nucleotides
are called short thunder rapids and
these ones are normally in intrudes or
intragenic spacers
between genes
and the number of repetitions in its
shorthanded rabbits str
body between people
and the combination of these number of
repetitions in its str gives us the dna
profile that i will show you in the next
slide
actually right now the fbi has selected
20 core str loss site that must be run
in all dna tests in order to provide a
common currency with dna profiles to
upload in the database that maybe you
saw on tv as well
so this is another 20 actually but this
is an example of an str profile what you
see
with the peaks here are the number of
repetitions and
in the top
the estia
here for example the 21s 11 this person
is heterozygous
with 32 repetitions in one chromosome
and in the other one 38
here dh01 you see is only one peak
because this person is homozygous 11 11
and also we check the
sex
eh through
but
what happens in these situations because
what i show you is normally what
you also put on tv the perfect profile
but it's not as easy so many times we
have mixed stores moreover in rank rate
cases
also in mass disaster scenarios we can
have degraded dna and partial profiles
and is when
genomics uh in this case massive
parallel sequence plays a key role uh
first of all i put here the forensic dna
signature prep kit from perugian because
it's the one approved by the fbi to
upload in the database
so still
this kit what it does is to analyze 27
global autosomal sdrs also ystr which
are from the male chromosome as you know
but are from the uh for example in cases
of in red cases etc and ex
sprs from the female
since the coverage that i show you uh in
the bottom is possible to a better uh
resolution in challenging samples for
example the greatest samples and
increase the resolution for mixed stores
and although sometimes is still
difficult but still
the application of genomics in this case
to forensic science will help in these
challenging situations
but
we always need a reference sample
so something to compare it doesn't
matter if we have the profile from the
crime scene
or the big thing
if we don't have something to compare
a reference from the victim or a
reference sample from a possible suspect
in this case we can think about what is
called forensic dna phenotype
this means it means infer the sample
donors estimate a disabled
characteristics eye color hair color
skin color from dna from the biological
material at the crime scene or from the
unknown bodies also we can include here
ancestry and h
in this case
we use
snips single nucleotide polymorphisms as
you can see from the picture is are
changes in only one base
and the combination these changes
are giving us the
different colors the eye color the hair
color the skin color and the ancestry
here you have a
comparison between strs and snips
and maybe you think if it will be
possible also to identify a person using
snips only yes and as you can see here
we have the identity snips
but
you require more snips identity snips to
be able to provide an identification
and also yes phenotype snips
and ancestors
so going back to the uh to this kit uh
this has two separate uh
i would say kids
instead of the kids so the first one is
the one i told you before with the sdrs
the second one is this one with the
n94 identity snips 22 phenotyping snips
for hair color
eye color
um skin color and 56 biogeographical
ancestry and here in the picture is the
result of the software
but with this you have to be careful
because phenotyping and ancestry
analysis are not allowed in sound of the
stage so
moreover in cases that you are looking
for the perpetrator because snips in
this case phenotyping and
biogeographical ancestry constitutes
identifiable information
if you realize when i talk about strs
strs are in introns or intragenic spaces
so this one you don't have the
information doesn't have any meaning but
this one does
so for the reason
in some places some states is really
difficult to use this
for example for identification of the
perpetrator not
as much for trying to identify the
victim
and the other trends right now that you
i ensure her a lot
is the lineage snips
and presenting forensic genetic
genealogy
this is based on the uh looking for
identical by descendant snips so the
snips we share with our ancestors like
here in this uh family tree
and here you have a table with the uh
relations um between the parents etc
and how does it work so when you do one
of these uh tests period to consumer
data
tests today ancestry etc now you have
the option to decide if your data can be
stored in the database or not
if this data is stored in the database
uh get match or family dna then
the forensic analogies are able to
access this data and go um try to for
example from an evidence of the crime
scene
uh to see if
you or or whoever has a relation with
the perpetrator for example from the
crime scene
and these are the different um
i would say kits or microarrays
depending on the type of
kit depending on the yeah on the table
kit you see um
they are overlapping uh some of them
have more snips than others but at the
end
they do almost the same but looking into
different things
and this is the workflow uh basically
when the investigator has a cold case
because i am sure you've heard right now
a lot of cold cases are solved thanks to
policy and genealogy so they have also
to request permission to use the
evidence from the crime scene
for foreign
then depending on how the things are
there are some labs that they do the
whole thing
analyze the snips and then
do the genetic genealogy or others they
simply send to the labs
uh do analyze destiny and analyze the
snaps and send to the genetic clean
allergies so they do the microarray for
the snips or a whole genome sequencing
and then they send to the genealogies to
do the genetic
genealogy analysis
and based on that then they can follow
the uh trait to see if
this aspect could be related to someone
in the
in the database
but again we have another problem here
because forensic kinetic genealogy as
foreign phenotyping provides
investigative leads to currently
identify the victim or the perpetrator
at the end it requires str analysis and
comparison so
it doesn't matter that you have this in
the forensic kinetic genealogy at the
end you need to compare the suspect
str profile with this profile from the
crime scene so again we have another
legal
issue here
and i include this one here because
we actually use for
some cases mostly degrading and
difficult samples is the analysis of
mitochondrial dna
the only problem it has is inherited
from the mother so
the
all the relatives from the maternal
limits they have the same mitochondrial
dna it's not unique because you can i
would say
share uh
share but uh cannot have the same
mutations as other person
and here what we analyze normally is uh
the
the control region which is a hp1 hp2
and hp3
so you compare these
the mutations of these regions using
normal standard sequence with a
what is called a revised cambridge
reference sequence and then
you compare and know the mutations with
these mutations you determine the
mitochondrial approach
where this i would say this person comes
from from the maternal units
so
there is here another uh this is also
from bayern
sun labs also are using is the forensic
and mitochondrial dna control regime and
whole genome kid so they have to again
two options you can only analyze other
region but the problem is if the person
doesn't have enough mutations in the
control region it's better to
to get the whole the
mitochondrial upper group to get the
whole
genome
and this is an example of the results
from one of the kids
and also this is the validation you can
see
that they more or less get the same
mutations
from the control region and the whole
genome kit
and
we normally use this for this kind of
samples that i told you uh they really
samples difficult samples like like bone
teeth a hair with a root although now
it's possible to get nuclear dna from
her with a root but before it was more
difficult so normally
you get mitochondrial dna fingerprints
for example because they don't have so
much dna and
remains or archaeological samples
so here we cover the genomics and
including dna profile phenotyping and
genius
going back to our crime scene
the other question is how long ago the
person died
and although on tv maybe uh used to is
easy
actually it's more on one of the most
challenging things in forensics so
maybe you are familiar with the terms
gregor mortis evo mortis algor mortix
these are good
but for the termination of post-mortem
interval or pmi
but
the main problem they are good for the
first
days of that
and after that is more difficult to
determine the pmi and also you can think
about insert activity but also has some
disadvantage
and also is not the same of course dying
or decomposing here in new year's eve
for example in maya
so
one of the things to improve that is
what we call sanetobiology
is the use of advances based on dna rna
and protein research for pmi estimation
and this is based on at the beginning
the cells go to autolysis
but the cell nucleus remains in that
four days after that
so we can apply cell biology methods for
pmi estimation
and here we are talking first about
transcriptomics
and i would like to show you this uh
study from
my group
we analyzed the post-mortem interval in
rat muscle
and
but using actually rna expression of
different
different
genes from autophagy and
apotoxy signal
what we realized was there is a switch
in signaling in the first hours of it
at the beginning there is an autophagy
signaling
because the cells are going to die by
but try to mitigate the estras
but at the end around 4-6
hours after that there is a
triggering of the apoptosis signaling
creating the extrinsic and intrinsic
pathway
and then releasing oxidative stress and
other components that could try to
mitigate that
so this was really interesting because
of the switching signals so when i was
actually a student for
a pump time biotech uh i did uh as a
final project i did
this a small study with uh previous data
from pratt retina and if you are
interested in the whole study is in the
youtube channel application of
transcriptomics amateur machine learning
to post multimeter on estimation and
here i would like to show you the
volcano plots that we
developed so you can see how
from the beginning of the death
there are there are kind of changes in
the expression of the different games
until the end uh 24 hours
is
up to where they get samples using more
genes
are experts
and
what
i really like because
is
is related to my previous research is
that when we analyze the pathways
affected and here you can see apoptosis
pathways some
genes were over expressed and others er
down dispersed so as you can see this
one more or less compare our previous uh
research
so we talked about uh transmitomics and
now the next one and also one of the
trends right now is proteomics analysis
of protein abundance
in postmodern
there are more studies but this one is
more or less recent and also following
with the mouse rat
mouse uh
studio you can see how
these are different animals i will say
but um
they have similar
outcomes in terms of proteomics and also
some of the proteins overlap as you can
see in in the b
and in fact they identify two proteins
that decrease with the postmortem
interval in both
uh
animals jpd8s and ef1a
so this can be useful for analyzing the
post-mortem interval in this case
so yeah we have the proteom
and then another trend is the
metabolomics analysis of metabolites as
a consequence of the decomposition
process
and here i would like to show you this
is from 2020 but i think it's really
interesting because here they could do a
study with human subjects
uh without killing anybody they did at
the
texas state university uh forensic and
tripoli research facilities so including
donations
and compared with the rats and as you
can see in the top you have two human
subjects over time
uh you can see how there is an increase
in these metabolites
are amino acids other are
decompositional by products and also in
rats you see mostly
amino acids
free amino acids
so it could be useful in both
rats and human subjects for pmi
so here
we saw that proteomics and metabolomics
can help for pmi estimation
the other uh approach for pmi estimation
is the analysis of standard microbial
and this fits
very well with the previous talk because
this is related to the analysis of
changes in bacterial communities as a
consequence of the decomposition process
so analysis here applying metagenomics
and here i would like to show you uh two
studies from my colleague the story
series
uh she
did also these studies with human bodies
from the
foreign research facility at the
university of tennessee knoxville
and in this first study she analyzed how
the soy microbial chains
with a data composition of the of the
courses and as you can see in the three
subjects in this case called three
donors
there uh you can see the same pattern at
the beginning there are a
proteobacteria from this
and others at the end mostly is
proteobacteria and feminine goods in the
three of them with variability because
obviously there is some variability on
the subject but still
you see the trend
but also what is really amazing is that
in the second study she analyzed the
oral microbiome of the corpses so see
how this changes
with the pmi
and you can see more or less the same
thing in the three donors but also you
see at the end the most common er taxa
or fila is the proteobacteria and
physical test so this
these are really interesting uh studies
because also we can apply
uh micro microbial microbial uh analysis
to a determination of the pmi and in
fact the thoracerius and i
are going next week to the forensic
anthropology research facility at
western arena university to continue
with this research and the transatomic
research
so here we talk about
metagenomics for pmi extinguish
estimation
i'm going back to our crime scene and
although i said this here it will be one
of the first thing you try to do at
crime scenes is identification of body
fluids although you think
it could be easy
it's not standardized because what it
looks like to be blood it could be
ketchup for example
so in terms of in this case people
approach these with proteomics analysis
there are different techniques
mainly malditov or cutoff
and is based on the identification of
proteins or combination of proteins
characteristics of the body fluid
however it's difficult to translate to
the field because normally when we go to
a crime scene
we try to detect all the fluids using
automatic light sources and then when
you identify them
you analyze on site
sometimes if not you send to the lab
with
for example rapid immunochromatographic
tests which are similar to the copy
therapy test that we use right now so
these are similar for blood semen saliva
etc
however this proteomics analysis
could be a conflamatory test for body
fluid identification
and here you have a summary of the
different um
different proteins
analyzing in the different main body
fluids that you find at the crime scene
but i would like to show you like two
examples this one they did with malditov
as you can see they didn't analyze the
whole ex spectra as previously but you
see the difference in the pattern
between seminar genie which is a
protein from semen
versus alfamilase which is from saliva
you can see the
the pattern in the in each one in the
mass step
in this other study uh you can see also
the different proteins
and the relative intensity or relative
absolutes
and in this case the authors also they
analyze uh so
pass through the
qt of
samples from crime scene so evidence
samples and even uh
they what they analyze the different
proteins
much uh well with the
with the polyfruit for example semen and
also semen
in different substrates cotton leather
so even with that
having the body fruit in a substrate
it doesn't matter because you can still
identify the body fruit
so here we can include in the proteomics
metabolomics the body fluid
identification
so in conclusion omix technologies can
help to solve current issues in forensic
science like identification of
challenging samples and improving
post-mortem interval estimation among
others
but omix approaches are slowly
integrated into the forensic field to
its legal limitations as i described at
the beginning
photo research will be able to span this
current studies hopefully leading to a
wider implementation of comics
technologies
and as i told you from our part we are
going to continue with research in
transcriptomics and microbial as i told
you with the thorium series i haven't
talked about epi genetics but i am using
epigenetics for age estimation and from
teeth
but
the integration of
next animations
in technologies in this case is slowly
as well
and also is using epigenetics for body
fluid identification also another thing
i didn't mention but is also
still on the works
and microbial forensics for human
identification and body fluid
identification so here we need to
include this
epigenetic
metagenomics
and
i would like to thank first you all for
distancing uh all the people involved in
the postmortem interval project also
time bio for the invitational support
their house during the uh the course i
was doing
um yeah uh one thing uh i am hiring uh
we are looking for a postal biology is
biochemist bioinformatics someone who
knows how to work with this data it
doesn't need to be a bioinformatics but
uh yeah
and also if you're interested in these
uh topics
thank you you have any questions i will
be happy to answer now or later you can
send me an email thank you
thank you sarah forensics is such a
captivating field you know we see it in
tv like i said in movies and yet so much
more i appreciate your time and
knowledge for sharing with us we do have
a couple questions for you in our time
that we've got left so feel free to
expand
how do forensic sciences benefit from
the omics technologies
so in general for example uh at the
beginning when i talk about genomics
in this case
because of the coverage of the olmics
technologies is er
obviously is easier or more like uh
yeah it coverage more in terms of more
for example the greedy samples
so
the problem
when we try to um amplify the str's in
in general
uh is that sometimes the primers are
really uh
out of not out but are not closer enough
in the region so integrity samples is
one of the three problems that you have
so with the coverage of the olympics
technologies
in genomics in this case it's possible
to cover this region several times
analyzed several times and try to be
more precise and getting better profiles
for example and then in post-modern
interval estimation in this case uh in
general transcriptomics proteomics et
cetera could help us
the different studies described
in improving their estimations
fascinating so what are the skills
required to establish a career in this
field
uh important okay uh these are different
skills i mean depending also on what you
know it's funny because you know uh i am
coming from biomedical science i mean i
am biologists and biochemists
uh in spain i am originally from spain
uh in spain we don't have so much in
forensics so i did my best in biomedical
science
uh
still i could change so i did a master's
in fluency androgen genetics at the
university of granada and i changed my
postdoc to forensic science so
i think the most important thing is uh
you are
interested in this field uh you are
willing to learn
and you have an open mind
you know there are a lot of legal
limitations in forensics as i describe
but uh i ensure doing research will help
with so many things for example
identification of human remains so
basically
yes
if you're interested in dna i mean uh
biology biochemistry
yes it's basically these are the skills
you got you're gonna have to know a lot
of that i'm getting from all the
speakers that it's just not you gotta
just go know this you've gotta gotta
know a whole bunch of stuff right yeah
yeah
yeah so i'm gonna i'm gonna come back to
real questions i've got a question my
own when are we gonna see on tv
i know
so what are the current omics
technologies used for data from forensic
science
so
assuming
in real forensic cases uh it means
because in forensic cases i know for a
fact that
some people are using the
i i mean beryllium is not paying me for
saying that but it's because it's the
one approved by the fbi i know some
forensic labs they use the
very genkit the forensic signature kit
also others
the str's
others use the
the mitochondrial dna for sure
and
also
because it's gonna think you heard a lot
the forensic genealogy
so
applicable to forensic cases
then in research we are using
all the
uh all the techniques that i show you
today
so one thing is research but in terms of
currency cases
people are using the the omics the
genomics forensic kit
then the
forensic genealogy
okay
how did you get interested in this what
made you switch to this field
actually i wanted to be a forensic
scientist since i was a child
but again
the problem
was in spain there were not so many
opportunities
so
yeah i got my phd i mean
i am grateful for the uh time during my
phd i learned a lot and in fact what you
saw today uh related to the post-mortem
interval the
uh rna expression analysis was because
of what what i was doing during my phd
but i really want i know is that and
also some people will tell you that yeah
the funding in forensic is not great but
still i think you are helping people
so i think this is the most important
thing
thank you so much we really appreciate
your time here i think at least i think
everybody's fascinated because of all
the tv shows and movies but um
it's still fascinating that all that can
be determined in that way so we really
appreciate your time here sarah thank
you for being on the uh symposium and
we'll bring you back here in a few
minutes for the panel at the end so
stick around we'll be right back to you
thank you thank you so much thank you
you're welcome
[Music]
well thank you again to sarah and before
we move to the south america speaker
presentation i want to introduce louis
carniel
lucas is our south america moderator and
also a partner at pine biotech and lucas
if i can see you coming up on the screen
here there you are no there's still
there he is there he is we'll get you on
the screen here um we're going to have
you go ahead and come out and have you
introduce omnics training
it's all yours
thank you grant thank you all first i
would like to
thank the academy
and all the participants present here uh
it's with great honor that i would like
to introduce and represent the
participation of south america in this
event
so i will share my screen
with you all
just a moment
lucas you're muted at the moment
and we lost you
and we'll give lucas a moment here to
come back on dr sakamoto will be with
you in just a minute oh look we got
we're going to come to you early it
looks like lucas has dropped out of zoom
so we're going to go ahead and come to
you luis if you are ready for us
um
well let me see we're trying to get him
back in here so give me just a minute
luis
the fun of zoom
give us just a moment please
all right luis we're going to go ahead
and pull the trigger here i'm not seeing
lucas come back in and we don't want to
sag too long so we're going to talk
about precision
and we all know about being precise in
language or when measuring a board
measure twice right
but precision is a relative thing if
we're going to the moon we may measure
in miles and my woodworking is in
fractions of an inch but precision
medicine in pediatric oncology is the
specialty of our next speaker dr luis
sakamoto dr sakamoto is a medical doctor
with more than 20 years of experience
treating children and adolescents with
cancer god bless you sir his topic is
the state of the art and perspectives
relating to precision medicine and
pediatric oncology louise something
tells me we're not going to be using my
wood shop
ruler hello hi everyone thanks for
having me thanks for the organizer to
for the invitation to
speak a little bit about my
my
my field my my work field that is
pediatric oncology
well i
guess i
let me see if i can
share my screen with you
just a little bit
[Music]
okay
let's see here
are you seeing my screen
yes we are we can see your presentation
just fine okay
okay next
okay
uh
this is this is
the top that we we will talk about today
uh i will
as i
i guess i think
uh
there is fewer
even known
attendance here that
are used to deal with children with
cancer so i will i will bring you a
little uh a few
few informations about pediatric
oncology and
in the second part i i
we will talk about uh
how this bunch of information that is
generated by the omix platforms uh
are changing the way that we we see the
disease in tube in
children
and how we can use this technology to
improve the efficacy of treatment
in the efficacy that i will talk about
this later but uh after that is already
uh really good when comparing to
adulthood cancers
so
let's go
um
why i
i guess that there is no
attendant here that is uh used to to
deal with
children with cancer it's because cancer
is a
rare event in childhood
in fact
uh
when we compared uh the incidence of
of cancer
in adult
adults and
in childhood we can see that the numbers
are
very different and we can conclude that
cancer is a disease
uh
proper from older people
so it's a really uh
comprehensive
really
understandable that there is no no
attendant here that uh used to deal with
this type of disease
uh
[Music]
but uh
this the
childhood cancer
although uh very hair
uh is in the
in the
in the high and middle income countries
uh is the second leading cause of of
death
in fact uh
cancer in childhood only
only
is only lost for the the
i'm sorry
just just a minute
oh okay
in fact uh cancer uh
only lost for the
only lose for for the the accidents as a
elite cause of death and
the the the major
the most common type of cancer types of
cancers are
that really that are related to a
metabolic
system
so we have the leukemia that are the
most common
in second place lymphomas and in the
third place
the central nervous systems tumors
although they are hair diseases uh
they are in the same way
a quite uh
very curable diseases
uh
if we
we see the evolution of treatment from
the 1970s to 2010 we can see that
there is a
huge improvement
in the efficacy of the treatment and a
decrease in the
in the mortality
especially for acute leukemias and
brain lymphomas and
brain brain brain cancer and lymphomas
especially non-vodka and hard king
informers
so this this type of graph
is
uh
it's a
a a reason for uh
all all pediatric oncologists
are very proud of this area of interest
because today we can cure a lot of more
children than not here
so why is important to
to study this this uh this type of
disease
uh given that we have a disease that is
quite here um
and it it's very curable uh the fact is
uh when we talk when we are talking
about a
a disease that's very curable
um
we have to think to
give back this this person this child to
the workforce to the society to to the
workforce and as uh
shown as a recent study that's published
in lansing's oncology uh
we
we see that
cancer in the childhood is a
a very common cause of disability and
and
morbidity in adulthood
so
um we occur a lot but uh
at what cost we are hearing
in middle and low-income countries
however we
we can see that this evolution of
efficacy of treatment
is not
as good as in high income countries we
can see for example that
the
the usa france australia european uh
countries are far
away and a lot better in terms of
efficacy of treatment than uh
latin america and east asia for example
we have a problem with
low and middle-income
countries that
in fact we don't know
uh
exactly how we are treating this this uh
these patients because we don't have a
system of register of cancer that is
really a
really good
and we can see in this graph that the
proportion of patients that are covered
by this
registries of cancers
are
almost
100 in north america but in latin
america for example it's only only less
than twenty percent
so
we are curing less and uh even
those with uh uh are
are not cured i mean we don't know that
why why why they are not
they are not being cured
uh
as i've shown before
in that graph that
shown the the evolution of efficacy in
pediatric oncology
all that evolution was due
the improvement of of supportive care
and conventional chemotherapy known of
that evolution was due
the new technology that we have today
and in the past
when when i i we treated for example uh
leukemia
in acute lymphoblastic leukemia
all we we did
when we are characterizing that disease
is to
to see the morphological aspect of the
cell and
try to differentiate differentiate these
cells from another kind of leukemic
cells that are myeloid leukemia so in
that in in
that time we have only the
the ability
to to differentiate myeloid myeloid
cells from lymph lymphoid cells
with the advent of the immuno
immunophenotyping
we had the capability to
we had the
we we we were able to characterize more
the cells in b cells or t cells and to
define
subgroups of leukemic cells
and this is a methodology that is used
nowadays to
to make the the conventional diagnostic
of leukemias but with the advent of the
new ohms platforms we are able as you
can see in this this graph
we are able to
to separate to
to define
various uh
subgroups of leukemia
leukemic cells that are that have
different clinical uh behaviors and
different prognosis
for example i
i would like to
to
i'd like to
to detail here uh this philadelphia
chromosome positive
acute lymphoblastic leukemia that
in the past has a
a really poor prognostic prognosis but
today with the advent of the tyrosine
kinase inhibitors have a better
prognosis and
with the advent of this on platforms we
were able to identify a group of
patients that are similar to this
philadelphia philadelphia chromosome
positive
patients but
in fact they they they don't they don't
have they don't have this this
chromosome altered chromosome
we
now are able to differentiate for
example
acute myeloid leukemia from adults
originated from adults
from acute myeloid leukemia from
childhood
as you can see here the target study
that
is performed is performed in in
in in
childhood
as compared to the tcga that was
performed in
in adulthood
uh demonstrate that we have a bunch of
alterations that are totally different
totally different
when comparing children and adults
as well the
the genes that are more prevalent as
alterated in in children are not
are not
almost
almost never outer alterated in the
adults and vice versa
we study another a type of of of
neoplasms that is uh medulloblastoma
that
is a a type of tumor that is quite
common in
in childhood it's originated from
cerebellum in the fossa posterior for
the cranium
in the past we are
we are
we were
we are able to
to
uh to classify only with the basis of
histology
but nowadays we
with the advent of the
omics platforms we
are able to define
four
groups of patients four groups of tumors
that has
quite different
prognostic
probabilities
just to know wnt
tumors
have a survival rate that is
are really really really higher
when compared to the group 3 for example
that are the
group that have the worst prognostic
and the worst survival rates
another utility that we have for this
new technologies is
uh
when we have uh
some kinds of drugs target tariffs that
are specific to the to
to
some kinds of of of uh
of gene alterations
and uh
we want to see if that alteration uh
that alteration
indicates the use of of of
of
of a specific drug
but to do that we have to to know if
that of the molecular alteration this is
an actionable target
and what is the action of type a target
is
a alteration
genetic or epigenetic that can be used
as a diagnostic prognostic too as well
uh can be predict treatment response
uh
there there are a lot of a lot of uh
uh schemas that to define this this
uh if the the target is in fact
actionable uh and i will not talk about
this uh right now
but uh
in general we we defined four tires of
or or or
four levels of importance to define if
the that target is actionable
and the taiwan is the
that variants that have a strong
clinical significance
and that
that that alterations um
implies in the the almost in the
the obligation of use of that the term
the term
that the specific drug
uh the tyre
uh is when we have a a
a variant that have a potential clinic
clinical significance but we we don't
have a for example fda approved therapy
for that
tyre 3 is that alterations that have a
non-clinical significance and
tire 4 is
just alterations that are
probably
passengers alterations that have no
significant clinical significance
i
brought the i brought here a clinical
case just for an example uh
a case often a male with
two years old patients with a diagnosis
of neuroblastoma that is a a type of
tumor that
that
originates from the sympathetic system
it was performed the ngs third that
demonstrates that this tumor has a
mutation g26s
in arc gene
and the problem is uh to define if this
is this alteration is clinically
relevant or not
uh and if it's relevant if this patient
is a kid that to to to the use of hulk
inhibitors
and we can
nowadays we can use uh we can make use
of
some platforms that are publicly
available one of them is from the sanjut
cloud
and what we see here
is that in fact uh
there is a description of this mutation
in alk
that already
have
been described
patients with neuroblastoma but we can
see here that the the the alterations
that
were described in the arc related to
neuroblastoma are
in other regions that
uh
are not this this this uh mutation that
was found in in our patients and the
classic uh r
1275 q that is related to the a alkene
hipto response uh is is far away from
this alteration that was found in our
patients
uh
just a second let me
just erase this
when we
when we made a search in
another uh databases we we found that
we found that this these alterations
have no
uh that have have has an uncertain
significant clinical significance
and in the cosmic database we we found
no
uh
no
uh potential target terp to be
that could be
used for this patient so
in this case the
defined of
alteration in alp g26s has no
clinical significance for the patient
so i think i'm done here
is that the end of your
i don't know
yeah
yeah okay
all right thank you luis thank you for
your incredible work
we all appreciate how important
pediatric oncology is and how it can
affect our families so thank you again
for sharing
and i'm sorry i don't have me on the
screen there
there we go not sure anybody wanted to
see me but there we are it feels a
little better there's dr sakamoto again
thank you again
this time we're going to stay clear and
bring lucas back on the screen for just
a moment he had an intro a little while
ago and then we had a zoom problem
that's first time that's ever happened
so
lucas i'm going to go ahead and take us
off the screen and bring you back before
we go to our panel discussion
it's all yours
so should i start
yes
okay
yes go right ahead please
let me share my screen
okay
so as i was saying before i would like
to take the academy and now the
participants present here
it's with great honor that i would like
to introduce and represent the
participation of south america in this
event
uh
my name is lucas i'm an undergraduate
student in statistics at the federal
university of ireland the march
and i'm a moderator at pineville tech
and i will start by talking about the
plans and the perspectives for the
contribution of comics large program in
brazil as well as the current scenario
of bioinformatics and why to encourage
the teaching of this area in brazil
so we have about two programs only for
the academic degrees of hd and dac
according to the international society
of computational biology and about just
six universities that offer postgraduate
courses focused on the area of
bioinformatics
with master and doctorate academic
degrees
so in addition to these programs there
are graduate programs in computational
biology that are offered by the theoplus
institute in the national laboratory for
scientific computing
it's not stable that bioinformatics is
still a new science in development in
brazil but also in the rest of the world
so some brazilian states especially in
the northeast
they lack this kind of knowledge and
there is an uneven distribution in the
implementation of bioinformatics
teaching among the brazilian regions
so the use of tools and information
obtained from the development of
bioinformatics can bring significant
advances to the field of education in
brazilian science
in that case a bioinformatics software
is well said that as an educational tool
in different educational institutions in
brazil
because it allows students to associate
the theoretical knowledge of biology and
computing
with the reality through the perhaps in
a virtual environment
so with that in mind
uh omixologic training has been the
focus of my work with buying biotech to
reach the faculty and disseminate this
kind of knowledge in threats among the
students and with that to encourage
these people in the citizen science of
south america to participate in this
community to contribute with the
advancement of this area in the country
so
i was
talking about the precision medicine
before the dr luiz
but
let me briefly highlight a few important
points about the topics of comics data
and bioinformatics in south america
in 2017 the brazilian association of
personalized and precision mixing was
created
there are small technology-based
companies are whitefield are now able to
identify new markers and develop new
tests that utilize genomics for medicine
in brazil this area is still
underdeveloped
in reality compared to
other countries like the us
but there is a trend to expand and grow
so with that in mind
uh training for new students is critical
to for the success of this domain once
large training and its problems are
designed to introduce anyone from a life
science background to the concepts and
large behind arms data bioinformatics
and their applications
and today i'm excited to share that we
are translating the materials into
portuguese and spanish and we'll be
making them available for free over the
next few months
i'm excited about the potential for
precision medicine
and that we have so much data available
to guide clinicians to adapt this
approach to the needs of patients across
brazil and south america
so
that's it
after that i would introduce the doctor
sakamoto
to talk about what the future holds for
precision made seem to become a reality
for every patient starting from the ones
for most benefited
[Music]
uh yeah thank you lucas for the
introduction and and thank you uh dr
sakamoto for sharing these insights i
think we can go on
and move on to our next speaker doctor
story canaan so grant grant if you don't
mind introducing him
we'll do that thank you so much
this time we're going to stay in the
same galaxy of cancer systems but a
totally different solar system as it
were we'll also touch on machine
learning statistics and large-scale data
our passionate speaker is dr kasturi
kanan an associate professor and
director of computational pathology
program at the university of texas md
anderson cancer center in houston texas
he's a data science with expertise
scientist with an expertise in cancer
economics epigenomics biomedical
informatics and image processing kashuri
is also working currently on systems
biology and spatial stachotic processes
with its application to multiplexed
immune
images i'm not even sure what i just
said but i'm sure it'll all be clear in
the next 30 minutes or so
sorry this the stage is yours thank you
sir for being here
oh thank you
this has been a wonderful gathering and
it's my pleasure i have known elia for
quite some time
and i'm uh
nice to meet him and everybody here
so uh let me start sharing my screen
are you able to see my screen
we can see your screen but you might
want to go there you go absolutely great
all right
okay so let's get started without any
further ado today i'm going to talk
about bioinformatics and
cancer systems biology in particular i'm
going to touch upon why bioinformatics
has been
critical for cancer cancer systems
biology
i have nothing to disclose or no
conflict of interest uh before going
into the topic uh first of all i would
like to establish my credentials on uh
on this area uh in general about uh you
know
what what led me so far uh the current
position here basically i'm a
mathematician i got my masters
in mathematics from india and then i
moved on here to study mathematics in
particular i was more interested in
topology approximation theory etcetera
etcetera
but my interest shifted towards computer
science and uh i graduated with a uh
with a phd in computer science
especially in computational physics
until about 2008 i have no idea of what
bioinformatics is uh or biology in a
biology of bioinformatics
i should share an anecdote that in fact
my mentor she wanted me to pursue
bioinformatics and she was interested in
protein folding and at that point i said
no no i'm not at all interested in
bioinformatics
but it later turned out that i went to
medical research institute where i got
some basics of biology and that led me
um
naturally to bioinformatics um you know
working with the datasets biological
datasets
and i was doing genomics uh large-scale
uh system studying brain tumors at
memorial sloan kettering cancer center
uh and then that led me to the position
at new york university where i was an
assistant professor and um
i came to know about elia and we had a
good conversation and uh i got
introduced to him at that point
and slowly that led me to our current
position at md anderson cancer center i
am an associate professor and director
driving driving majorly uh what is known
as computational pathology and but
that's not going to be the topic of
today i'm going to talk about uh one of
the another uh exciting area that i have
been um that have been working for about
uh maybe two years now uh in general my
expertise are
uh i mean um like uh you know uh it's
it's it's it's very like you know it's
like a swiss army knife i mean
in general i would like to call myself
as a data scientist about 15 years uh
specifically focusing on cancer research
all right
so
let's go to the topic uh let's go to the
state of modern biomedicine right i mean
it's like a big elephant and we all know
the story that
elephant and blind men right some people
that's uh touching their tails and
thinking that's a snake and some of them
touch the
skin and saying it's a wall etcetera
etcetera but nobody gets a big picture
right i mean it's so fragmented and this
fragmentation actually appears
especially when it comes to drug
discovery we have water water everywhere
not a drop to drink and uh data data
everywhere not a drug i think that's one
of the fame
quote that's been
you know widely used now
but but the key thing is that we all
know that the medicine is very very
fragmented and bifurcated
uh and so we are having a hard time in
reconciling you know what directions to
pursue what are the good targets i mean
people go by single cell rna-seq or i
mean all the things have now
come to the fore good thing is that we
have discovering so much the data is
everywhere
uh but unfortunately it's all difficult
to put everything together to find a
bigger picture of what's happening in
modern biomedicine
so the key question
as we dive into the topic is about
nature versus nature right at the end of
the day we can think of genetics as
something hard coded in our dna
right mutations in deletions etc etc
and then there is a whole phenomenon of
epigenetics where
the methylation and other things can
contribute to uh gene expression
silencing and uh
and we know that these are this is
another major mainstream mechanism so
people are like
uh some people subscribe to genetics and
some people subscribe to epigenetics
like i was telling about the elephant
and blind man right i mean uh i have
seen people uh saying that okay i am a
geneticist and i believe in epigenetics
so the key questions is whether how they
interplay right um
one of you i mean whoever have a strong
base in uh studying the dna might uh
might subscribe to the dna model uh the
basic central dogma and say that
genetics is the
key thing that's driving but but we
really don't know the answer that's the
truth
so in the absence of consensus right in
god we trust all others must bring data
so what does that data tell us right
whether it subscribes to genetics or
whether it says that it's genetic some
genetics we know that it's both but how
much of it right i mean the problem is
that
the data now we have a deluge in biology
right explosion of data sets now we have
the ngs uh they're all bioinformaticians
you know about all these things i don't
have to tell
but then the primary
aspects of the data or mutations copy
numbers when it comes to you know dna of
course gene expression could be
controlled by both by the dna as well as
the rna
and
you know there are so many other things
like structural variants and so many
other things that we could study
uh that we are unable to get a consensus
of uh what actually is driving right the
tumors
so
so yeah i mean it's like studying the
wings right uh and saying that oh the
airplane just runs because of wings and
some people study the engine saying that
oh you know it runs because of engine
right
of course we know that it's both but uh
how do we study
both right without ripping the plane
apart right how do we really study uh
the entire structure right the
aerodynamics is not just an outcome of
just a wings or an engine alone right
the aerodynamics is determined by
the flow of the air and it's a process
right the dynamical process it's a
spatio temporal process and not uh not a
static thing that we could study by
ripping things apart right
so
uh these are the some of the things that
had uh
i have been thinking for a long time
and um that's when i hit upon the
system's biology and i've been thinking
about systems biology i've tried to
watch some videos and everywhere
when people talk about systems biology
there is not a
definition of it right people are saying
okay yeah i mean systems biology it's
tough to define right
so the the problem is because um let's
forget the systems biology for a moment
but the whole point of just studying
these mechanisms the biological
mechanisms is that the modern biology is
more or less reductionistic right we we
break it apart we study um hoping that
when we study these parts and try to put
together
we will get a uh understanding of the
entire mechanism right i mean it is like
saying that you have let's say that we
have a bunch of best cars in the world
right i mean one is good for let's say
a bmw as a best engine and a volvo
probably has the best transmission and
uh
say some other car has a you know a best
uh uh uh a best uh best battery or
something like that so when we are
trying to rip everything separately and
trying to organize something that we can
put together we will not even get an
automobile that's the unfortunate thing
we will be able to repeat apart we will
be able to study
but putting it together
is not it's
possibly impossible
so so the divide and conquer approach
will not work when studying complex
systems it's really biological systems
um
and uh especially cancer right cancer is
a very complex and adaptive uh
it's an evolutionary mechanism the
things constantly the dividing cells
constantly adapt to their environment
and so it becomes uh it's it's a it's an
adaptive system and so it it's it's it's
we we will not be able to put together
and study how the mechanism works in
real time right
so when we think about how reductionism
works it is like a relational database
right i mean we break things into tables
and we study each tables right and then
we hope to do some joins
and uh understanding okay so i'm going
to join this table x table x with table
y
uh using some primary key or foreign key
and hoping to understand table x and
table y together right i mean these
joints are made out of inference it is
like a reductionism so you can actually
think about reductionism as a relational
database but but this is not going to
work because putting it together it's
just an interpretation at some point
right it's not going to reveal an answer
by itself so we need an integrative
paradigm
which is known as a systems approach
systems approach is putting things
together and studying it in a very
comprehensive fashion
whether are we ready there yet whether
or we
do we know how the mechanism works by
integration that's something that's the
biology of the future
but the the right approach would be to
actually put things together to see that
what makes sense and what doesn't make
sense uh the systems approach is
characterized by a simple thing the
whole is not the sum of its parts so
that that's a that's the key um sentence
that defines systems biology so the
whole the entire picture that you see is
not going to be the sum of the parts
because the interaction between the
parts matters as much as the paths
themselves without the interaction
between the parts the part doesn't make
any sense whatsoever so that is the
entire idea behind systems biology
so how do we
then define it right so i was looking
into the
uh
the the definitions of systems biology
and i came into this uh institute for
systems biology and uh they
they have this model that they say that
okay you have the technology and then
new technologies give rise to new data
and the new data give rise to new
software and then out of that doing some
bioinformatics we form new hypothesis
and then the bio hypothesis will gain
rise to new insights and then new
biological questions this is a cycle
life cycle of
technology computation and biology that
defines uh systems biology but but this
is not true
because uh you know it's an integrative
technology that defines systems biology
the integration like i said the whole is
not the sum of the parts systems biology
and complex adaptive systems
are defined by uh the integration and
when you when you look at it it's just
the technology just doing some next
generation sequencing or
any of these it's not going to be
you know imaging is not going to
define systems biology all we will get
is a bunch of data and of course we can
do bioinformatics with a bunch of data
and then try to answer some questions
but that is not what systems biology is
so um
with this uh we started to and trying to
think about
uh uh the goal of the project so i
started thinking about okay what it
makes sense but i'm going to before i go
into the details of
what it how we can really identify
system biology and how what it has to do
with bioinformatics right
uh start uh let's uh was thinking of
doing a project actually to define uh to
really showcase what it is right so the
goal of the project is creating a
unifying computational framework so it's
a computational framework and we want to
integrate all available patient data
okay so we have uh we have the tumor
recurrence data the primary data and the
recurrence data and so we want to
integrate all of them um and then in an
unbiased manner
for actionable target validation and
predicting disease outcomes so that's
the in the idea behind the project that
we
initiated at uh
uh at md anderson cancer center when i
joined i want to start the systems
biology initiative for brain tumors and
the key thing is about integration right
it's it's an integrative technology that
we have to use here
so why brain tumors um of course it has
been my expertise for a long time
um
for about 10 years i've been involved in
brain tumor research both in
neurosurgery and neuro oncology in
neurosurgery i hold a joint appointment
there so in general i have been studying
brain tumors a lot
and so that was natural for me to do
this
systems uh cancer systems biology
in glioma so gliomas or in general the
nervous system neoplasms that uh that
that is derived from epithelial cells
in general the differentiation or
classification is by glial cell types
right i mean usually uh the brain cells
if you take that on neurons that are
astrocytes oligodendrocytes and
epinephrines
so
in general the gliomas arise from glial
cells and it constitutes about 30
percent of all central nervous system
tumors
and uh in fact in particular if we look
at the brain tumors we have about 70
percent of them um of them are brain
tumors or gliomas so they are divided
into two major categories the low grade
glioma and the high grade glioma
usually the low grade gliomas are grade
213 which largely consists of
astrocytomas uh oligodendroglioma
and then grade four which is a high
grade tumor it's usually known as a
glioblastoma it's one of the most lethal
cancers uh people died in about 14
invariably they die in 14 months it's
it's it's a very aggressive cubers and
uh no cure has been i mean or no um
reasonable progress has been made on
gliomas on glioblastoma for the last 40
50 years despite
there are little progress in terms of
chemotherapy and stuff like that
there's not been much progress on that
right
so we not um and then the tcga that the
cancer genome atlas started with
understanding of glioblastoma as one of
the key projects in there
and so they we know quite a lot about
molecular biology of clear mass from a
dna rna and 14 and epigenetic levels
right we know a lot through the
sequencing doing bioinformatics
we have tons and tons of data now in
pcga on glioblastoma right but then the
problem is that uh people invariably
record right even though they are given
chemotherapy at some point
uh they they get the tumors again
and so uh
and so uh we we really don't know about
what happens how the uh how the relapse
happens and so we start they should
little
know little is known about
tumor uh primary tumor and recurrence
about progression resistance metastasis
and so many other things so that's why
there is something called glamour glass
con glioma analysis consortium called
the glass consortium was formed to
understand glioma from a recurrence and
uh and a progression perspective
and so uh the glass aims to perform a
comprehensive molecular qualifying uh
profiling of uh maths primary and recon
tumors from thousand five hundred
patients
and so this consortium includes
investigators from fourteen uh academic
hospitals and universities md anderson
is one of the core sites
in for this
glass consortium and uh this glass
consortium when i joined i'm a part of
the glass consortium it's led by
investigators in here so i thought the
best case
for defining a systems framework should
be to do a glass
use the glass data that has already
profiled tons of tumors both primary and
recurrent tumors and study how the tumor
progressions is happening in terms of
both bioinformatics and systems biology
perspective
so what we know about recurrent gliomas
is that the first published study they
analyzed about 222 patients with glioma
so they analyzed mutations copy numbers
across a variety of molecular subtypes
of glioma and there are three major
molecular subtypes of glioma one is idh
codal
idh non-codal and idx while type
so what we know about is that uh the
study also said that okay drivers genes
are initially selected and then they
were retained at recurrence but there is
little evidence of recurrent specific
alterations so most of them happen in
the primary stages
and these are some of the inference that
they have derived the alkaliting agents
introduce what is known as a
hypermutator phenotype
and then on employee abnormal number of
chromosomes is frequently detected in
recurrent gliomas
and then the clonal architecture of each
tumor remains similar over time
and no difference in the level of in
from the immune standpoint between
initial and recurrent tumors there is no
difference and these are the inferences
that was derived but the the thing is
that we have to understand these are
done jus just using the basic
bioinformatics they have not uh done any
data integration across several types of
data to understand glioma
recurrence in a very integrated fashion
right so that's the key
thing that we wanted to study again is
uh what is missing is that
the key thing is that
they are
what they have uh understood from doing
some rudimentary bioinformatics is that
it's it's it's largely stochastic right
but then we have to integrate gene
expression data we have to integrate
methylation data clinical data think
about the initial uh uh the elephant or
the blindman
slide right i mean we did something
separately we did gene expression
analysis separately we did dna um
mutation separately methylation
separately but then we have to put it
together to understand it and how do we
do that right that's the goal of the
project we wanted to create a unifying
again to reiterate uh what we wanted to
accomplish is that creating a unifying
computational framework to integrate all
available patient-centric human
recurrence data
to generate hypothesis in an unbiased
manner for target validation and
predicting disease outcomes so this is
the systems approach not the regular
traditional
individual bioinformatics approach right
so
so how do we do such an integration so
here comes the meat of the idea of how
are we going to integrate say very
disparate data let's say that gene
expression data
with mutation data or methylation data
with copy number data how are we going
to even integrate all of these things
right
so that's where what is known as graph
databases coming okay so you might all
have a known graph by graph you might
have meant a pie chart or some kind of a
pictorial representation but that is not
what a graph is from a mathematical
standpoint um it's it's a it's a name
for a network right uh it consists of
nodes and edges right
so in traditional databases you have
these uh separate tables and we are
trying to infer things together right so
you have mutations let's say you have a
copy number table and a methylation
table and you join them try to do some
um
understanding based on the biome the
mutations copy number and methylations
would be done so based on some
bioinformatics right i mean
there are mutation callers
or some pipeline git k pipeline and so
many other things right but then there
is
but then there is no explicit
relationships that are embedded into
these tables and so you have to infer
these things separately right but graph
databases the relationships are defined
right think about facebook think about
amazon think about all these things
right i mean how do they even work for
instance amazon you buy a product and
immediately says that okay this product
uh also uh what do you mean uh when you
buy this product people who bought this
product also had brought another product
so how do how do they infer that
in real time right people there is no
person sitting there and trying to
analyze your product and then try to
match up with other people's product who
also purchase the product right i mean
these relationships are already embedded
in here and so it's just a matter of
querying right there so the there is a
system already in place that has these
relationships defined and so it
immediately points out to the product
people who bought this also bought this
it's an association right those
associations are already mapped same
with things happens with facebook right
a friend of a friend friend is a
relationship between two people right so
when you have is a friend off can be
embedded so that it can be naturally
rendered in real time and similarly
happens with twitter and all so many new
technologies are just based on these
kinds of graphic graph databases
so
so the graph architecture the
integration is natural
and it's an unbiased analysis becomes
very very uh you know easy right
so all you need to do is define the
relationships and uh and so we can write
appropriate queries uh to answer that
right so is this idea new not really uh
if you think about this idea it's
already been one of the papers that was
actually a very
good paper in fact that was
key for me
to develop this is that uh they have
already done this in what is known as a
colorectal cancer they had these
mutations and that they have this
relationships defined
and then um they have tried to integrate
all these together using the graph
databases right and so
the problem with their model is that uh
they have to create additional
relationship for new data let's say that
you're introducing image data so they
have to introduce new uh
you know relationship type
and also
it results in restricted survival
analysis we will go over that a little
bit later
so uh the key so then there are problems
with the existing approach uh the key
attributes of the system that it should
be integrative you have to put in all
data that you can find and it has to be
unbiased
uh as well as uh it has to be absolute
in time uh so these are the three
characteristics of the system that we
have to develop
and so uh
so that i was thinking about it and the
idea is very simple so you have two
molecular events and you connect them
saying that if there are patients who
undergo those events
then that forms a relationship so the
patients are the relationships in our
model right so in our database there is
this basic representation there are
these molecular events
and you connect them if they are
if there are more than one patient who
undergoes those two molecular events
right
so with that we built this graph
database where we were able to integrate
copy numbers where we were able to
integrate methylation mutation
expression
and if you are having imaging we can
integrate whatever data that you can get
we can actually put them in this
database so this is in this database we
call it as graph engine for systems
medicine or otherwise genome in this
database they have an intel in this
database it's all it's an integrative
database
and so we would be able to uh query
anything that we want right um
so there are 370 patients in this
database so far about 11k nodes and 16
million relationships and this is the
venn diagram of how the distribution of
the data looks like
so why bioinformatics critical now that
comes to the critical question for this
right so like i said garbage in
garbage out
right i mean it depends on how you
define the system and it's it's very
important when you are constructing such
a systems biology approach it's it makes
sense that we have to make sure that we
really put in all the things that are
important right so we make sure there is
a good bioinformatics uh that is built
uh in in
in in developing the system so for
instance uh identifying mutations right
we identify key driver mutation so there
is a pipeline already
we have alignment and a gatk variant
calling and then we do the driver
passenger analysis and do the mutation
uh non-driver passenger mutations and
then we upload it into the database so
it's important otherwise
it's all garbage there's going to be
millions and millions of data points so
this is where the bioinformatics is
critical before it's the next
the whole systems approach is uh the
downstream of bioinformatics that's
critical to understand and there is
secondly um there is this patience there
is another filter in there it's
determined by the number of patients who
undergo the molecular events and also we
have a robust statistics and connected
events as another filter and then we do
a random walk and survival correlation
so these graph databases have a survival
correlation so like i said right two
events are connected by patients so a
patient a trajectory a could be
different from patient trajectory b
could be different from patient
relatively c so they will have different
types of survival
so in general we could enumerate all
type of paths that's going to give
different survival but that's going to
be extremely hard problem it's an mp
complete problem in computer science so
we will not be able to do that so what
we do is that we simulate a random walk
random walk is like uh how many you know
it's just a tossing the coin so if it's
like you know say there are six parts in
here
if you throw a die and if it says five
you take part number five etcetera
etcetera so in general we would be able
to simulate a random walk
and then uh do the survival correlation
so for instance in this one of the walks
in here we have the path number 51 and
path number 54 right they show the
survival difference between the patients
and what you see is a bunch of
different biomarkers or
genes that's a combination right it's
not just a combination of me it's just
as mutations or copy numbers it's a
combination of this that gives the
difference in survival so in this way we
would be able to determine the survival
of patients
and this is another random walk
simulation too so we have these two
parts which show completely different
survival times
uh this is random walk three for another
specific type of glioma where we see the
survival difference between the patients
for path number 16 patients who take
that path and patients who don't take
that path
so the power of this approach we have
identified several functionally
important genes for conducting
biological experiments so for instance
there is a recent study that says that
uh glutamine synaptic signaling is
important reel in signaling so we have
identified all of these things
uh in general right this provides a
strong framework for systems biology
paradigm in medicine um it's it's
patient driven then patient property is
given it's truly unbiased and
integrative it's not subject to time as
long as there are patients we are going
to have this
framework and it's correlating with
survival combining multiple parkers has
not been attempted so um
so with that uh i would like to
the and the acknowledge i have got the
patients and their families uh my
student uh phd students he has been
actively developing the database
uh dr hughes puduvali uh and then dr
lang a neurosurgery chair and neuro
oncology chair they provided and they
were in support of course
my senior vice president and cto of md
anderson um he used uh he he was like
totally in sync with these ideas and
helped me helped us
in providing all the support in here
moonshot gave us the funding brain tumor
center gave the resources
of course the database supported md
anderson and the id staff we were
available anytime that we wanted to go
and have some problems and of course
this was done on neo4j neo4j team
rob martin fannie and greg shirley they
were
critical in providing the neo4j for us
in developing this system
so with that uh i would like to end my
talk um and
open the flow for questions
very good thank you thank you doctor uh
we do have several questions if you want
to go ahead and pull your uh screen off
we can just see you in instead
so one of the questions is yeah we'll
even make you uh
get me off the bottom here we don't well
yeah we there we go
so
is the database you're describing be
being used by clinicians right now
yes they have been
utilized by clinicians uh we are testing
out
certain biomarkers that were derived out
of this database yes
okay fascinating so how important is it
for a clinician to be aware of the data
analysis methods to use it properly
uh well uh we wouldn't expect too much
uh inside i mean for clinicians to
understand the database and the queries
which we will handle
uh all i think now what we would expect
for the clinicians to know is that we
can provide some actionable targets and
for them if they understand a little bit
of biology to see that what makes sense
and what doesn't make sense for them to
conduct some biological experiments i
think that would be fantastic
okay it's probably really important to
know where and how the data was
accumulated so they can use it properly
is that right
yes of course yeah yeah i mean yeah so
we have to develop systems like systems
like this for each and disease types
yeah
thank you do you see any challenges that
need to be addressed to integrate data
when it does not come from the exact
same patient but rather different
individuals
oh yeah i mean this database is about
different individuals right it's about
population so it's not just one patient
we have about 370 patients in our
database
uh data that we are integrating so yeah
any type of data any type of patients we
should be able to integrate this
database using this approach well thank
you thank you for your remarkable work
that you're doing with cancer i i loved
all the metaphors throughout the the
elephant and all that that's that's
pretty good stuff
we're going to ask you to stay on and
join your fellow presenters from this
session for a panel review so if we can
get all of our panels to be coming back
on i first want to remind the audience
to register at learnomicslogic.com
learn or slash projects for your free
learning portal account and if you
forgot earlier i'd like to encourage you
to do that now i'll put the link in the
chat box here so everyone can see it
if i get the setting right here we go
so you can make sure you get there and
click on the register free button so if
you can all do that that would be great
and we need to find sarah to bring her
back in so sarah if you're out there if
you can come back in we'd appreciate
that
and i think we're ready to roll so
gentlemen and ladies and gentlemen there
we go there she is uh we've got dr
akashiri kanan associate professor at
translational molecular pathology that
we just heard from dr sarah zappico an
assistant professor in the department of
chemistry and environmental sciences at
njit
mr elia brody ceo of pine tech bio in
new orleans and dr oskalov who we heard
of from earlier senior bioinformatician
at the department of biology lund
university sweden and the science for
life laboratory
ladies and gentlemen the first thing
unfascinated to know is how and when you
decided to get into this broad field and
of course
your current niche and i'm going to call
your name elia let's start with you
thank you yeah so um
i guess uh you know i
came to this field
uh just because i was interested in how
uh data analysis could be applied you
know more in a more applied way you know
and more biomedical research kind of
application so i think that's the major
role in
um you know we we talked about how
this is being used you know to treat
cancer to uh study uh different
important things that i think are really
much more concerning than you know where
um a lot of things
in data science are being you know used
like marketing or something like that so
it seems like a much more compelling
reason
to apply these skills to these kinds of
data sets
cool
sarah
i really realized yeah i was weird
well yes in terms of forensic science as
i said before i always wanted to be a
forensic scientist uh
so i switched
after my phd
so the obligate particularly the
application of this technology is
because i see
the potential for the field in terms of
uh for example in challenging samples
identification of human remains i'm sure
that
although they are not
as you seem as everyday
needs but
uh
i hope in the future we can use in a
regular basis so for example the
phenotyping uh you know it would be
really helpful to
identify human remains which i
i mainly what i do
and yeah other things and for example in
there's a postmortem interval as well uh
we have a really a need for technologies
and i think based on our preview
research that is what we need apply
these technologies
uh just an observation before we go on
grant i just noticed that you know we
had people here that dealt from
childhood cancer right so all the way to
kind of post
mortem uh
studies so it's kind of interesting but
there is a distinct difference right so
there is
applied
and then there's research
so maybe as you describe your you know
how you got to this maybe you could
mention so i understand sarah you're
mostly doing research with this right
it's not actually being used
yes i am your research right now uh for
the moment it's not applied yet to the
field so with my some research
what i did in
age estimation
we were able to apply to one or two
cases but again it's difficult because
of the legal problems
basically and also it depends uh for
example when i talk about phenotyping
uh
for example in new york it's really
difficult to apply in cases to determine
for example who was the physical
characteristics of the perpetrator
so
for the big thing is different but still
you need to ask for permissions etc so
here also the problem is legal issues in
terms of
with the genetic genealogy although you
are
i am sure you heard about a lot
uh
you have still to uh
ask for permission to use genetic
analogy and at the end again you need to
do the str's
definitely any profile so
yeah the problem right now is
the actual application cases but slowly
uh we are trying to do it so
so yes this is our main intentions
fascinating absolutely fascinating thank
you sarah nikolay
you're muted
oh is he a co-host or maybe
there we go
yes sorry uh i think it was so i was
trying to unmute myself
um yeah so i'm uh originally from from
physics uh and um yeah this field i i
guess uh you mean how i moved to this
field broadly speaking to life sciences
i met
medical doctors clinicians who showed me
their data and i got fascinated by the
amount of open questions
basically compared to physics i would
say
you feel in life sciences and biology in
biomedicine you feel like a child in a
candy shop
there are very many questions um in
physics you kind of have a stable
knowledge
uh accumulated over many many
ages basically
in in life sciences it feels differently
there is very little well-established
knowledge which is good for researchers
because it's uh we are curious
we want to know something uh
new um
but maybe
it's not good from the point of view of
patience because we would like to have
more knowledge
of course and help them
um
[Music]
okay thank you thank you much uh dr
cannon we'll come back to you
uh well i mean like i said i was in a
medical research institute where
i was doing some core microscopy and
then
i mean i've been a computer scientist so
in a biology
biology institute
so i think it was a logical
uh destination for me
uh you know to do some bioinformatics
and most of the bioinformatics that
i did was i learned ad hoc i did not
have any formal training per se
it's like
trying to i was like i'm very curious uh
to know and to understand so
so most of it is like trying it out and
seeing what it is and stuff like that
and initially you have no idea of what
the file formats are even when i was
introduced to sam and bam files and
things like that so but most of the
stuff is like uh for me is about being
curious and trying to figure out right i
mean like using computers i mean the
terminal was at hand the tools are there
i mean nothing really stops me from
identifying or you know doing
discovering stuffs on my own so
uh you know
i learned it on the fly i would say and
it's
yeah very cool very cool
we want to touch on careers in
bioinformatics and data science so
open this up to the group to discuss as
you will how bioinformatics is
revolutionized research
what skill sets are required for
students to excel in these fields
bioinformatics and data science
yeah so maybe i can briefly start
you know i think what is interesting to
see is that there is
this diverse range of data types and
approaches also depending on where they
are used right so as we saw today maybe
in a clinical setting it is very useful
to have that population level of use of
databases and finding the connections
between clinical and omics data is very
important in other cases
i think that you know what was
explained by
nikolai is
very applicable to the type of data that
just is starting to be generated right
this is not some widely adopted
translational research that is being
described these are cutting edge
algorithms and methods that still need
to be developed and validated i would
say right so so i think that depending
which direction you go
bioinformatics is becoming one of those
domains like data science that becomes
you know it diverges like a tree into
many different domains so knowing where
you're going with this are you going to
go to clinical research are you going to
industry
a completely different story or are you
going into research and then which area
of research i think really will
determine and help you understand what
kinds of skills but universally speaking
i think we can all agree that you know
coding databases these are going to be
your
tools
of the trade and so you should excel and
and know how to do that and depending on
whether you're a developer versus user
that's also going to determine how much
of math and and statistics and kind of
the underlying algorithms you would need
to understand and you know potentially
develop on your own
who else would like to jump in on that
okay let me jump in on that if uh
that's okay so one of the things is that
i feel that math and not math forget
mathematics but statistics and computing
right those are the essential skills
that i think every high school student
needs to learn because the applications
are enormous so you can get into any
field that you want
so
fundamentally if you are
learning statistics and programming uh
whatever type of programming i think
those are critical
um that we can build upon um biology or
bioinformatics for that matter right i
mean if we chose to focus our efforts of
programming and statistics in biology it
becomes bioinformatics naturally
so
those are the critical skills i think
any aspiring bioinformatician or should
have or any anyone for that matter
should have
and the second uh point that i would
like to
focus on is actually network science
learning some network science i mean we
know that uh the data are integrally
connected and the world is getting
connected more and more so
learning some network science will go a
long way uh in in in applying the
bioinformatics learned bioinformatics
into useful into clinical practice
so i think uh these are the key
two main things that probably um
that people should be focusing on uh
statistics and programming and the
second is network science
interesting
nicolae or sarah
you all can just stay unmuted if it's
easier for you you don't have to keep
muting it's up to you
sarah go ahead if you got your mute
button ready okay
yeah i wonder
so actually uh it
gives me my point of view i was a
student
for biotech as you know so i learned a
lot i mean again uh you can be
a developer or a user so i think
depending on uh
what you want to learn or what you want
to apply you can be simply a user i mean
uh
is what i am uh learning from uh these
courses so
yeah i think uh the skills again uh
one of the important things at least for
me when i choose the students is that
they're interested i'm going to learn at
the end it's the most important thing
and you can learn everything
if you are interested in in the subject
so so yeah
not so much helpful but i think yeah
this is the point of our researcher that
uh i am mostly a user in this uh
bioinformatics stuff
alkaline
uh yes uh so what skills are important
um yeah i would say
three types of skills uh biology
understanding of biology uh programming
skills and mathematical background is
also good to have uh yeah i i basically
see
uh maybe i would say two types of
bioinformaticians it can be biologists
not having a wet lab background who
learned uh computing
uh who learned programming and
math to some extent and there are also
computer scientists who come from from
different
angles so they they can do linear
algebra maybe but they not really
understand and cell biology
and the both i think can be learned so
basically people with mathematical
background can can learn biology to some
extent and people from biological
background they can learn must to some
extent
so i think uh um
but but uh talking about lund university
i would say we still have a
lack of
bioinformatics training uh so
maybe because bioinformatics is still
it's a new discipline
so maybe there will be more um
bioinformaticians but we are kind of
still uh
still there is no formal training in
bioinformatics as i said it's either
biologists who learn
maths and programming or computer
scientists who learn biology but that
there is no like a separate education
and bioinformatics unfortunately
maybe to uh just pick up on that i think
what we heard both from kasturi and from
maybe sarah as well is you know
not always is it about those technical
skills right sometimes it's that
curiosity that need in your project that
really brings you to the point of
learning and mastering a skill that you
needed at the point at the moment and
maybe another perspective on this
bioinformatics is a very diverse field
so
it
has changed significantly today we heard
about how it's continuing to change and
we know that the the pace of the change
is just going to increase and so so i
think that's another component right you
have to be driven by your ability to
be curious find answers but also
overcome challenges and that i think is
the reason why you need the algorithmic
perspective as well is you need to be
not only solving challenge like a
tutorial that somebody gave you but
really trying to kind of solve the
challenge maybe in a new way thinking
out of the box
you're muted grant
sorry about that what would you say to a
chemist trying to join the trade that's
from chat
nikolay since you were already up let's
let you take that one you start in on
that one what would you say to a chemist
coming into the trade
yeah i've seen
people with chemical
background with the background in
chemistry i think they uh have a
relatively smooth
path to
biology wetlabs because they know all
the routines and they have similar i
would say similar standards
um um i i mean it's not uncommon i think
uh chemists who
start doing protein research
i've seen many
people
who moved who migrated from from
chemistry to
biology and computational uh i think in
chemistry there is uh
i mean they the these guys uh
they have a good education and um
i don't know quantum chemistry so it
means they they
they understand um
some computer they they do have um
good skills in uh they should
in my understanding they should have
good skills in computational work so i
see
no problems
for
chemists
migrating to
to bioinformatics
let's switch over to what job
opportunities and internships for
students and researchers there might be
and sarah i think did you have a job
available or something like that if you
did we'll start with you and then we'll
hit the rest of the group
yes actually i have a postdoctoral
position
in principle for a bioinformatician but
i am open to
biologists uh biochemists uh that are
familiar with the this data personally
because we are going with the different
programs i have right now and we are
going to work a lot with omics uh for
the moment with
um
transcriptomic some metagenomics
so yes someone who
knows how to analyze this data so it
doesn't need to be a bioinformatician
but at least a biologist biochemist who
knows
how to uh deal with this data so
yeah the the post yeah i think yeah it's
already great i think elia just posted
the link so thank you for that
more generally uh what do you think guys
job opportunities internships for
students and researchers
well okay maybe i can jump in here and
just say that
i think it's very critical for people
the students to have opportunities to
intern and maybe even for free
participate in a project right because
many times when you are taught
bioinformatics in a very standard way
you don't have the opportunity to see
the project as a whole and really know
how useful your work is so i think
internships and and especially
mentorship are critical so
um i know that uh kasturi you know you
do a lot of mentorship i think we also
spoke with nikolai you you do some
mentorship as well i mean maybe you can
add on to this how does this actually
work in your organization you know is
there a process do you see
um you know where it's very critical at
what stage of that learning process are
these uh
is that a critical component
kasturi do you want to
yeah so uh i mean one of the things that
we are trying to do here is links
talk uh analysis uh and then it's
important for them right
nikolai i think you were uh on mute for
a while and kasturi started speaking at
that time
i'm sorry sorry go ahead
no worries
oh okay
i mean i think uh you know one of the
key things that i find it challenging i
mean in terms of uh
you know as you saw that we are
developing this systems framework which
is heavily dependent on bioinformatics
and uh of course i'm
mentoring uh
high school students as well as the key
thing is that uh sustained effort is
critical right i mean on this uh you
know learning some bioinformatics i mean
there are opportunities uh very good
opportunities especially uh this
research that we are doing is actually
translational it's directly impacting
patients lives in here
and so uh uh
you know that is uh there are these
challenges uh which i say that you know
it's it's about like uh
uh
getting to uh you know like you you
exactly pointed out right i mean it's
not just about trying to learn but also
uh navigating the difficulties that are
you know on the way right i mean having
some troubleshooting the errors and
persistently doing that so i mean i
think uh these are critical skills that
are needed for any anybody but then yeah
we are
we are training people in there and so
yeah our program is expanding so what
was the critical key question in this uh
whether uh
i think i'm missing the point here what
what were you asking trying to ask
what what the job opportunities and
internships for students and researchers
might be either specifically with your
organization or generally
yeah so uh you know as as this program
expands obviously there is going to be
as i see the future is going to be more
uh systems oriented and already there is
something called a breakthrough cancer
foundation that has announced uh you
know about 100 million dollars for uh
you know integrating data and data
integration and these are going to be
the key uh future prospects so
i think uh
you know um
if if students uh can get trained on
this aspect of bioinformatics where they
could all not just learn how to do just
the pipeline alone but how to integrate
together to have a meaningful patient
driven systems
then uh you know combining with the
databases like the graph databases the
cipher query language i mean cipher in
the neo4j has been like uh peop i am
seeing there are lots and lots of
opportunities that are coming not only
in the bioinformatics space but outside
that are requiring this graph databases
knowledge
so i think those combinations will go a
long way in securing a good uh you know
internship and job opportunities for
students
right nikolai
yeah uh so within our organization the
national bioinformatics infrastructure
sweden we have a
bioinformatics advisory program so all
phd students in sweden and swedish
academic
institutions they can
have a bioinformatician a senior
bioinformatician as a mentor and that's
very important so i found it uh very
important
for for for the pg students because very
often
those guys
they come from from um
they don't have uh
a good environment uh uh don't have a
critical concentration of people who can
talk analysis
and they they need to discuss um
analytical tricks with uh with um uh
with analysts
um and uh sometimes i i see that people
are sitting in the clinics uh they're
embedded into
into this
clinical environment but they want to do
analysis and then
for them talking to
other analysts this is absolutely
critical and this what we are trying to
to help them with with this
bioinformatics advisor program so it is
very critical to interact
uh with other people who are doing
analysis
fascinating that's really cool stuff
that's a nice nice program i want to ask
how the interdisciplinary fields are
integrated with multi-omics if you guys
want to pick that one up
well i was actually surprised to hear
about the way that there is using uh
multi-aeronautics i i think so here we
have three different ways that
multi-omics was described right sarah
was talking about just
using different omics to estimate the
same parameter
and then kasturi was talking about
building a database that has those
connections between clinical and maybe
multi-onyx and then nikolai was actually
talking about integrating them to see
the same experiment but just from
different perspectives and so i think
these are very unique different types of
challenges but
i mean
maybe it's a question whether multiomics
is a must
is it
just something that happened to uh
appear or is this something that is
going to be
like a replacement of a single omics i
mean
what does everyone think about this
if i may go answering that i mean i
think it's a natural thing right i mean
whether we have to subscribe to
the single uh you know like i said right
i mean it's about protectionism versus
systems i mean directionism is not going
to go the same studying single omics is
going to be there there are lots of
things to uncover for instance doing
single cell sequencing i mean this is
about
on a single cell level right i mean so
it's it's not it integrated with a bulk
population level so that's that's there
but then if you want to understand uh in
a very population-centric way how we can
put together to have understanding uh
you know you know in a holistic fashion
then obviously multi-omix is the way to
go i mean it's ultimately uh the
difference in the philosophy whether you
know whether we are going to go
reductionistic or whether we are going
to
subscribe to systems i mean from our uh
40 years or 60 years of uh you know uh
decades of
experience still we have not yet gone to
a place where things could be translated
to an actionable you know
where it can
benefit a large class of population so
if you ask me i would um i would uh
uh you know i would place my bets on
systems biology so multiomics
uh you know is a way to go you know in
terms of understanding and in fact
translating the the biology to practice
anyone else
all right let's look at some of the
strategies this is the next question
that's come up um
the strategies to evolve and involve
students in bioinformatics and data
science what kind of strategies do we
need to approach
and maybe before we jump into that sorry
but i see ryan uh here has a good
question in the chat what are your
thoughts
on the interact tone and study the
integrative cell biology so i think it's
a little bit
um close to what nikolai was describing
in his talk
i don't know if you want to answer that
um
um
yeah so by interrupt tom um
uh i think yes talking about
maybe by interact tom ryan
sort of network analysis and
the graphs that i was showing um
those were graphs uh
where each node was
one cell
or one sample one patient
uh
by interact on people
typically mean a different thing um they
they mean um maybe it's proteins then
the nodes of the graphs are
the the features
and
so i i think it's not exactly what i was
showing because
um my graphs they looked a little bit
uh differently exactly to drive network
medicine yes this is what ryan is asking
um
uh i think it's a a slightly different
focus um
how features interact and how how how
they're linked
um
how they cluster
basically as i said
in the talk you have two dimensions in
your data metrics and you can
do cluster analysis and
look at the links between your
statistical observations patients
samples
or you can do
cluster analysis and look at the linkage
between
your features i mean it's two sort of
sides
[Music]
so i i'm doing maybe more one thing than
the other
so i'm not very much into the interact
home uh
but uh
it's uh
basically yes it is another way of
looking at the data and very interesting
way so i
so so i think that maybe you know since
we are coming to a close i i just want
to maybe spend a few more minutes i
think nikolai
um you know mentioned this aspect of you
know you can look at either you know
cells or you can look at
a lot of robustness
interact i think nikolai sorry i
interrupted you because you were on mute
again
but
um
you
mentioned how
uh you know the
cell biology right is important here
because you are studying cell biology
ultimately by looking at these different
aspects i mean how far away is that
disconnected from then understanding how
those different features are linked you
know let's say the cell develops into a
certain phenotype there's some sort of a
you know
separation of these different cell types
do you look at all at what defines that
cell type afterwards i mean you must be
looking at what genes right or what
methylation pattern so so that there is
kind of like a way to go further into
understanding how those clusters are
formed and what defines them right
uh yes so uh first of all uh you you can
hear me because i think i i get muted
and unmuted randomly and it's not
uh yes
yes so you were asking about uh looking
at the mechanism so if you see cells uh
clustering uh if you see cells clusters
uh you yes you would like to understand
the
um what
biological molecules drive this
clustering of the cells
and if you have the molecular
uh information
from the cells yes you definitely uh
want to interpret this clustering so
it's a it's a
it's a little bit like looking inside
your machine learning model so your
machine learning model can can maybe
find these clusters but then you want to
understand why
uh
it's a next natural question um
because you want to get a deep
understanding not just see the clusters
but
to understand what they mean um and
um
yes if you have the molecular type of
information from the cells you you
definitely can um can look inside the
model and understand why
i hope this is what you're asking about
but and i think that you know the next
part of what he is asking the network
medicine that's exactly what kasturi was
uh talking about actually sort of right
so so i guess uh you know as we are
wrapping this up
um
you know how do how do these things can
where do they connect you know on one
side we have you know single cell
techniques that generate multinomics
data and we need to go deeper into that
data to really understand what does this
mean biologically and all the way to
population health level you know to try
to identify patients that are very
different individuals
that maybe also
will benefit from identifying these
unique clusters of cells that might
drive metastasis or something like this
right so i mean where do these things
converge i guess
uh okay
can i answer this question or do you
want me to
okay i mean i i think this is uh i mean
this is where i think uh you know on
like you exactly pointed out uh the the
cell
uh level you have these two levels on
one hand you have the population and you
on one hand you have this uh single cell
level right obviously they have to
intersect and the model that
probably that will integrate is again
going to be a graph model where
we can actually uh integrate the tables
for instance that has these
you know specifics of cell like patients
who have those specific algorithms i
mean these could be modeled based on the
graph databases i mean as i see it it's
not going to be such a huge problem
right now the problem is that we are
like trying trying to think these
networks are totally
different and not looking at a database
level but less looking at the just how
these connections are from a basic
network level right i mean even in
network there's a difference between
network
biology and systems biology right that
was my initial question whether like
okay why don't we call it as network
biology it's still a biology but why do
we have to call it as systems biology
unless
we have the power to integrate any type
of data that we want that the graph
databases provides us with such a
technology to do that right i mean it's
a very recent technology it's it's has a
basis on wonderful computer science
right i mean pointers and stuff like
that so
you know it can be integrated but i feel
that the integration will go in the
direction of graph databases and it
cannot be just thinking in things in
isolation
if you ask me
anyone else want to pick that up
okay
not seeing oh go ahead okay okay sorry
no because of the integration of uh
technologies i know this is a in a
completely different field you know uh
one of the things we are looking into is
the integration and combination of omics
for post-mortem internal estimation so
it's kind of uh what i think you are
meaning in terms of health
but uh in the application of forensic
science so i think also
the integration of the different omics
could help in that
nicolet any closing comments
uh yeah i i understood leah's question a
little bit differently
i was asking
nation population versus single cell and
uh i i know i heard this opinion that um
typically when we work with
single cell data it's just one
individual maybe
and then how does it generalize
on the population
and i think it's still early days
um we will eventually
uh
hopefully
uh reach this state that we can um
sort of uh utilize uh millions of cells
from from many many individuals um
um
sort of the question of generalization
of what what you discover on on one um
one particular sample um
it's still it is valid so maybe all the
conclusions
might not be generalizable
for the population
but uh
still it's
those are early days so we just want to
see the heterogeneity between cells and
usually it's consistent
between individuals at least the the
types of cells talking about maybe blood
cells they're more or less consistent
you see the same cell types from one
individual to another
but indeed there can be diseases where a
certain cell type looks strange and um
this is what we want to catch but the
more the more we sequence uh the more
data we have the the easier it will be
to to answer a question
very good
well i'm going to go ahead and close us
up we're at our ending time and i'm
going to put my closing in the chat box
also we want to make sure that we thank
our honored speakers today dr oskalov dr
julia panoff who was on earlier sarah
zappico dr lisa taraneko who was on
earlier luis sakamoto and elia brodsky
so we want to thank you all for being
here today and for contributing to this
fantastic
session be sure to join us tomorrow for
our second day of learning thinking and
being challenged by our amazing speakers
and one last reminder and it's in the
chat box to sign up now at the omix
logic sign up page click the register
for free button get your free account
and start learning
thank you all again we'll see you
tomorrow and yes the session was
recorded and will be available to those
who registered thanks again see you
tomorrow
and i want to mention to connor i know
that we didn't get to your question but
it's a whole another topic so maybe
we'll we'll pick that up tomorrow
very good thank you everyone thank you
all